foreign
[Music]
three two one here we go
foreign
[Music]
steps
there
everywhere
[Music]
remember
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
myself hello everyone this is your daily
dose of Internet
that's how I thought I win
[Music]
I'm gonna have to
do it
what's good Turtle Squad it's your boy
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
I'm gonna win this [__] thing oh baby
he has to move his brown man whoa whoa
you could do that I can't move your
crown man like that
they have this chest rabbit that's just
terrible oh
brilliant really hey move is a movement
isn't it smarter than the computer
welcome to podcast ladies and gentlemen
welcome ladies and gentlemen to day six
of pogchamps five the fifth edition of
the scintillating event featuring all
sorts of famous content creators
YouTubers twitch streamers and other
internet personalities I'm your host
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinsky and
alongside me today a pleasure to be
commentating with the one and only
Andrea botez good afternoon to you
Andrea are you excited for another Full
Slate of exciting matches this is
probably the most formal intro I've ever
had he used the big word I didn't even
know what it meant but I am very excited
today we're gonna have a whole party not
only are we blessed with the presence of
the Prophet but we also have Danny
joining us later
um and also Donya just so you know Danny
calls me Grandmaster botez
um so you know if the creator of Chess
does it it's it's very legit you should
too if Danny wrench does it I gotta
follow his act yeah Danny will be
commentating the last two matches so
you'll get all sorts of Daniels
commentating with you today and area but
we're gonna get all sorts of matches and
players playing today because we've got
a very heated situation in some of the
groups the participants are divided
between four groups you can see the
standings there with Gastly winning a
huge match yesterday in Group B that was
amazing Andrea even though I know you
trained with virtual I think his
opponent who will be trying for
Redemption today in tyler1 and Group C
xqc raising the ranks there with a
victory at the end of yesterday as well
so many interesting story lines Andrea
as we look at these standings
I have two star students they're gonna
have to face each other soon I'm not
happy about that xqc calling out tyler1
yesterday definitely a top highlight I
think this is one of the most weighted
matches it's coming soon but xcc just
kind of killed his competition yesterday
we're gonna see if he's gonna do the
same today
um not today I mean in another day but
wait no today yes today it's today sorry
yeah he is he is playing at the end I
don't know you know but I think today is
the day
I think today is the day especially
given his performance yesterday let's go
through the matches the menu for today
first we have virtual against daily dose
of Internet unfortunately neither of
these players has a chance to make it
into the championship bracket but it
doesn't matter we're here for the fun
and virtual is here for Redemption that
is followed at 4 pm Eastern or so by
Germany's largest streamer pop of Platt
facing off against fousey who also seeks
her chance at Redemption after losing to
I did a thing yesterday then qut
Cinderella will play that very same
Australian Juggernaut streamer I did a
thing it was really really confident he
is tough to play he puts a lot of
pressure on you and then of course at 6
PM xqc against Ginny xqc talk about
confidence he is the picture of
confidence but that's not the end we
have another QT Cinderella match at 7 pm
and the second game second match for
fusely to round off the day at 7 pm
Eastern so if you have any meetings if
you have any dates if you have any
anything cancel it all because you will
not want to miss these five matches with
two Danny's Andrea there's something for
everybody today
yeah I have to say Cutie's debut is
today and I'm so looking forward to it
haven't seen her play chess in a while
but cutie has gotten very strong I heard
she's just beating Ludwig back to back
just kidding I just made that up I don't
know if that's true but I'm so excited
she's gonna bring the trash talk heat
um there's gonna be a ton of great
matches xqc versus the queen of twitch
Ginny we have I did a thing like you
said the Australian man who's literally
Not Afraid of Anything virtual who's
been training in Norway IRL lessons with
Anna kramling picking on daily dose who
you know he's beating us at everything
else in life but we hope daily dose is
going to win a game in this tournament
so far
yeah he is gonna have to give his
opponent a daily dose of nasty and his
opponent is virtual though before the
tournament one one of the pre-tournament
favorites over 1200 on chess.com but as
we've discussed many times you really
can't put too much stock into anybody's
rating in this tournament because
experience level how nervous someone is
so much more important virtual is the
YouTube's largest trackmania content
creator he's taken lessons with Anna
kramling but he's struggled with his
time management with his nerves and
Andre he's gonna have to harness that
experience in this tournament to play
better today and I think play just a
little bit more faster
yes exactly virtual unlike most
pogchem's competitors they're actually
very strategical and very good at
possession positional chess but that
benefits you a lot more longer time
controls where I have seen a few times
like you said where it kind of cracks
under the pressure in those tie Breakers
so we're gonna see if he's gonna speed
up the games today when when the moment
calls for it
indeed and his opponent it has yet to
win a match in POG gems daily dose of
Internet one of YouTube's biggest stars
over 60 million subscribers on YouTube
with his daily dose of Internet videos
the daily daily dose of Internet videos
I should say 7 billion views total I
mean this guy is Mr Beast level and he
competed in this tournament I forgot who
this tournament was named after it was
this bullet Invitational but I forgot it
no idea any ideas like a relative of
mine maybe a second cousin or something
but yes that makes sense he did play in
our bullet tournament
um but daily Joe's has a lot of
strengths actually and he's been
passionate about Chess for a long time
of course like most competitors he's
handling a lot he's traveling the world
he's running his YouTube channel but he
is still taking chess lessons he just
took some recent lessons with Nemo so I
really am running for daily dose today I
have to which isn't fair because
actually I read it against virtual last
time so I I should take that back
well daily dose you can see how upset he
is at uh I don't think how happy he is
he's not a we will be as usual listening
to both players virtual is streaming
daily dose is not streaming he's not a
twitch streamer but we can still listen
to him from time to time as he is known
to occasionally share his thoughts and I
think it's fun for both players they
know that there's nothing on the line
and I actually think that'll help
virtual I think he kind of got in his
head yesterday against Gastly there was
that crazy moment where Gastly put his
Queen on pre
virtual could have taken it that would
have ended the match instead he moved
his King ghastly saw it take took his
Queen and that ended the game how
heartbreaking is that
yeah I didn't hear I asked them about my
student about his match and he said that
virtual crushed his King's Indian had
very strong opening prep so Props to him
curious if he was doing some lessons or
if he just had a very strong opening but
he did not tell me that he had missed
aboutes Gambit he didn't report that
back so we'll have to have a chat about
that one
that reminds me when I used to send my
over the board games to my coach I would
sometimes change some of the moves to
you know just the Highlight to gloss
over some of the worst mistakes you know
there's a blunder here a blunder there
but I don't want to talk about it during
the lesson uh so no there were no Queens
blundered yesterday nobody saw anything
yeah okay good to know no one's in
trouble then
not at all so we've got this first match
daily dose of Internet against virtual
we're getting the players set up and the
game should begin momentarily and you
mentioned it virtual good positional
player and good opening preparation
yesterday's openings between ghastly and
virtual were some of the highest level
that we've seen across Pock jams like a
king's Indian defense we had a scotch we
were all over the map yesterday and
virtual is very well prepared good
coaching
yeah I was very curious if you did prep
but I have to say like this POG Champs
people have been raising the level I
think yesterday you got you should know
this number better than me xqc had like
90 accuracy more than that in both of
his games if I'm not mistaken
yeah I think that's correct
yeah that's that's pretty crazy and I
would never expect also I have to say I
did not prep gasly for any openings he
did all that on his own like he there's
six the seven hundreds are out there
studying their openings more than I do
so they're they're really putting in the
work indeed they are and he's gonna have
to show it because these matches they're
short two games a piece ten minutes plus
five second increment is your time
control 10 minutes per side every move
executed you get five seconds added to
your clock and in the event of a one one
tie well obviously we get a tiebreaker
Blitz game and the time control of that
game will be three minutes with a five
second increment and the tie Breakers
among the most nerve-wracking for both
of the players that's where the real
blunders come out it's when you've got
seconds on your clock you feel the
butterflies in your stomach so I think
virtual definitely hoping but he doesn't
feel any Deja Vu from yesterday's match
okay what are the odds we're ready to
begin the games it's gonna take us into
a tie breaker today
I think virtual is the heavy favorite so
I definitely have to be objective here
I'm gonna give it like a 70 30 odds okay
Underdog for sure but however this could
be a comeback he has got the SpongeBob
mug really anything could happen today
yeah
he's got his uh victuals nearby and a
van Cruise opening now is that a mouse
slip Andrea
this is the cow oh my God he's playing
it finally the day has come I'm not
kidding I spent a whole my Friday night
I was just prepping my student versus
the cow against virtual and then virtual
just never played it but he has been
saving it you don't know what the cow is
it's Anna kramling's famous opening and
I actually found the one weakness of why
it doesn't work but I don't know if
daily dose I should have should have
shared my prep with the world
so Andrea my association with the move
One E3 is the bunk loud I think that's
what most people associate that move I
remember Jan Christoph Duda played E3
King E2 against Hikaru in the cgc finals
but the cow correct me if I'm wrong
involves bringing the knights out to B3
and G3 is that right yes yes which looks
like black is just helping white with
the plan
um but exactly the knights go out to the
side and then the plan is to get one
small pun push break in the center
um okay he's just what what nights
well now it looks so I was gonna say the
one way to defeat the cow is actually
you punish the knights for that awkward
development and you push either your a
or H puns but he just traded off one
night so I have a feeling the cow is not
gonna be punished and virtual actually
has a very good score so far with the
cow opening I mean he has a nice he has
a nice position daily dose trying to
grab the cow by the horns but uh White's
got the bishop pair White's still got
that other Knight White's got one horn
on G3 and this Central Construction
engineer is very hard to break down it's
very tempting to start pushing all your
pawns up but then you get over extended
and you start blundering your pawns
let's see how virtual uh is
demonstrating his knowledge of the cow
can we tune into his stream for a little
let's hear him out
okay
[Music]
this is
there's one way to refute it but you
know what I'm gonna make a video on that
after the stream I think he is looking
to Castle as well it's all good by me
hoping I don't face virtual before I
watch that video play most of the time
but
I also like see right here the C Pawn
E4 probably a better idea than C4 in
these positions open up the dark squared
Bishop
them in the light squares
if he locks that's a little bit
we're gonna get a fast attack
I don't even know how white is oh wow
okay so he blunders upon here no that's
a good move or at least this is a trade
I don't get pushed out I don't know if
he intends to Castle my first king but
there's nothing I think I can play this
yeah there's a check with the white
Bishop on H5 I can't tell black and just
block it with his Pawn with G6 so if
you're virtual E4 F4 does look okay
actually stop the progress there
here
is a very annoying move to face that's
for sure
yeah kind of a five head move by daily
dose the SpongeBob cup is giving him
power and maybe here
pretty sure it's the top engine
recommendation so actually virtual kind
of struggling to figure out the right
so impressive that's amazing I didn't
even Castle push I would probably go
Knight
yeah he's strong this is what happened
yesterday Andrea where virtual really I
think yeah I think four minutes but I on
an early critical moment and then really
starts feeling the heat as they enter in
the middle game on his clock
I'm making the move that I believe in F4
is on the board stopping the progress of
blacks F Pawn
yeah that's my thought process
I never never thought the move
okay so now
there we go I was gonna say the beauty
of beginner chess is that daily dose
finds a move like F5 that I wouldn't
even consider that somehow is a top
engine move but because I'm so used to
principles like you know you don't want
to open your king and you don't want to
open the light squares you don't even
think about it but once again daily dose
found a beautiful refutation but virtual
is holding his feet very well
he is and Black's last move there Queen
C7 not a terrible move by any stretch
obviously he's protecting the E5 Pawn
but I would have probably pushed that
e-pawn one square further just to keep
the center closed and when the side that
has the bishop here often wants to open
up the center because when the center is
open it's easier to find good squares
for Bishops because there's more open
diagonals so if I'm virtual I'm taking
on E5 but all of this is on a very
positional level Andre this is not
what's going to decide the game
yeah I actually I love
Bailey's Castle this is nice this is a
potential file where there might be some
trading I'm
about um daily doses opening now and I I
know in Virtual I don't think he's going
to be inclined to take on E5 because I
think what he's used in this opening is
trying to keep the pressure keep the
pawns but
who knows E4 I was literally just gonna
say there's a crazy move where you can
just say I'm gonna Dynamite the center
I'm gonna blast it open and try to
punish black for not developing his
entire Queen side and then he played it
E4 is a lovely strike which I think
daily dose might really struggle with as
he pushes the Deep on forward we've got
a pawn Cube Andrea our first of
pogchamps
but do you think daily does blocking the
center here was the best Strat for him
probably not I'm afraid that after white
takes on E5 which I know you said
virtual sometimes errors on the side of
keeping the tension but I feel like
white is better equipped to deal with
the opening of the center and the King
side than black is because Black's got
all these pieces still asleep and uh
White's uh you know he might not finish
putting his pants on and White's already
gonna be crashing through on the f file
you know today I'm hearing all types of
new analogies that I've never heard
taking the cow by the Udders and the
pants I guess Dania really is a man of
culture I have a lot to learn from the
grand Masters
well thank you my analogies are utter
pandemonium and especially my puns
yeah wow virtual not holding back I mean
he's just gone that Queen C7 was so
unfortunate just kind of set black up to
lose all these tempos and now they're
really going to be behind in development
where the knight in the bishop by this
point in the game you don't want to have
this many pieces on the eighth rank
yeah it's moved 12 and it feels like
White's if it feels like you know like
when Lionel Messi is playing and it
seems like you've got more than 11 men
on the field when you don't develop your
faces messy it seems like well White's
messing up uh messing up Black's
position here feels like White's made
more moves than black has and daily dose
already sliding into a very problematic
position Bishop F4 was a really nice
move he takes F5 might come at a very
inconvenient moment Andrea so you've got
to be careful first of all move the
queen if you're daily dose okay step one
has been achieved
I this this works I was a little
concerned with the queen being on the
same file as The Rook but there's no
tactics in sight yet
yeah I don't see anything EF5 I guess
black plays Knight takes F5
yep no actually his development's pretty
good this is probably better than even
going and blocking his Bishop but I just
want to see daily dose able to develop
his pieces
yeah his next priority should be Knight
B to C6 if you're virtual
you can take on F5 and slide this Knight
over to a nice Square in the center 94.
he plays Rook C1 is he trying to open up
the queen side with C3 is that something
that you think might appeal to him
uh let's tune into virtual he was giving
us a commentary now he's silent but I
think this C3 might even give black a
little bit of opportunity maybe to open
those dark squares in the king so that
could be something that lets daily dose
get this opening position back
but does daily dose sense that his top
priority or his only priority is to get
those pieces out because one way or the
other the center is gonna open up and
there we go Knight bc6 I think he senses
the moment
okay let's tune into virtual I want to
see if he is looking for the C3 plan
let's hear it
okay yeah now big question interesting
move will white take on F5 when will he
release the tension and get himself that
E4 to go on with this plan for his
Knight
um
I realize now that just like what Dania
was saying that picking picking yeah the
actually would lead you into a pin but
it did the job it scared off virtual
from wanting to attack the queen because
it made it seem like it was defended but
there was definitely a tactic that made
it not work
yeah I mean I would grab this Pawn on
every move and just force black to make
a decision because if the G Pawn
recaptures as you're implying the Knight
can jump into H5 but virtual has his
eyes on the queen side he plays C takes
D4 now I'm imagining the black will take
with a pawn although taking with the
queen here deserves some attention as
well but that might drop upon after
Bishop E3 yeah he keeps the status quo
and how will virtual keep putting
pressure on Black's Position will he go
B4 and try to attack on the queen side
or will he in fact take on F5
shut up and I'm desperately trying to
find the tactic there's so many things
but I feel like like mustard
like can of worms and taking on F5
it absolutely does and you made a great
Point Andre I just think virtual has a
tendency to keep the tension he doesn't
like to you know kind of release the
tension in the center out of principle
so I really I feel like he's not even
thinking about taking on F5 and using
that x-ray down the f file to his
Advantage right it's actually very funny
because it's really opposite to most
people's instincts who are newer chess
because they want to take everything
they see and one thing my chess coach
would always tell me when I was getting
a little bit better was like keep the
pressure as much as you can don't trade
keep bringing all your pieces but in
this scenario he actually just needs to
trade but I think he also has to realize
this semi-open file where the Rook is
placed on F1 with the queen there it's
just it's a dynamite waiting to explode
dude I feel like we're watching like
Hikaru mvl here with how deep these
Queen side moves at b3a5 like I mean
yeah no it was kind of attacking on the
queen side come on Wow daily dose
holding down the fort very well there's
not it's very hard when you don't when
you finish your development to find a
plan to do but they're both just
incrementally taking a little bit of
space and this is a good Strat here well
maybe not for virtual but
another good move I love Bishop D6
because what are you doing you're
pinning the Knight I'm a broken record
but you are setting up he takes F5
because black what a daily dose he moves
his Rook out of the pin he's got really
good instincts about what needs to be
addressed in the position I like rook
fd8 and pointing out that virtual down
to four minutes but I think he he sees
it
should I did the sniper he has now lost
his Bishop pair which was a very
valuable asset and doing that he has
helped black unpin his Queen which has
removed a lot of the threat behind
taking on a five
that dark skirt Bishop was a huge piece
he's given it away what has he got under
turn I think he's winning a pawn though
Andrea GF Knight takes F5 he's got three
attackers on that pawn but this is a
really Advanced point after everything
is traded on F5 Black's Queen can slide
up to E3 force a queen trade and get a
monster pass Pawn on E3 if he sees that
move then daily dose will be very well
equipped in this end game but first
virtual has to realize that he can just
grab that pawn on F5 yep and he sees it
of course he has been built for these
tactics this is getting a little bit
scary for daily doses King is wide open
which like Dania says the best hope if
you want to play with an active King you
trade the Queens off the board so this
is a critical moment let's see okay well
still possible but now okay I'm still
okay dangerous territory
but the thing is if White NOW white can
trade Queens with Queen G5 and that is a
more favorable version of the end game
because in the queen E3 check end game
black would have this killer past Pawn
on E3 and the Knight could have jumped
into D4 now white can drop the Rook into
G5 can move the queen up and trade
queens or
the move that I think virtual is likely
to play is Rook C to F1 just keeping the
tension let's tune into virtual see how
he's looking at this critical position
big decision let's listen to his thought
process
maybe this yeah he's thinking about it
wow
wow this yep it's Chuck he's thinking
about it you can't look up The Rook he
can go here I don't think that's good
for him
does he see that that's a queen trade
I don't think he sees the trade I don't
think he's coming to the attack he just
thinks that's a check I don't think he's
he's
here I believe the queen wasn't defended
exactly
a daily dose okay
oh
well yeah take that kind of choice
almost like I can
win the piece but I don't we're gonna
get a very like balanced end game here
Andrea surprising it's a very tame no
yeah
isn't it okay only a pawn difference
pawns are weak and game is just a whole
different territory for this level
completely this is like something that
could be confused
for a super GM game like if someone told
me this is I don't know you know aronian
against gukesh from last year I would
believe you play Foster I also know yes
maybe this a lot of their games in fact
oh it looks a bit do you use one of them
uh oh he didn't see it and
but Rook F7 Rook F7 covers it enforces
the Rook trade has to find it otherwise
oh man oh man yeah virtual read just a
couple more tips in the chess book for
beginners because pigs on the seventh is
the most powerful thing right away if
you're not aware and you don't defend
it's fatal
Yasser sarawan was the first to
introduce me to that phrase Piggies on
the seventh refers to two Rooks on the
seventh rank but look at me look at
daily dose he's just gone to B4 and he's
captured the pawn on A2 so he's still
only down upon two and a half minutes
now for virtual as he goes after the a
pawn and another great move post night
let's go this is beaut I don't think
daily dose knows but he is doing the
same following the principles that night
on C3 is a monster defended by his own
book C5 wow that was the best move this
is amazing defending the pawn and
virtual's last move was a mistake
because look at that Bishop on F1 it's
got no prospects he should have put it
on F3 where it controls the most amount
of squares when you're in an end game
you don't have a lot of pieces left so
you want to make every piece work for
you I don't know about that trade though
oof yeah I was gonna say another Pro for
daily doses position is all this pieces
were on black squares once again making
that light squared Bishop pretty useless
but he doesn't take the Rook this is
good this this end game could go from
almost very much in virtual's favorite
to daily dose coming back and putting on
the pressure
both sides bringing their kings in Black
did have a check on F5 winning the oh no
it doesn't win the bishop
because after King G3 you can't take the
bishop you get skewered on f8 but will
daily dose even see the move Rook F5 no
he brings his King up to F5 instead good
thing he did good thing he didn't good
thing he didn't ignorance is bliss
that's exactly right that's so funny
like it's good that he didn't see yep
then he could win the bishop is very
good at playing fast solid moves once
again he's he's more than double his
opponent time and we know virtual is a
very strong positional player as we have
seen but where he struggles is under
time pressure daily dose is really
holding his wedding here it'll almost
come this is almost his game
white should create a pass Pawn on the
king side with G4 that is where his
extra Pawn is oh and this time he does
one with the bishop oh and he missed it
daily dose playing too fast he's got six
minutes on his clock take a moment
ignorance is bliss not Blitz but that
too Manitoba honestly
not bad not bad
all right round of applause now we're
leading a little bit astray but I and
the King coming backwards isn't the
worst thing what would you think is the
best beginner plan for either P like you
said for white to push G4 but what about
for black to defend because I think
right now he's done everything you could
do to activate his pieces and he's
starting to wander off this Trail
he is Wonder wandering off the although
that was the idea of Knight doing he's
getting the Knight onto a different
Outpost earlier I thought the black's
plan Andrea should be to attack this B3
pun the problem now is that white is
tied to this A5 phone so even if you go
Rook B5 and take B3 white will be able
to eliminate Black's pass spawn although
then D3 will be hanging so I would
definitely play them with Rook D5 to B5
here but look at virtual setting up a
discover check against black sync Bishop
H3 was an excellent move and maybe daily
dose should move his King out of the way
to make G5 harder to achieve no
three was of
a virtuous part and I'm glad daily dose
is taking his time currently
The Rook is defending G5 but it's not
doing anything we can't get that pawn
pushing he has to stop it uh can we turn
on daily doses audio
let me bring him in yeah does he realize
that he's starting to slip away he's
just holding his SpongeBob SpongeBob mug
and quietly talking but I don't know if
he senses all this Danger
just like his videos very calming
but he's still thinking
yeah he kind of just not knowing what to
do here and I don't know what he should
do because White's objectively close to
winning now because of the threat of G5
the threat of King F3 to E4 will
dislodge The Rook you're liable to lose
the D4 pawn and all of that happened
because Black's Knight on C3 was
actually a great piece it was
controlling the E4 Square he brought it
to a different Outpost and it's actually
a lot worse on E3 but there should be P5
my gosh literally not bad at all as
Donya was going yes would be five take
B3 take D3 pulling a Hikaru I'm like in
my head there's no way a Pog champer is
gonna see this but he does and I stand
corrected this is probably like the best
counter-attacking plan he's gonna have
to move that King regardless out of the
pin anyways
oh and virtual missing the first chance
there to push that pawn all the way up
to G6 pass pawns we all know what to do
with them
and we don't blunder them that's that's
not it sorry I didn't mean to leave you
hanging there
no no you're good
yep white is putting pressure here on
the D4 Pawn I think black has to defend
here we don't want to give him that pawn
otherwise that Knight is just gonna be
also under attack so it looks like he
can only defend with the Knight
yeah Knight E3 to C2 the problem there
is if virtual sees the X-ray on the king
and if he finds G5 G6 I think he wins
the game I think that might be the X
Factor to determine whether his clock
will be the deciding factor or that g
Pawn I have no idea
there's daily dose
I think honestly I have no idea
there wasn't there really wasn't much
WoW but once again he's not I don't know
what else I'm supposed to do here
he's reticent about pushing this Jeep on
and he's just gotta close his eyes and
do it
there's no other way to win this
position yeah at this point virtual is
almost maybe no moving I think we can
pull it off and there it is don't go G6
prematurely though because of King F6
and the pawn will be contained but he's
going the wrong way is Daily News
yep Rook A7 decisive he's gonna bring
his Rook down
and at that point like I I don't know
what I'm supposed to do we buttered his
Rock
he plundered it
is he gonna see it he's so down on
himself I don't know if he will
Knight moves hard to find you're right
Andrea psychologically you get into that
mode
oh my God
and now it's a completely new game this
should still be a draw
but Virgil gotta cut these one move
blunders out he knows better than that
virtual is very principled knowing to
bring the roots to the seventh but when
he needed it most The Rook needed to
come down again
objectively Andrea this should still be
a drop if so all of the pawns are taken
off the board these two pawns and this
Pawn it's a drug theoretically Rook
versus Bishop is a probable position but
at a lower level it's very very hard to
hold because most beginner players don't
know the right drawing techniques and
look at daily dose King F6 hitting the
bishop
and if the bishop moves away you can you
can take that g Pawn he's slowly coming
back to take back those pieces
unbelievable what a turnaround
oh man and all he had to do was Rook B7
uh should we tune into virtual
let's do it how is he taking the loss of
his Rook is this still completely drawn
uh
that's not good far from over
all right let's try to cause chaos
Bishop D7 good move
behind the thing would be very bad for
me don't give up that g point
oh my God why am I afraid Bailey doesn't
want to take that pawn if he go if he
goes here I can play here and the King
can never take my Bishop is what I have
to realize nope that would be a blunder
he's
he's on power pressure
he sees it though he's playing fast this
is an easy position to play though you
just shuffle your bishop and your king
and keep the pawns protected it should
be a draw
as long as he avoids any Forks
but it is
together you'll be good
I think it's a draw because together one
two keep the bishop on e4 or F5 Andrea
if you played Bishop before I can take
the bishop and promote his d-pawn so
there are some tricks oh my God
ah yeah now I have to um
get through with the black piece of
stuff
okay he's not he's not playing I mean
the setup for winning this would be
winning no virtually
kiss those dreams goodbye it is
my Bishop I'm glad he's not going
fishing they're defending each other and
then my king can maybe try to win his
Pawn yep
I think I need to make a turret if daily
dose moves away from the e file and
gives up the d-pawn yes then white will
get some chances but that's I don't
think so unlikely to happen
White's just shuffling I'll just go up
yeah I'll just go up
top same situation professional draw
we've had so far yeah
don't make progress
and it's very likely to because daily
dose kind of realizes that he can't make
progress important for virtual not to oh
he did blunder a bit Rook takes E4 he
did blunder that just now but daily does
didn't see it though yeah if you want uh
I was gonna see if you could go back on
analysis board well maybe he goes back
Rook back to E6 yeah Rook second for the
bishop he's got that strong password and
that deep Pawn is just three squares
away from promoting would have been an
absolutely beautiful tactic and he has
the time to think for it but it's really
hard when you're not used to this
pattern recognition to recognize that
you have the potential for a sack
that's exactly right if you gave this to
him as a puzzle Rush problem he would
find it right if you tapped him on the
shoulder and said daily dose I think uh
there is a tactic in this position yeah
rookie four is easy to see but the
second component is understanding that
you have to look for something and
that's what trips up a lot of newer
players they don't know when to even
hype when a tactic might hypothetically
exist and that prevents them from
looking for it
and a drop yes a drop by repetition the
first positional draw of [__] game
that's honestly a very satisfying result
virtual played some amazing chess he had
that one blender but daily dose an
underdog with you can say you know 500
points here holding his ground and not
only holding his ground but almost
winning the send game so I'm very happy
with the draw that was a great game
great game
yeah
and clean clean chess for most of the
game
yeah I mean I was too pawns up oh yeah
this was passive not seeing the pawn
hanging
I don't hear that Bishop F1 was a
mistake
but the biggest mistake was not pushing
that pawn and giving up the rook in the
end
yeah that was virtual kind of examining
his game the first game ends in a draw
the underdog daily dose plays a clean
solid healthy positional game he holds
from a position of strength but Andrea
there's a second game and virtual is
gonna try to play more actively if he
plays a little bit faster I think he's
got a good shot to win Yep this is daily
doses so he is daily dose has been in a
very stacked group first of all and I
think virtual's still the highest rated
technically in the group so him getting
this draw is amazing we love to see it
um so yeah the second game well now
daily dose will have the white pieces so
we won't be seeing the cow
um so maybe he will not get into such an
unfortunate position straight out of the
opening we will see
yeah it feels like he experimented with
it once he got a decent position but if
virtual plays more aggressively he'll
put more pressure on daily dose's clock
and uh I really think that he should
play something more mainstream although
Anna kramling's opening is the best in
chess but it should be reserved for
tournament play you know
and a Friendly's cow opening for
tournament play
sorry I zoned out for a second and then
all I heard was and then I zoned out
yeah over the for over the board serious
play like in the world so you're saying
maybe one day in an IRL tournament you
would play the cow yourself
if the circumstances were right I mean
maybe my last game of chess ever like
the game before I retired okay okay
at that point you just have to create
your own opening that is true I mean
there was a brief time when I played a
line on the Karo Khan that started to be
become known as the narokan the problem
was black had about seven ways to get
the advantage so I quit that's always
the problem with making your own stuff
but if we didn't have computers then
nobody would know well eventually but
yeah that's why I wish I was alive in
the 60s you could play one A4 2h4 and
get away with it that is a bygone era
now as we wait for the second game to
begin should be starting any second now
yeah I think daily dose is loading in
very curious where daily doses heads is
heads is at as well because he he
probably senses that he's an underdog
but I think this game should be a huge
boost to his confidence I just wish he
would take his time a little bit more
that if I was his coach which I would
happily coach him first of all that's
the main piece of advice I'd say
especially when you're up two minutes on
the clock and you sense these critical
positions just sit on your hands and
take an extra 30 Seconds To Think
chess is such a hard game there's just
so many things that have to go right for
you to win a game and so many different
areas of improvement it can be
incredibly daunting as a newer player
just you know understanding everything
that you have to get better at and these
players they handle it very gracefully
the game has begun and a bird opening by
daily dose of Internet another rare
guess at this level
the cow and the bird were just in
Farmland today
so this is something that he's played
before yes he so far the only daily dose
games I've seen with white he always
plays the bird
okay the bird it is not named after a
certain kind of bird it is named after
Henry Edwin bird it was a British player
of the 19th century
I know so boring Andrea chess players
never name anything after animals I
guess there is the lion
I see see donya's just kind of like an
urban dictionary for NHS opening like
the fact that he knows where the bird
came from that it was a guy in not a
bird very impressive
Bird yeah I wish it was a bird trust me
I dearly dearly wish for that now daily
dose like he did in the previous game
has given away his light skirt bishop
and some of the light squares in the
center leave a lot to be desired you're
getting fact checked in the chat we have
the hippo and the Dragon
oh the dragon well the dragon's a fake
animal not real what animals dragons are
real and so is Santa Claus how dare you
Daenerys Targaryen just just cast a
spell on me
okay
how you're supposed to play the bird
from my um limited knowledge on chest
openings otherwise in the London this a
little bit passive and white doesn't
have as much Center control as they
should but maybe this is a bird thing
yeah I mean it is sort of a bird thing
White Center is solid White's got this
E5 Square for his Knight so just like in
the previous game I hesitate to nitpick
because this game could go either way
like these positional considerations
generally don't decide a Pog Champs game
although you know the previous game was
decided by a lot of these positional
factors yep
Bishop D2 okay black can expand with B5
and A5 just engineer a queen side attack
you could also bring your queen up to B6
and tickle that pawn on B2 so lots of
things that black can do to improve his
position Rook C8 is also one of those
decent improving moves
yeah I'd like to see daily dose I don't
know what the night on A3 is quite doing
but I think he understands he should
take these light square holes he brought
his Queen to you too maybe a knight C2
but I don't like seeing the Knight on
the side of the board and that is
probably one of the most straightforward
lessons in chess that you can teach to
anyone who's new Knight on the rim is
dim or slim I always forget one or the
other you know Graham Grim there's a lot
Prim
Knights on the rim are Prim okay I don't
know what premiums I haven't heard that
one yet no that was I just made that one
up well with Donya you know any word he
says is a big word maybe you don't know
questions I think
yes yes tennis night jump the queen G4
we're hearing virtual right now people
lose upon with that I like this move
what does Knight you for do
nice we're singing back but uh that does
weaken him on the dark squares
so now this bishop G4 is a very
weakening move he meant light squares
hold on to it I don't want to trade it
for a night oh he was referring to the
move H3 so yeah he was referring to the
weakness of the G3 square but uh now he
can get his Knight into E4 for me
or should I take if it takes files I
kind of like the idea of a later G4 like
a crazy King attack you bring your queen
to G2 here
this is good that is typically why it's
planned and these Stonewall structures
C4 was unnecessary it's my black white
was not threatening to take on C5 I
would have played 94 immediately but he
sees that score he understands that
getting the Knight C4 is his best
positional asset
he has a very good understanding of weak
squares and dark squares and weaknesses
in the position
indeed this is basic positional chess
when you get a piece into the center it
controls more squares particularly if
it's a knight
also his Knight is just straight up
unguarded okay he's a fun set not
anymore yeah don't see anything wrong
with this this looks very good yeah like
the Knight was under attack but it's
interesting that they both had the exact
same thought process
that night is power we're getting a
similar situation as the previous game
blacks made the obvious moves the
low-hanging fruit but now you need to
find ways to improve nutrition my and
that takes advantage
move here
uh this and this take take I like that
plan
this take take take I will win this
trade at least
too many trades although I really like
that yeah
no his intuition for finding these
questions amazing okay so he wants to
break up there and attack these pawns at
the daily dose
that's right the C4 Pawn is so well
protected whereas white spawns on the
king side are a lot more tender and
White's pieces are so passive that if
the Center opens up white could get
checkmated down the f file
so what'd you say here since the queen
side's kind of getting blocked White's
plan is to attack on the king side
um it's hard to it depends on whether
black plays E5 if black plays E5 which
he just did white has to try to keep the
king side closed so you might ask well
what happens if everything is traded on
E5 well if you imagine the Knight on F3
being gone and the pawn F4 being gone
Black's Rook threatens to infiltrate to
F2 with decisive effect so when the
Center opens up the side which has a
space advantage and better placed pieces
is more equipped to turn that into an
attack so if your daily dose I'm I mean
his position is miserable here I would
consider Knight C2 it may be just like a
waiting move of some sort but it's hard
to even make a waiting move
and you don't like F5
it's interesting you can try to keep
things close but then maybe black and
try to pick that pawn off
I was gonna say also you just get forked
with Knight G3 but looks like that's
happening anyways
yeah
oh no
oh
he doesn't want anything someone walk
away from the board in pogchamp the
other one was either one Naruto running
away from his win for a daily dose
because he put in so much work that
first game but you know what like we've
seen in the past one blender isn't going
to decide the entire game so dumb
no especially not a pawn I'm much more
worried about the state of White's
pieces than I am about the pawn he just
lost now virtual can win a second Pawn
Andrea if he plays he takes F4 he takes
F4 the E file opens oh and 92 check
actually picks off The Rook on C1 oh man
that would be devastating and he finds
it first step is complete will he see
the fork on E2 though
honestly daily dose was in a very
difficult position like you said it was
a difficult plan to find for a newer
player and his pieces were just so tied
up that when you don't know where to
develop it's very likely you blender but
it's over like it's you're very right
close Center position it's hard to play
Virtual misses the fork comes back to E4
still an amazing dominant position
though all right come on don't give it
it hurts to see daily dose down you know
the voice of the internet you never hear
him being sad and it kind of breaks my
heart
it is weird isn't it given the the
incredibly positive quality of all his
videos
that's the lesson right that's the
takeaway
but who knows maybe maybe it comes back
like you said his pieces are still a
little tied up here but you know maybe
this G file getting open could be a good
thing he moves his King to the H file
just I don't know where he's gonna put
that Knight on E1
um I guess C2 is the only square but if
he could maybe make a battery on on the
G file that's a little bit of potential
oh but not on the same diagonal as the
bishop maybe H1 was a little bit less
dangerous
agreed White's position is so miserable
Andrea and black you know the issue is
that black has more ways to improve his
position than Henry VIII had wives like
you can do anything and it's gonna be
good for you you can play rookie eight
you can take the bishop and weaken the
F4 Pawn you can play Queen C7 and when
when the you know the the margins are so
wide
um newer players feel really comfortable
so virtual will have to work hard not to
win this game oh Knight T2 great move
and then the queen can come into E4 and
you just can't defend that F Pawn Queen
E4 is decisive oh my goodness yep you
can't use that Knight because then your
knight on F3 is hanging and otherwise in
the night there's no other piece you
defend with your king but that's even
really walking into the war zone let's
see let's tune into virtual oh my God
and he sees it he's done it he sees it
yep I mean I'm not surprised with his
intuition and his positional
understanding these moves are just gonna
have the Jeep on up to G5 and challenge
that pawn even further he's done it wow
and virtual automatically finding the
counter attack because but I think
Andreas
because the king will be defending the
other night so yeah black has to find
maybe like one or two accurate moves to
finish this game is still there Knight
G2 half has to find Niger tour he loses
instantly and he's done it daily dose is
refusing to die
wow
two Andrea those are two only moves yeah
so now what is what is it the the plan
black is still in an amazing position
with so much space but now it's not so
obvious either there's a couple
different plants you could go for oh wow
he just trades right away makes sense
wanting to open up the king
the winning move is king h8 oh and he
plays Bishop F4 he took too early oh
what am I doing if we get a queen trade
now remember we were saying about that
Knight being a burden now it's open the
way for the Rooks and if they trade the
Queens then we might just have a very
similar scenario to the last game he is
once again down upon
inexplicable decision for someone with
positional understanding that's really
solid to give up that Bishop for the
Knight on F4 which is pinned all he had
to do was shift his King to h8 and Rook
G8 would have dislodged White's King and
won the Knight go go ahead Andrea
virtual actually made the same mistake
twice giving up the bishop here I think
virtual learned almost every single rule
of Chess except for the bishop Aaron
Grand Master Hammer will be very
disappointed
that's that's the one rule that I'll
never forget don't give your Bishop go
ahead it's it's a good technique no just
totally agree with you to be aware of
what your strongest pieces what is the
piece that's causing the most trouble to
your opponent and it was the dark
squared Bishop it was paralyzing white
and yes when you're up a pawn
simplifying can be a good idea but not
at the cost of giving away your
strongest pieces we've got the same
scenario oh my God Pawn up end game but
White's in the best shape he's been all
game oh I wish he would have pushed that
pawn on the dark squares don't bring the
king back the king wants to be active
and daily dose blitzing out again being
up on the clock and um you know he does
make solid fast moves but he should
really be taking his time in this
position
yeah he's brought his King all the way
back into the corner which
doesn't really impact the game on a
basic level one good thing for white
Andrea is the placement of these pawns
they're all on dark squares so they're
unattackable by Black's Bishop it's
gonna make it very hard for virtual to
put his extra Pawn to good use
maybe we could unmute players
thank you
daily dose
isn't saying much right now
there's one Piggy
rookie seven on the board
he learned from his opinion
okay what is black gonna do here how is
black going to deal with that Rook on E7
the best move is rookie
I was gonna say this I think this bishop
F5 plan maybe the Knight could attack it
but I find intimidating because maybe
bishop comes C4 if the knight ever moves
to attack it then you have Rook G2 and
virtual finds the best counter attack
Bishop B4 here you're absolutely right
Black's Rook potentially could come into
G2 and I really worry the daily dose
might automatically drop his Knight back
to D2 that loses the game on the spot
that's to rookie too
it's very critical
very important SpongeBob cup
okay no he looks like he's he's
contemplating he's very stoic
let's listen it's a virtual here right
after this it gets tricky because he
disconnects his Rooks actually
[Music]
so you'd have to make the correct trade
I'm glad he wants to play this time I
play here I think
white has two ways to stay in the game
Knight H4 or Rook E3 to protect that
Knight do not go Knight D2 or Knight G1
and he's found one of them oh this works
this keeps white in the game but still
problematic especially if black can take
the Rook on E7 off the board White's
pieces
very very passive
[Music]
I really like my Bishop but maybe in
order to have any play here I actually
have to
um
to trade a rook because
wow I don't see how I can make problems
great positional thinking he gave away
his dark screen bishop and now he's
finding like the most advanced position
there but I wonder he went to the same
high school as Magnus Carlson yeah this
is controlling his kingdom yeah exactly
in case he doesn't trade
this all makes sense
living in Norway just raises your
chassillo by 300 points
and then this is going to make for a
very strong Bishop now
I gotta push this Pawn this is my win
condition this guy right here my win
condition
[Music]
win conditions very Advanced Rook on the
open file
I feel like that's a term borrowed from
gaming because you acted like you knew
so I thought I was getting left out of
it
yes of course I use that phrase all the
time what is your win condition which is
very annoying to deal with
uh did you trade Knights here
tradition for night I mean it's not good
for him uh I feel like if he does this
trade we might have a similar scenario
like last game what if we had two
dresses and get in here that would be
insane that definitely would be a record
that probably stands for the entire
future history of POG Champs make like a
Sentry in the middle oh he's giveness
juicy Square on E5 but he's brought his
Knight to the side instead which is not
that bad
but it's not that bad right black can't
infiltrate to G2 this way and the one
thing of the night not taking the E5
Square maybe the king could okay not if
we go oh boy okay uh luckily there's no
Rook G2 check just yet but that means
that the Knight has to say on the rim
where it's dim slim and Prim and that's
not good you don't want to use your
knight to just defend one square and be
useless in the end game he's kind of
caught himself in a jiffy here
if you want to be evil with black I
would make this move Rook G7 just
seemingly blundering the pawn but kind
of opening the gates for Rook G2 which
would be decisive so if your daily dose
your next move should be Rook F1 to F2
just over protect that square so that
your knight is free to roam about the
cabin
three unmute daily dose uh here's
thoughts in the background
let's do it
how is he going to handle this defensive
test Rook G5 good move
he saw the threats
um but this is just drastically worse
because I'm guessing they trade Rooks
and then in this end game what black has
a pass on and they just activate their
King and push the faster because he's
also up a pawn
the Knight on H4 is also dominated by
the bishop very instructive scenario for
newer players look at that Bishop on e4
holding every one of the knights squares
once the Rooks are traded a pawn end
game is winning for black so the Knight
will never be able to rejoin Society
without allowing a decisive trade of
Bishop overnight but he declines the
trade
a lot of mistakes in the send game wait
why is he daily dose just has given up
wait okay he only has one move and it's
King what is he doing he thinks he's
organizing his name
I'm literally blind Nike too you're
right it's a way out of this and I don't
but even team G3
he's back up he's got his SpongeBob cup
he's not giving up chat he's just
grabbing his SpongeBob cup don't worry
just needed a little more coffee to find
them of Knight G2 and he's gone King G3
he's gone with your suggestions oh God
it was a bad suggestion the computer did
not like that one and I'm starting to
see what
and the but it's but Andrea like black
still has to win that Knight versus
Bishop end game which is far from
trivial true wait what happened did he
resign no he's still here
wait I think he resigned
[Music]
you resigned why don't you resign what
what why did he resign it was still fine
if you went back
yes that's a repetition that moves it no
we'll see was losing his Rook
was it a mouse well that's a win but no
no I think he saw the move Rook G5 and
panicked and thought he was losing I
think he could have just gone up here
man defend the Rook again
psychological game
never resign until the last move of
Checkmate even
even Chesterman playing till the very
last second doesn't matter you just hang
on there
oh my gosh daily dose he did this in the
previous game he loses the match one and
a half resigns a position in which yes
yes he was losing objectively but
virtual was stumbling he didn't see the
winning plan and he was down three
minutes on the clock daily dose giving
up hope too early Andrea that's just sad
you know that is sometimes a product of
inexperience you feel like the game
isn't going your way and then you panic
too early but you have to stay calm play
on until Checkmate there's nothing to
lose man Yep this is something that I've
done many many times especially reminder
daily dose was in a stacked stacked
group and today he rose to that level he
he had a beautiful draw even in this
game he was really coming back in like
one of the most difficult positions he
was hanging his ground coming back but
when you're constantly fighting from the
Underdog position sometimes
psychologically they defeat you and
that's kind of what happened today
it is indeed but daily dose should hold
his head up high he played way above his
rating as we see the final standings
there virtual a disappointing result in
the end he doesn't make it onto the top
two spots but he will have his chance to
redeem himself in the consolation
bracket wow what a series of high-level
games we had today and we will have the
interview coming up as we set up the
players we hope you enjoyed this first
POG champ Smash and we'll be back with
the players in just a couple of seconds
foreign
[Music]
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carlsen and Michiana
this course is generally about examples
like this common knowledge that's used
on on the highest level
good intuition comes from knowing a lot
of examples from having seen examples
thought about them and perhaps tried to
implement the principles but under
different circumstances having thought
about it having tried to implement it in
a way having debated it so that's more
or less what I try to do with this
course
basically puts the foundation for
positional understanding positional
intuition you will see in in many
players
foreign
this August engage in a battle of Epic
Proportions against some of the most
Bodacious artists history hath ever seen
behold Raphael the prince of painters
doth seek a fresh Apprentice Dosh thou
possess the prowess to impress him
Michelangelo a true renaissance man
painter sculptor architect and poet doc
possess a myriad of artistic talents yet
one wonders can his creative genius
translate to Brilliance upon the board
of chess
prepare thyself for a game as dramatic
as the Baroque paintings of Artemisia
gentileski one of the most expressive
artists of the 1600s
I renowned sculptor Donatello stands
tall as one of the most important
artists of the early Renaissance his
unique blend of creativity Aesthetics
adaptability and patience maketh him a
challenging foe Lo Leonardo da Vinci
known for his artistic talents
scientific curiosity and innovative
ideas is the very embodiment of the
Renaissance he is not only among the
greatest artists to ever live but also
one of the greatest thinkers May a
fortune smile upon thee create thy
Masterpiece on chess.com cowabunga
[Music]
three two one
foreign
[Music]
[__]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to day six of pogchamps 5
the first match is in the books it was
one of the highest level levels Pock
Champs match that we have seen as
virtual defeats daily dose of Internet
one and a half half we have the players
here in the studio for an interview
virtual congratulations on the win I'll
start with you you had a disappointing
match yesterday you came back with
inventions today what lessons did you
apply and how did your approach change
in preparation for today's match
uh well today's prep was a bit different
from the other day so I realized we're
not going to the top bracket and that's
okay but what can we do we can have fun
with the game of chess so I played uh my
coach's own opening the cow opening
which I thought was was fun to play it's
it gave me a good position but
um then I also knew that daily dose
likes to play F4 with white and we had a
preparation against that so I felt very
comfortable in both openings today
uh
sorry go ahead Andrea go ahead Andrea
um and daily dose you know I want to
just first of all applaud you I know
you've been literally traveling you're
taking lessons you have been in a
completely stacked group and um today
even though the the matches the last one
didn't go your way the first game you
came with an amazing draw and the second
game where you just held your ground and
I know you're so tough on yourself but
we have to ask I'm assuming the resign
happened because you assumed you're
losing your Rook
uh yeah hello everyone this is your
daily dose of resigning uh that's all I
do apparently because I I refuse to lose
I guess I don't know
um so I would rather uh you know well uh
you know end it myself
um but yeah I did not know that I could
get out of that situation I guess I went
a little too fast there so
well you know in in the GM World they
may respect you even more but I do wish
you played on because you were in such a
difficult position where all your pieces
were tied up and you found like the one
plan to defend everything go into the
end game and similar to last game we are
down upon your fighting in the end game
and then you can make a draw happen
um and I just want to say I I would love
to see you continue playing chess I
would love to do some lessons I think
with a little bit of prep it'd be a Pog
champ winner and I understand being
tough on yourself and I understand the
resignation and we'll just say you did
it for the memes and the GMS
yeah what's what's a GM
um
you don't want to know you ever heard of
a Hikaru
a grand master oh okay yeah Grandma a
question why did the time keep going up
did you see me freaking out there
I didn't know that's why you were
freaking out so there is um increment
where you're gaining seconds every move
and that has been the format of the
entire tournament and every other game
that you've played
I'm just I'm just learning here so like
I've never done this sort of thing
before this is probably the like the
first time I have played against like a
human in like a year maybe so it's been
a long long time
so like yeah I've had like human roles
no friends I'm using one I don't blame
you
yeah but it was fun but yeah I
definitely I had zero practice for this
stuff
yeah yeah I would like to quickly say
that yes uh I I'm really impressed uh
daily dose with how well he played well
being on a travel in Norway and we had a
very competitive uh first game there uh
with the with the draw which is kind of
crazy so uh if this is what you can do
with like uh very low prep then I look
forward to seeing like the next games
now in the in the Knockouts you know to
see uh see how it goes
oh am I going to see you in the knockout
I think I think we're both going to
Knockouts right in the consolation
bracket yeah you're both going to the
constellation bracket and ver I want to
ask both of you really quickly who who
if anybody you're looking forward to
facing in the consolation bracket
virtual I'll start with you is there
anybody that you want to deliver Revenge
to or are you just looking forward to
the experience overall
I mean that's uh I don't wanna don't
wanna wish upon anyone to go into the
constellation so maybe it's best to talk
about players that are already confirmed
to be there uh Jarvis is a good friend I
was impressed by his place I think it
would be fun to play against Jarvis and
chess and uh other than that we'll just
have to see how the last group stack up
I think
really does what about you
wait so this was basically like a
meaningless game neither of us could
Advance
yeah but well
it was a Redemption game because you
know you're at the bottom of the bracket
but now you've got a strong draw so I
think it was a very important game for
you to get that yeah well I had fun
that's all that matters so you seem like
you really enjoyed that game walking
around from your PC a couple times
I I
hate seeing myself do dumb things so
welcome to Twitch daily this is why this
is why you're safe on YouTube
together
yeah what uh yes you're very good I had
fun so yeah
well you have more fun to have in the
constellation bracket both of you do
best of luck to both of you guys and we
will let you get ready for that bracket
and take your well-deserved rest it's
pretty late over in Norway so virtual
daily dose thank you uh for playing two
very high level games
is my
all right thank you guys bye bye guys
okay oh man I feel like we broke daily
dose I don't think he ever wants to play
chess again yeah I'm gonna reach out I
want to do some coaching he's such a
such a strong player and I love that he
also just has absolutely no clue of
what's going on really the beauty of POG
Champs it's honestly you know hard
because yes he had zero points but it
wasn't the games were very competitive
like the the margins that decided the
games were very thin and for somebody
who had zero almost zero chess
experience before POG Champs massive
Kudos like this the the growth curve
that a lot of these players have is
pretty impressive and it's not like they
don't do anything in their spare time
exactly yeah that's what I really wanted
to emphasize the daily dose but I think
for the consolation we'll Reach Out do a
couple lessons his opponent had been
prepping for these games and like you
said again someone completely new that
was a very hard battle
indeed it was but we've got another hard
battle coming right up between Papa
plate and foosli fusely with a matchup
yesterday but Papa plate I have not seen
play in pogchamps just yet his chest.com
rapid rating 712 one of the largest
twitch streamers in Germany and this is
also his second Park Champs appearance
which for some reason I didn't realize
so both of these players Andrea are
experienced this is not their first POG
Champs Rodeo
not their first POG Champs but both very
new to the game I don't think Papa plate
has played that much just he's done a
twitch Rivals before
um and same with fusely I think she did
maybe one tournament before but this
will definitely be a very different type
of chess
it will indeed as we see papa plate
they're a little bit of a real Do Hast
kevonen
and he celebrates his wins here
Annunciation
but yeah this is going to be a close
match I think fusely of course she
played yesterday she was on the right
track against I did a thing but stumbled
in the first game then couldn't quite
recover in the second she is a jack of
all trades a musician with uh over 10
million total streams across platforms
and this is also her second POG Champs
appearance we were really impressed uh
yesterday Canty and I with her attitude
and just her positivity even in bad
positions it's honestly very refreshing
right it's not all about being Uber
competitive having that positive vibe
can also be very valuable
yeah I wanted the same same for for
fusley and saikuno they are both
relative skill level getting paired up
against people who've been playing chess
for a long time but the fact that they
always have such a great attitude
towards the game they're always
entertaining to watch even their
commentary I enjoy watching myself so
it's I like like you said it's nice to
have a bit of ref refreshing takes into
the POG Champs it most certainly is and
I think fusely has modeled her opening
repertoire based on the Gotham videos
that she's seen she plays the Lenin
system with white
and then with black against one E4 just
she probably plays E5 I forgot what Levy
what is his biggest recommendation
against E4 with black but what we're
definitely going to get at least one
London to our great Chagrin although he
also plays the London it's chess
commentator content creator
forget her name though it's kind of
escaping me I text
I texted Lee the other day I was like
hey fusely you want some chess lessons I
know you got a big game coming up and
then she never replied in my texts and
then she just watched Gotham chess's
video instead on the very own opening
that I'm known for but it's fine it's
fine everything's fine and I'm being
told yeah ikarokan is correct I
apologize she played that yesterday as
well so we're gonna see E4 C6 very
likely and we're gonna see D4 and and
Bishop F4 but I don't know anything
about Papa plates tendencies in terms of
his style in terms of his openings do
you know anything about what his
stylistic Tendencies are I actually I
try to do some research but he doesn't
have that much game chess game history
except for one twitch Rivals long ago so
honestly it could be anything but I also
haven't yet seen Papa plate
um so I think it's very cool to have
streamers from all around the world
joining us and like you mentioned
earlier here's the top streamer from
Germany curious what type of energy he's
gonna bring
me too we'll definitely be tuning into
his stream and Bruce Lee is also
streaming so we'll have both of their
streams at our disposal we're setting
the players up right now so the games
should begin momentarily we've got five
total matches today this is only the
second one after this match I will be
replaced by a more able commentator in
the form of Danny
amazing commentator
I wish you could just stay and just the
three of us could commentate I
appreciate it if you guys have been
enjoying donya's car I think everyone's
been loving your analogy and your
Grandmaster dictionary you're very able
fluster fluster here you know I'm I'm
not gonna be able to commentate now
um so Dania can say just kidding
I'm uh I'm flattered thank you
we have more Donya commentary coming up
after today
wow chat is really Chad is really being
wholesome right now I don't know how to
handle this
well maybe we just don't let him leave
we could just keep him hostage kidding
this is an outpouring of of love that I
was not expecting today I really
appreciated everybody very very soon
thank you Andrea mind you chat this man
got called up this morning last minute
came in with a great attitude brought
the energy we were so blessed with
Sonia's presence and I'm also hoping to
get some more Dania Park Jim's
commentary
well thank you that that means a lot to
me
um that's that's what keeps me going and
what we'll keep the players going is the
longer time control 10 minutes plus five
seconds per move I like that time
control it's chill lets the players
think and there are two rapid games per
match in the event of a tie we will have
a Blitz game will this be the first
match that we
go to tiebreaker it's pretty evenly
matched on paper so I think it's not
unlikely that we get a 1-1 score
yeah I think one thing that's made
pogchems difficult yet very entertaining
is we have all these amazing
personalities joining us with you know
very varying levels of Chess experience
and because of that there have been some
mismatches
um but I think fusely first Papa plate
should actually be a pretty dope matchup
they should be close in skill level
whereas Bruce Lee was kind of just you
know put up against Australian the other
day I did a thing a very strong man he
goes into the water with sharks he's
defeated poisonous spiders like he's not
afraid of anything and it was a kind of
brutal match yesterday for fusley so
hopefully today it's a closer match
maybe a comeback
yeah and uh we have about a couple
seconds here to the games as we open up
the board that's Papa plates stream he's
got the chessboard
pulled up man his chat goes a million
miles an hour doesn't it geez I've
actually never seen a bubble pop-up
latte stream is he streaming in German
or English or both that's a great
question yeah let's see you probably
wouldn't understand anything but um I
speak the language of techno you know I
know a thing or two
kidding
that is Bruce Lee
I think it's safe to say fusely
streaming in English
yes I think we would yes but I wouldn't
be surprised
only Germany
mustardy Brown us Americans very
educated as well
you're always talking about varies
mustardy Brown I forgot that we were
playing I wonder what she was referring
to Lobby I really don't know I don't
know if we want to find out I I like
over invited and he's like so
hi Doc miss you
man I feel like the the vibe and the
energy level is going to change once the
games begin the players will get more
intense right now it's all smiles it's
all chill but first couple moves are
made and the energy in the room changes
completely I'm curious how papa plaza
will be well he's sipping on what I
think is a Red Bull so definitely taking
this very seriously and the games have
begun
yeah it's almost very intimidating even
more intimidating that we won't be able
to understand the word he says but you
know any Germans in the chat they can
help us Translate
yeah unfortunately if it was Russian or
Spanish I could help but I got us but
yeah we got a lot of languages covered
just just yeah
all right so he's playing an aggressive
opening he can control both squares in
the center I'm curious um if fusley's
done some opening prep but I think like
you said she was watching some of Gotham
chess's videos yeah but the thing is
here a very common beginner mistake is
to bring the night out to F6 which
allows white to push E5 okay fousey
plays E6 which sort of transposes the
game into a French defense but a passive
variation the move C6 and E6 closes the
bishop down so in that position you were
supposed to take on e4 and bring the
light scored Bishop out to F5 now the
bishop is stuck behind the E Pawn and
Black's position is very solid but also
very very passive
also if we could do an open mic on
foosli I haven't got to see her play yet
and I would love to hear how she thinks
let's tune in
as the queen comes out to E2 there over
protecting the E4 Pawn
definitely a good idea here's firstly
oh okay interesting exactly okay
um well that's fine what if I just go
like this develop my piece a little bit
let's see is anything of his unprotected
no no no so let me just bring out my
night good safe thinking always good to
double check I like these words Leslie
would do something she did that
yesterday too checking for unprotected
pieces
and it helps her capture one of White's
Bishops right fortunately the game went
Australia protected wait this piece 57
is a good move right
nothing's protecting this right so what
if I don't know push this
oh boy we're yoloing a little early in
the game
it's not tied to YOLO you gotta live a
little to YOLO first maybe he waits on
the 15. maybe move 15 and then you can
okay good she's
gonna say here
oh no no no don't put it on C5 don't put
it on C5 it's already kind of I'm not
supposed to have Andrea you know what
worries me I have um black goes Knight
F6 then white will push the pawn up to
E5 with a fork so Bruce Lee will have to
develop her G8 now there's no oh okay
we're yoloing Knight takes D5 picks up a
pawn because the queen
is pin I didn't either I won't be honest
I didn't know
yeah we were looking for the fork wow
and he didn't even hesitate
Papa showing seriously who the papa
Plata is
but that's only a pawn plate even
Stanford do you know
he likes I lattes
I guess I'm curious if Papa it's two
words like Papa my name is Papa plate or
is that like one long word
Chad please um enlighten me
yep dad play any German speakers but
what what does plate
what does latte stand for nothing not
even in German gotcha cool thanks chat
you guys are the best okay so it's one
of just one of those like just names you
know just a name that doesn't really
matter meaningless name yep
well okay unlike meaningless but not
like this position Papa plate has gotten
the advantage straight in the opening
won the bond and now there's even more
potential for Forks there's also open
light squares around the king but that
check's not doing anything yet
um but let's see if he's going for these
plans that Dania is making beautiful
arrows for
I would this is about the extent of my
art history I I would have castled if I
were white just taken care of the
fundamentals you can also bring your
dark Square Bishop out to G5 and hit the
queen
he gives a check on B5 which fusely can
pretty easily cover with Bishop D7 and
generally when you're up upon your
advice that simplifications are good but
that Bishop on D3 was actually a very
nice piece it could have combined with a
queen from E4 to deliver a main thread
on H7 if black had castled so I actually
think this trade makes it a little bit
easier for black to play
yep totally agree and fusely finds the
best defensive move
even though we don't speak German I'm
still curious at least once to check out
Papa plots a stream to see The Vibes we
will learn German you learn chess we
could learn German
I think he's deciding between 95 and ig5
I don't know why the beautiful thing of
Chess is you don't need exactly the same
language to understand these arrows are
making it very easy for us to see stop
process so thank you yep you always have
the common language
okay
means Queen I know allow for Springer I
know that one too Knight and Bishops
no not a good idea
have on this it's been fauna you just
need a little bit of German techno going
on in the back and you know I could get
used to this
a little bit of a Rammstein
I wonder if he's gonna find that C4 he
is
that of plates so he should be looking
for that fork because he likes to eat I
don't know
C4 I would still go C4 and try to drive
that pawn up to C5 deliver the fork but
Bishop D2 is fine the Germans have
completely taken over our chat I can
tell but I like the energy that they're
bringing in let's go
okay
okay okay I'm not gonna read random
German words from Chad actually
okay this is how we would get canceled
in another language I feel like I said
something bad I've never listened to
Ramstein or don't know what it is I just
know it's a music band I apologize
I have never listened to it nothing
about it it has sold in another country
it's only been I knew it would happen
someday
that's funny all right we haven't come
with the fork really wants to trade off
these vicious almost given a pawn here
well he is giving up on
this could be foosli's comeback
this should be four but I can take twice
very similar Vibes to the previous
um to the previous match in the sense
that there are no big blunders there's
like small mistakes but again it most
pox Champs games are decided by big
wonders but the previous match wasn't so
fusely 95 centralizing or night that's
not a bad move but yeah she could have
recovered the pawn there by taking twice
on B4
yep which her Instinct night in the
center I know we see that ugly X on the
board but hey that's a good Instinct
defended by the pawn it's not under
attack so for this level you always want
to bring your pieces to the center she
did miss the pawn but I think that's the
only reason there's a big X oh actually
no well C4
all right we have that pawn again but
she has to see that she can take it with
the knife yeah Knight takes before he's
basically forcing black uh to win that
pawn back and that's exactly
I that's exactly what she does I mean
you're gonna force her nice
Let's Open fusley's Mic but stay on this
layout just to hear her commentary in
the back
she has to see if takes we missed it
earlier but I'm sure now it's a little
more obvious nice good stuff and she's
recovered the pawn
yeah and your white one
because no reason not to it's gonna kill
me right
right I'm cooking okay she's been
hanging out with Frank
she's cooking okay okay okay now he's
bringing the queen in all right that's
fine right that's okay
um so so that's okay he wants to do some
okay that's okay
so I'm a little scared here wait why
he's gonna push it well he's gonna do
something here he can do this
oh we can do this and this what can else
can you do with the queen
I guess you can like attack this I can
attack that I mean I can just defend
here with my Rook
revoking C5 but it's probably not good
actually well D5 could be good never
mind
okay okay
right why do you move his Queen there he
wants to like you know attack this piece
well that's fine I'll just eat him with
my queen back right he can attack this I
eat that he could tax that I go like
that
um what else is threatening me nothing
really okay nothing really this goes
here I eat this
um push push nothing right there's no
there's no immediate threats very active
good critical thinking yeah
um
for someone new to the game oh never
mind
never mind okay
but that's okay because
what else is unprotected this is
unprotected
what if I just what if I just go like
here now oh wait until the night is
protecting it less than one is really
taking their time
that on yeah that is a very very cool
move we entered danger lands we've got a
backward spot on E6 now White's gonna
have a Target to attack and queen comes
forward to E3
but I guess you can Retreat although
the one thing to note is that it's hard
for white to get a rook to E1 oh my God
because Black's Bishop is firmly
ensconced on B4 and it's actually hard
to take that Bishop away either like I
think I'm black and play A5
at some point and really just stick that
Bishop on B4 controlling the E1 Square
first of all Papa plaid has to move his
Queen and he does let me think what if I
push my Bishop here right
move his Rook
I kind of like that I I'm I can push
here okay his Queen's here that's fine
it can't really do anything because
takes what can he do right nothing he
takes this he can go here I guess but I
can kill him there he goes there he goes
there I can eat
um take okay so he's not in a great
position I feel like with this queen
unless I'm just missing something
entirely
um I kind of want to do this with my
Bishop
I don't love that move it's a one move
thread and it moves the bishop away I
think at the moment from its defended
post so if white plays Rook ac1 you're
just gonna have to bring this bishop
back to where it came from right so
again no big mistakes here Andrea it's
just like small things but I feel like
eventually we are gonna get a big
blunder as the clocks continue to
dwindle yep these one move threats that
is fine on the surface well it can
really change your chest levels thinking
just two moves ahead rather than one yes
you attack The Rook but after they move
what's your plan right now we most
likely just go back
indeed and Rook ac1 is on the board at
least I like that um The Bishop's gonna
stay on this oh oh I was gonna say I
like
I like the diagonal to prevent real
but now it's not it's attacking The Rook
yes but it's gonna take us a little bit
depends where the Rook goes if the Rook
goes to C2 then the bishop no longer has
that C3 Square
and that's exactly where the ref should
go to now fortunate for fousey the
bishop is not trapped it can go back to
A3 and then it can Circle back around to
D6 and knock the queen out of the center
but I think fousey's is attracted to
these one move threats just sort of
hitting the Rook hitting the Rook it
gives you that rush but in reality you
know a threat isn't good because it's a
threat it all has to carry some other
idea and papa plaza thinking about where
to move his Rook he's probably also
considering them of Rook C to E1
Bishop could go back to C3 it's very
important that black continues defending
that E1 Square because that E6 Pawn is a
huge weakness and as soon as the Rooks
are creating a battery on that e-file
black will be in danger so she needs to
find the right Square for a bishop
and she plays it back to C3 we could get
a repetition of moves here
they walk into a three-fold repetition
without knowing okay oh Knight G5
oh this is tricky yes it's a free night
but Queen takes these six King D eighth
I don't know Queen to D6 there's
actually a mating sequence in that
position that's Uber advanced
so if booster gets baited okay wow she
didn't get paid but she doesn't but
there's another eight is gonna be a
nasty track here nasty nasty track Queen
check Queen block d8 Queen takes King
takes Knight F7 fork and papa plate is
eating up on his big plate and eats that
Rook up
you should be able to find the
subsequence this is what the your
username is all about uh never mind he
sees it but he thinks Queen's defense he
has to he has to keep calculating after
that one don't give up yup takes deeper
yep but Andrea you could also take B7 in
that position and hit the Rook on C6
that's like the next best thing oh my
God yeah that honestly he's gonna do it
wow
see
being attracted to the danger plays
Among Us she's talking about eating and
killing but she did not sense she needed
to Castle that was the last thing she
needed to do and now there's punishments
oh Rook C8 no she blundered a rook
oh my gosh she forgot that square is
undefended I mean it's literally GG
because now the queen blocks you just
have another he's just literally taking
these rooms wow yeah that was a blow
right there
the execution is stronger than the
threat Henry they
that was straight from my brain right
I knew that one and I didn't take that
from the chat
it was actually Catherine of aragono
just kidding yeah Queen takes B7
with a made threat on F7 Andrea he's
trying to finish the game right away but
he didn't even want to run the night on
G5 the blacks take the Knight on G5 and
she's in the oh she missed the mate
and it's over
Queen F7 will he see it
I mean I made in one
tomato one
he's thinking he's not playing it yet
will he play Knight F7 instead will he
get attracted to the fork which is of
course completely winning
and he sees it nice
all right maybe we were holding our
breaths there
ah yes um
he does indeed the queen of seven
language do has one no no I'm so sorry
please forgive me ladies and gentlemen
wow and he switches to English over
there he knows the crowd is watching
[__] go
oh yeah he definitely speaks English
well oh definitely wow what a game
fooslis opening in our thought process
she was on top of the game and then one
slide in accuracy she didn't castle and
that night move even though maybe not
the best move for a high level chess
completely worth and let her stray so
nice game on Papa Plate's end
and unfortunately that kind of followed
the pattern of yesterday's game where
fousey starts off well she plays a bunch
of good moves and then at some point in
the middle game she just sort of loses
the thread I think it started with the
move F5 when she weakened her E6 Pawn
that let White's pieces get active and
after that she just wasn't able to
contain all of the threats
it happens
um it's just part of the experience and
I think fousey takes it really well
she's got a chance to come back with a
with a win and she's got that solid
London system under her belt Papa plate
is I think in a struggle to get a
position he's comfortable with out of
the opening in the London
is playing the London right right I'm
looking forward to this London and I
have to say this was my first time
seeing Baba plate play chess and yes he
maybe missed a free Pawn but so far he's
a very strong contender in here I'm very
excited to see the rest of his games
I am as well I Knight G5 was actually a
very impressive move that night
sacrifice in orders to take on E6 was
very Advanced I don't know if it was
calculated or just the coincidence and
I'll never know because it was all in
German
um but I'm guessing it was just
masterfully calculated
absolutely and we are waiting for the
next game to begin it should be starting
we have over 900 games played ah it was
not yeah can can the Germans tell me it
was random it was lucky it was a
coincidence okay maybe I praised him
just a little bit too much and yes I did
go to Oktoberfest
um and we went to Berlin but the only
thing that I did in Germany on my free
time when we weren't playing chess was
go to the Techno clubs
um so I didn't quite learn German but
maybe another day chat
I've heard a lot of things about the
Berlin techno clubs those are my maybe
maybe one day I'm gonna bring oh we
actually hosted a chess Boiler Room in
Berlin and fun fact don't invite a bunch
of chess players to the club because
everyone comes and they ask where the
chess is and they don't dance so that
was my Learning lesson
that sounds like a group of chess
players yeah and look at papa plaza just
copying foosli's London she played a
jabalanda she brought her night out to
C3 which I like to see but Baba blase
doing the same thing yeah I the the job
of London look okay finally a game that
I can commentate this is in my realm of
experience if you guys know anything
about me I only play the London and
nothing else
um I think the regular London's a little
bit more easy to play as a complete
beginner
um but and and the one thing that's
really annoying in the London is it's
such a straight up basic opening people
can get away with just copying you and
sometimes it happens in some of the best
lines
yep and it's happening right now
um but pop-up latte the first move which
deviates from what his opponent did
Knight comes out to F6 he could have
copied white with Bishop D6 there was
nothing wrong with that because the
trade on F5 isn't necessarily bad for
black black increases his central
control so let's see how fusely keeps
this going probably Knight F3
and Bishop D6 we still have a completely
symmetrical position I think fousey
likes to bring her Knight over to E5 if
her game yesterday is any demonstration
yep I mean overall 95 I think for a
beginner play is very nice because if
they ever do fall in that trap of taking
they take with the wrong piece like the
Knight then we get another Fork oh my
goodness okay our pawns
um and if they take the bishop then you
get the bishop pair but then she has to
know how to defend the pawn in the
center so it could get tricky
H6 on the board I would have taken on F4
and then slid this bishop over to G4
pinning the Knight and attacking D4 now
it's too late the position is still
symmetrical like they're sometimes
making different moves at different
times but move eight and they've copied
each other's moves in verbatim
I mean honestly a good shot so far it's
working but it'll only go so long
not a bad Strat at all and I I think
this is the threshold where at this
point with all the pieces developed
you're gonna have to start making some
independent moves my guess is 95 I still
think that fusely will bring her Knight
up into the center well the thing with
95 is black could continue to copycat
it's not stopping it yet Papa plate
might just go in 94. and it's actually
building
um however there is a nice thing I don't
know if Lucy would see it but she does
have F3 in that position but that's a
little more advanced
um but I actually get really annoyed
when people just copy my London all this
way
it's hard it's surprisingly hard to
punish your opponent for that and it can
be infuriating when yep your opponent's
not making a single one of their own
moves and yet you start calculating the
lines and you can't actually punish them
yep so if I were playing Black I would
maybe take that Knight off the board
Bishop takes C5 maybe first take the
bishop on D3 and then take on E5 so you
could trade a bunch of pieces here the
position is like really really quiet
it's it's hard to make a really bad move
here the only blunder that you could
make really is Knight takes Knight you
don't want to do that because white
takes with a pawn and the two minor
pieces are going to be forked exactly
that is the one and only trick in this
position really
let's look into foosli
um
oh my God no no go back remove wait
where's my piece what is she doing well
I don't mean
it was here or here she's pre-moving oh
God
right click right click sorry okay there
we go that could have went terribly
wrong missing I think she wasn't aware
of the right click as a way to cancel
the premium just in case just in case
if he would have made some quick moves
me game because of that if he does that
I eat Bishop
so is Ian wow I like it
interesting okay quiet move he's scared
pushed a pawn feeling the pressure of
the London he's actually trembling right
now on the great presence of the London
okay well she just uh A3 they're really
just like
yes just you know like eight six eight
three they're like at this point just
offer the draw come on so funny to me
chipping away at the edges you know
funny
oh man he just needs his night up in my
business now you know because she pushes
really is trying to manifest that floor
watching why doesn't he do that
probably will
and then free sleep might get stumped
yeah because at that point the light
will have to do something how to make
direct contact yeah age five
oh my gosh they're just continually look
at that A5 A4 dude is actually playing
the reverse UNO card now because first
we started with Papa plate copying her
opening but now he's forcing him to come
up with the creative original ideas I
like the way she thinks
it is true that she's milking a solid
amount of time off of Black's clock pop
applies I think he's trying to find a
way to mix things up get it more
Tactical
and he's made a great move like what he
did in the last two moves was really
impressive he's gone A5 he Laur he
induced the move A4 now he sticks his
Knight on The Outpost on the queen side
putting pressure on foosli's Bishop and
likely leading to a trade of light
straight Bishops which is also going to
change the pawn structure in an
interesting way but nothing cataclysmic
has happened yet like at all it's still
impossible to predict where this game is
going to go from here
yeah here now if effusley continues the
Strat Knight B5 I mean it definitely
take some calculation like black could
take the bishop on D3 then she could
take the bishop okay all right she's
making the bishop trade I think actually
a pretty good move
okay waiting for Papa blase to recapture
on F5 which I hope he's gonna do
although it's a little alarming that
he's not doing it yet I I don't know
what he's thinking about which let's
tune in okay there we go a little bit of
German content okay yeah
I wouldn't mind because the arrows he's
good at drawing arrows to show what he's
thinking
ip5
he's about to get that move
Loosely just played her knight from C3
to B5 let's see how Apple Platt will
react once that moved
is shown on his stream we're a little
bit ahead of them there we go yep
of course of course Andrea that's what
we were doing it's actually better than
I thought he's a lot of stuff yeah
he really does why is everyone's pieces
pulsating why do the beginners like to
make their Pieces come to life
yeah they are pulsating aren't they I
was like someone slip something into my
coffee this morning wait a second okay I
don't know if she's gonna see it
Queen takes 96.7 this is the second one
and only trick in the London and I know
all of them so um this is very exciting
because typically stuff doesn't happen
in the London but it's happening but I
don't know if she's gonna see and I
think of seven right now we got a
discovery attack the bishop is defended
by the pawn the queen has entered the
area of the sniper on The Bishop's
diagonal he needs to spot this discovery
attack and we got a free Pawn or Knight
G6 yeah
or even a free exchange on f8 and it's
important there's two components you
have to see the X-ray that the bishop is
exerting on the queen and then you have
to actually see where the Knight could
go Knight G6 is a very unintuitive move
sometimes because it puts the Knight on
a square where on a defended Square so
you have to understand that the threat
against Black's Queen beats anything
that black can do to this Knight Knight
G6 picks up the exchange in fusely she
misses it she makes a move on the other
side and 4k3 is not that bad per se it
gives black a chance to move his Queen
away from The Bishop's purview if only
she took lessons with me and didn't
watch Gotham chess's videos
to all the chest elitists in the chatter
like oh my God she's wrong yes they both
work typically in these positions this
is a famous trick and black isn't
castled yet so typically you're not able
to attack the Knight with the Rook
that's where the famous trick comes from
but yes in this position there was two
and papa plaza is thinking still a very
close Center position it still happened
I would be happy with either
although I think you should see that the
queen is uh that the queen is under the
X-ray of the bishop let's look into
[__] is she maybe paying attention to
my Bishop oh but then he that X-ray and
the Queen
check this out watch my Bishop right oh
no then he eats
um
and he did move the queen opportunity
train has left the station doesn't even
know he wants to do this
his night here C3 is a great move
forcing the Knight back onto a passive
Square
though white has a great position the
rook's a little random on A3 however her
pawns are connected the dark squared
Bishop is definitely an asset
and The Rook could slide over to B3
exerting pressure on the B7 Pawn so you
could try to justify it see my plan so I
wanted to so I want to go like this
right but then he eats there so if I a
little too late now she sees it yeah I
know when you could have made me proud
first you ghost me wow okay but she's
making Donya proud she has found the
Grand Master Rook plan this is a rook
lift lady she's making threats and then
you know make 40 threads your opponent
it's gonna blunder eventually
but I protect my knight when I push
there so we can't even eat my nights so
just vacation for this plant it's very
interesting but still finding the best
place but then my night yeah I kind of
lost the threat of logic at some point I
think I'm overcooking
I'm gonna I don't know I'm doing
okay Knight can move back now actually
that's a super Advanced move Andrea I I
mean maybe she'll play it yeah if you
play Knight back to D3 you hit the Rook
by hitting the Rook you dislodge the B7
Pawn so that is a free Pawn or even
Knight F3 she wants to do something with
that Knight she just has to realize f
it's not happening it's hard to think
backwards that's what you do once you
hit 2000 level you start realizing that
oh G3 and that traps her own Bishop now
the move G5 is another Advanced move
which hits that bishop and wins the
bishop because fusley's last move
cancels out The Bishop's Escape path
instantly I was just saying Foos is
doing so well look at that
Bishop that and she gives that away had
it I blame Gotham for all of this making
my own video in the London again
and that's what happens it's easy to
pick up
the issue is that when fusely blundered
pieces in previous games that's when she
kind of collapsed like she gave away one
minor piece and then the wheels came off
completely let's see if she can just
sort of keep her composure avoid
blundering more pieces and just cut your
losses to one or even go Knight takes C6
here and try to get that rook in the
corner
um and attack it with two minor pieces
at the same time
yep yeah no things are gonna get like we
saw in the last game she literally won
small inaccuracy and then boom four
moves later it was GG we're gonna see if
she's gonna hold hold her footing here
um but there's really nothing she could
do about this bishop her best bet is
Maybe
getting that King off the file and at
least trying to get the Rook on the G
file but black will just replicate and
and now that Rook on B3 doesn't have any
thread it's just oh
and he and she's gone Knight G6 and
that's a super creative defensive move
because you're hitting both Rooks
actually one of them with the Knight and
one of them with the bishop so whichever
minor piece black takes you're gonna
take a rook either way black should take
the Knight on G6 and then
uh Papa Plato will get two nights for
the rook and black is much better in
that position because well two minor
pieces in the middle game are usually
much better than the rook and White's
Rooks are not particularly well placed
or well coordinated at all yeah I I
totally agree with the chat with chat
it's very impressive that she found this
move this is a very nice counter-attack
and like Donna said still not great for
Life
getting a little low on time too he's
got to keep an eye on his clock we're
watching him contemplate the
possibilities here
he should just take the Knight it's
better than taking the bishop
[Music]
denim
his pieces are also pulsating
good free move
does firstly see the hanging Rook
Let's uh let's get a fusely point of
view too
both Andrea I'm a little bit worried
chat he's worried that he's he doesn't
see The Rook no she did take the Rook
she didn't take the Rook okay so yeah
the downside is too very active right so
so then I take his Rook
I'm just gonna take his Rook I don't oh
my God he predicted that that was fast
okay
um I think that's fine that's all good
oh I don't know if we want to do that
don't get wired okay so if I take any
anything obviously hard to find a move
for white there's just not nothing much
you can do back with his oh G4 is a
terrible idea don't open up your own
King
this is this is the desperation tactic
when you kind of really run out of ideas
so you just start pushing pawns scary
happens I feel like this might be this
might be the beginning of the end
oh my God yep yeah he's bringing in all
the troops This Is War he's not holding
back
all right Queen on e4 hits the pawn on
H4 and there's just no way to defend it
if you play F3 ah give it two Pawns yeah
now black is a choice a menu of options
between Queen takes E3 and queen takes
H4
either capture is really good for black
but first they should have done is just
hang in there and reroute her Rook so
maybe rookie three Rook a one over Queen
up
um but very common when you feel stuck
you push pawns because you don't know
what to do oh but he didn't take either
of the free Pawns
and she does not defend he can still
take E3 and that's a huge Pawn to lose
because then your whole King side just
collapses on the spot but maybe problems
is just stable light maybe he'll bring
his Knight back into the game via Knight
C7
that's another possibility
okay he's thinking he's got three
minutes on the clock like he's taking a
solid 30 seconds per move speed up soon
unpleased with this position but he's
really doing great he's up Shane just
gotta Free Pawn he chooses to
fight Pawn which yes he didn't take
right away but you could say oh my God
this is just allowing the Knight outpost
on G4 which is gonna make the blow on E3
even stronger and open the tag pack on
H4 if he finds this move which he
accidentally walked into a very
interesting night move last game if he
does it again but Knight G4 would be a
beautiful move
Knight G4 as well as Knight E4 as well
as Queen takes E3 played absolutely
because it sets up the threat of Knight
G4 and that seems to be the beginning of
the enthusi has to try to get this Queen
off of e3 I would play Queen's position
is lost the position is lost but you
just want to extend the game and the way
to extend the game is to try to get the
Queens off the board make it a little
bit harder for black to make decisive
progress
chat says seems like he realizes the
night can come in now too I didn't know
you're a mind reader oh cool
Chad is capable of everything
that's you should know that by now
Andrea Chad there's nothing that Chad
can't do but speaking of chat they were
asking about C4
ooh
C4 is a great very cool move yeah it's
probably the best move well other than
Queen F3 I think C4 is possible black
drops the queen back though it's not it
doesn't change the nature of the
position The Rook on B3 doesn't have any
good squares along the third rank that
it can go to I like this move Queen D2
fusely doing the right thing
yeah C4 looks really nice but if
anything after the queen would have
moves would open B4 for that other dark
Square Knight and doesn't really make a
difference
okay I think it would have been a good
countertech
less than three minutes now this could
get down to the wire in terms of the
clock
he's thinking about the check on G3 but
that check can be covered by White's
Rook
yep but then black just skins collecting
them pawns wait actually no because
because G6 is going to be hanging
still lost but at least the position
becomes a little bit more tactical and
he is leaning
might get a pawn trade here white maybe
opens black skin
foreign
then black gets into E4 and she does she
blocks to The Rook
now he's probably gonna take that pawn
yeah the hard thing is
G6 you can just goes step seven not that
way yeah actually nice never mind yeah
he attacks the rook and now black will
have a lot of threats Rook the Knight
coming to G4 trying to infiltrate the
holes there's a lot that can happen in
this position
okay but at this point he's in too deep
like I don't know what he's thinking oh
it's not a blunder technically it's a
queen trade but
oh he wants to take the queen and hit
the Rook on B3 but that Rook on B3 can
escape through A3 so this just extends
the game and it gives the side of the
time Advantage more chances which in
this case
getting off the board
[Music]
gives her practice
position is still dead lost for white
objectively like make no mistake but
also she has to realize what's going on
here and it's very possible that instead
she moves her Queen
foreign
moves
and she has moved her Queen
she has moved her Queen but maybe not
such a bad idea because the queen is
aiming at H5 so now Papa plate has to
move his Queen I would still take on H4
white will take the pawn on G6 with
check and the King's drops away to F7 or
H7 no good follow-up there for white
two minutes
yeah this might actually have been the
best strap for fusely to really put the
pressure on him under under time
pressure I think not simplifying the
pieces when he's already a better ball
oh what did he do he just left his Queen
on G3 he didn't move his Queen oh my god
let's let's see Bruce Lee come on take
the queen this is everything all right
everything we trained for even though
you ghosted me come on
oh he played it he realized it he played
it at the moment he released his King he
grabbed his head and firstly he's not
seeing it at all neither side is aware
that the queen is just sitting there
the queen is hanging it's one square
away
I want to see her realize
to see it no I think she's not even
looking at the king size she's like yeah
he's doing tinkering with something
there and let me go on the queen side
and that's it that was the chance the
queen has been saved ladies and
gentlemen
and to check him here
she is she's yoloing it that's what's
happened
queens
[Music]
and just giving it all away she thinks
maybe that the uh other Rook is
defending G6 maybe she's forgotten about
the C6 Pawn I don't know but she's she's
losing the threat of this game
giving everything away you know yeah
Rook B7 the queen takes night but okay
okay
she's in the blundering on our piece of
stage you know yeah and that's okay and
then I'll go before is
is very relieved right now because his
reaction to that Queen
I mean and that wasn't just a queen when
black would recapture White's Rook that
White's Queen would also swing forward
to like E6 or E5 and start picking away
the rest of Black's pieces but fousey's
only chance here is the clock Papa latte
is still playing very slowly he just has
to trust his instincts okay Queen is
hanging move the queen take the pawn on
F4 and play Quinn F6 doesn't matter but
he's under a minute now and he does take
on that one time pressure he's got that
Knight hanging on A6
but it's it's not gonna make I just did
so well and then just decided to start
sacrificing everything
some some German went over and handed
her a check it must have been a paid
actor like I don't trust this this is
some funny business
now fusley has to curl up into a ball
and literally just watch Black's clock
tick down which it is
50 seconds he's got to start moving
faster you can't get down to five
seconds because a lot of these players
they're just not used to playing on
increment right they're not Hikaru yeah
some of them don't even know it exists
actually yes why their clock is adding
time okay here's the night
oh no
she's giving away all her pieces
will come
yeah that's actually that's actually a
very powerful maneuver devised it's
never going to see the light of day
because why he's gonna give away all her
pieces way before that happens
fret
he covers with the knife something oh we
don't
yeah I mean even a draw is suitable to
Papa plot that will win him the match
but this one
who sleeve was thinking
but open her mic Maybe
Knight F3 check would end the game 30
seconds though Andrea for papa plaza
he's gotta not overthink it just trade
coins and wins oh well look at that move
Queen takes out four there's Knight Fork
on H3
and he just wins I don't think she's in
the business of taking Queens
oh my God this is no she's blundered it
instead
again and then
and he didn't know but the crazy thing
is it's not a free Queen he can win it
back with a fork but he clearly did not
anticipate he did not design that he
blundered it oh my God this the end of
this game has been painful oh and he
doesn't take the queen I mean that check
doesn't hurt anything
and now he does
[Music]
work I think when you're thinking
please chill
yeah oh my God
oh he's just taking it well her
stalemate Strat has worked really well
she didn't even pieces and she has given
all of hers away now the final test for
Papa plate does he know how to checkmate
at this point it doesn't even matter
because he's guaranteed even if he's
stalemates he still wins the match
I know but I I would feel like somehow
Bruce Lee's plan was accomplished if
this was a stalemate it would make at
least all the pain that we went through
a little bit better it would be
completely fitting given the end of this
game
he's not holding back he has no mercy
and D1 equals Queens pre-move will lead
to a check
and there it is Nick
yeah I think he sees D2 and D1 very
Advanced Strat gg gg I heard him so I
understood that it finished
foreign
good one oh
well that is the art of pogchamps ladies
and gentlemen nothing makes sense
sometimes that is questioning our
existence I wasn't sure what we were
commentating earlier because it was very
unpog champs-like these first mat the
first match this this match has been a
little bit more Pock champs-like but a
big congrats to Papa plot he wins 2-0
and fusely she's passionate she has her
moments right she has moments of clarity
but too many one move blunders and just
losing the threat of the game in the
second half which is understandable
she'll keep it going maybe in her third
Hawkins performance she will that will
be third time will be the charm as uh
Papa plot secures his qualification into
the Champions bracket along with I did a
thing
yeah papa plate could be a very good
Contender for the championship rocket I
think Papa plate xqc and the other group
I think we have ghastly these were some
very strong players I'm very excited to
see papa plate take on all the other
champions
yeah he was really just like focused
Uber focused the queen blunders were out
of character for him I really feel like
he is stronger than he showed himself to
be in the last part but folks we will
have three more matches today Andrea
you're gonna stay on the grind I will
leave you guys and David yes
this was super fun Andrea thank you post
some chess streamer and now he's in
medicine he's leaving
thank you Andrea uh Danny wrench will
replace me after this thank you
everybody thank you Andrea and pogchamps
will return with QT versus I did a thing
in just a couple of moments
thank you
[Music]
Rook takes Knight and now Queen F2 Queen
g2's just game over like yeah and oh and
he's Queen up two oh no oh no oh no
we have two Lodge if misses it clean up
two
[Music]
oh no the only one oh we missed it and
now he's made it because me Ludwig is a
force made in two I know he's made it
[Applause]
and then Queen C8 and there was actually
a staircase Checkmate oh man logic
through maybe Seven's made me oh Rook D6
57 Queen D7 they're three mates here for
white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
today we're gonna go down into the New
York City subway set up a table on the
subway platform and see if we get some
strangers waiting for their trains to
play chess with us
[Music]
all right I'm gonna see if I can get
anybody
sounds like he knows what he's doing a
little bit
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good got the chess.com app
do you ever play on your phone oh yeah
he said he barely played I'm a teacher
what do you teach chess I'm just kidding
self-defense how do you stay sane I used
to do a lot of meditation take
medication
what's like lesson 101 of self-defense
run what are you listening to right now
train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran what is the meaning
of life it's funny because like what I'm
doing I feel like doesn't align with my
philosophy on what the meaning of life
is but it's like obviously spent as much
time with family as possible the best
person you can be get closer to God not
to be evil to each other
good game thank you
good games
I'll see you in a self-defense class
enjoy Harry Styles
[Music]
come on
let's go
[Music]
foreign
we are back here with POG Champs 5
Andrea you just got downgraded you went
from a grand master named Daniel to an
international master named Daniel but I
hope you'll have me here for the rest
absolutely not a downgrade we are
honored and lucky to be blessed with the
presence of both of you honestly you
should have just taken my spot if
anything I'm I'm the Imposter here but
it's exciting we get both Best of Both
Worlds with Donya he's teaching me all
about the urban dictionary of Chess and
he had all these innuendos so I'm
excited to see what you bring to the
table today I don't think I have the
puns or the innuendos that John yeah I I
a dad great a Dan Gray I did throw out
my I did throw up my back watching
fusely and papa Placo at it which
doesn't make any sense but I it took
some Advil so we're all going to be okay
and uh hi Hikaru just want to make sure
I acknowledge yeah he's there no Chad
was saying they really wanted Hikaru to
commentate today but he has been very
unsatisfied with the performance and so
he's drinking talking his coffee and
looking very disapproving from the back
background so maybe maybe if we get some
good wins in the next games then he will
return to the table maybe cutie
Cinderella will bring it out of him and
we know that she's about to throw down
and make her POG Champs debut cutie it's
uh it's been too long since she dumped
jumped in right she's taking on I did a
thing and she's the next match up
followed by xqc and uh and Ginny in just
a little bit these next matches are
gonna be hype cutie Cinderella she has
been training she has been improving in
chess we got blessed with her presence
in the very first POG Champs and she has
been playing chess since then so I'm
very excited to see we have I did a
thing streaming all the way from
Australia he has also we did a lesson
with him many weeks ago so he has been
doing chess puzzles and training for
this day for many weeks to come so that
is not going to be an easy battle for
either side and then the long-awaited
xqc match yes he is showing up he showed
up yesterday he's gonna take on Ginny
the queen of IRL streaming
um you know I really can't predict who's
gonna win that one because they're just
so close in skill level I think suc is
going to win 2-0 I just hope Jenny feels
okay about it but let's talk about cutie
real quick because uh she's amazing
she's a streamer YouTuber podcaster
she's also the founder and co-host of
the streamer Awards where she's uh made
even more of a name for herself I think
we all know that there was a danger that
cutie might have peaked at POG Champs
too but we talked about it and lucky for
her she didn't Peak with POG Champs too
her career has continued and she's even
played more than 1500 games on chess.com
and there she is the queen herself
getting ready to go
I'm really excited Cutie's got cutie
brings a different energy to
I wonder if
it would be Ludwig the co-host of the
tournament and she's looking at Taylor
Swift tour okay
yeah I didn't I didn't uh I I don't know
that her and Ludwig have played a lot of
Chess it's actually funny we'd have to
scroll through her profile I don't know
what happened Chris who wins woman grand
master key Cinderella yes
um yeah maybe if we put some Taylor
Swift tickets on the line she'll be more
motivated to win
yeah that's true we know that she's been
balancing you know streamer camps and
Disneyland visits and all the things but
I know she is also excited she was one
of the first people to say I'm back at
pod Champs is back so even though it
took a minute she's here then we've got
the guy with the you know all I've
noticed is his accent I'm just I I owned
it before I I ended the show on Monday
I'm a sucker for a sexy Australian
accent it's just the truth and uh there
you go outside of his sexy Australian
accent I did a thing is a man of many
crafts and a man who doesn't fear
anything if you've ever seen his YouTube
channel he performs probably some of the
most dangerous content on YouTube he's
nearly like lost his fingers the hermit
crabs many times literally has been face
to face with deadly sharks in the
Australian Waters he has even come to
America to film a video called how many
shorts will stop a bullet so he is not
afraid of dying and he's not afraid to
take on cutie Cinderella which is really
equally as scary I was gonna say now
he's doing the most dangerous thing of
all playing in a chess tournament I'm
sure he's gonna say that that this is
the most scary thing he's ever done in
his life I bet I bet that he would say
that uh when he's all said and done he
was actually very nervous for this
tournament which is very funny
considering but if you guys haven't seen
his YouTube channel probably one of my
favorite video channels on YouTube so we
are honored to have both creators
playing this game
we are and everyone knows and loves I
was honored to watch you and Dania by
the way you guys were having a blast a
lot of fun so I'm excited to step in the
games are starting and if you're just
tuning in here we go it's cutie
Cinderella back back I said she has been
training with Anna Anna Rudolph or Anna
kremling there's a lot of Anna's in the
Chess World but yeah I'm curious if
cutie has been taking any chess lessons
yeah I I know she's been ghosting me
since I offered chess lessons back at
pogchamps too so I can confirm that
she's not taking lessons from me
confirmed here live yeah the common
pattern in the chess Community is US
chess player and getting ghosted by cool
big streamers we just need to get cooler
cooler than than me and you already that
was I don't get it that yeah yeah never
mind sorry okay I was gonna say that was
weird that you honestly I was super
weird that you would even say that
honestly we're really cool Danny and
that shirt is making you look even
cooler like cool people wear chess ponds
on their shirt while commentating chess
and it doesn't get better than this it
doesn't I agree let's let's talk about
the chest because it doesn't get better
than cutie Cinderella Stonewall for
anyone who's not a fan of cutie uh you
should check out her chess openings
because when she seriously when she
committed in POG Champs 2 and then
continued doing lessons with Gotham and
others there for a while she really
committed to learning The Stonewall and
I'm just gonna quickly go through the
opening to show you what that is that's
when you play this D4 E3 and then
normally if you can you play F4 next to
really hold on to the dark squares in
the center and the nice thing is that
normally this is an opening Andrea that
cutie can play against anything but
unfortunately or fortunately I did a
thing played like the one move that that
stops the Stonewall which is just gives
up the E5 Pawn uh and she just had to
take it so I'm very curious if um Alex
has prepared for Cutie or if that was
just a coincidence because this is
compared to the game we just came from a
London position which hey no slander on
the London this is a very spicy opening
position that we're getting into very
quickly
if I if I had to guess there's a decent
chance that he prepared this is working
out for cutie but it's only because when
uh when she played F4 after F6
he didn't take the pawn on E5 which he
probably had a chance to do instead he
played Bishop F5 so I wonder if someone
gave him a tip of playing this movie
five to stop her from from getting her
normal stuff so anyway secret coach
because I started as his chess coach we
did one lesson and then there were no
more so on it's funny you and I have a
very similar pattern we give people one
lesson and then they never return our
calls after that true I have two
students we did many lessons and they're
at the top of their group
um but yeah Alex must be doing some
secret training over in Australia
all right well he plays G6
about this move it's interesting it's
obvious if he's playing it with the idea
with the idea of being keto in great
right and and that's going to put more
pressure here
um but at the POG Champs event sometimes
we're guessing at what might be inside
their head and it can be a dark and
Mysterious World in there
um and so I don't know what he what he's
what he's trying to do next with G6
unless it's Bishop to G7
and cuties development here is so far
very straightforward you and it's she
has to know to keep the pressure here
I'm assuming because white does not want
to take the pawn on Wow wait the email
bar is just completely winning for white
I feel like I'm missing something let me
turn my brain on for a second
all right well let's listen to her maybe
she'll see why she's winning let's do it
then he's like yeah that's chess
commentators
I'm not gonna lie I'd rather hear what
cutie has to say then then your analysis
not because your analysis is bad no no
you know
okay I take here he takes
I take
he takes
it's even
but then when he takes he checks
then I don't I think I have some idea
then I don't take when his Knight comes
here and instead
uh um okay I feel good about this I'm
not gonna take with my knight your
analysis is bad yes
bring this guy here
I don't know if that's smart I I'm not
thinking ahead
okay
so he had a great worst case his Knight
can go here
wait no here wait back up here
here
I'm just gonna pressure it because I'm
already ahead so I'm not gonna be crazy
this is like
this is incredibly high level chess
right now from cutie
I'm not gonna lie I mean like she she
calculated taking but she's like I'm not
going to take a second time because then
he'll check my king I'm just going to
develop and put pressure because I'm
already winning which she recognizes I
mean this is this is great stuff Taylor
Swift concerts apparently make you
better at chess and yeah
even though so the eval bar is like so
high up and so much in favor of white
and there might not be an obvious you
know tactic like he's winning a pawn
even though right now there's a lot of
puns under attack but it's okay you know
what this position needs no more
analysis
um never mind I was about to go into a
very deep positional understanding about
how black is underdeveloped and what's
ahead in development but the game is
ladies and gentlemen the Australian has
lost to the Rook this is like what did
Levy say you don't scream The Rook when
it's a bad move you only screen The Rook
when you're sacrificing it Levy's not
here so we can do whatever we want right
The Rook he lost the rook and it's over
and I agree with your analysis you were
about to give it was going to be
instructional to describe why black is
losing so much not using his pieces but
it doesn't matter because she's up a
rook it's over
man that one that one hurted
that did hurt it it hurted big time it
heard it yeah you can face the sharks in
the water big spiers the hermit crabs
but and face cutie Cinderella
they're saying he can still win of
course he can still win this is POG
Champs it's the most exciting chess
event in the world I literally don't
know what's gonna happen next I would
typically stand by that statement but
not against Cinderella
yeah I I said before the event Andrea
and I don't remember where I said it and
so I'm gonna say it as if I said it on
the record you're just gonna believe me
that I did but I think two OG's of POG
Champs would easily be overlooked by
fans and those are xqc and cutie because
they haven't won yet and they played in
so many and people are like ah they're
whatever but the truth is yesterday
Felix was was amazing and he has gotten
so much better and cutie is a way better
player than she was when she first
started so I actually believe that cutie
and Phil and Felix are legitimate
threats to win the whole thing I just
want to say that on record now
I'm trading Queens when you're up
winning material you know this is a way
to make life simple I think she could
have also totally kept the Queens on the
board placing like 94 trying to just put
pressure towards the king but this is
such a solid Strat and cutie is playing
like a veteran she knows what she's
doing who invited Robert Hess who would
why is he what is you even Robert it's
past your bedtime go to bed
why is there no Hess commentary Hess I'm
missing I don't I don't wanna I don't
want to reveal any personal news for my
man Robert but he's got a lot going on
so he's uh he's got a lot going on so I
hope everything is well with you and we
miss you and everybody
and he was I think Judy Cinderella's
chest coach yeah or maybe Ludwig's um
apparently he's her he's his favorite
she is his favorite co-commentator which
doesn't make me feel bad at all
well you know he's he's a legend we only
get blessed with his presence once in a
while so you have to appreciate
greatness when you're near the face of
it
it's sort of it's true I would I would
say that until five minutes ago
um all right well no cutie is dominant
and I love what you said Andrea we got
distracted by hess uh but she played
Queen D5 check took the Queens off the
board and this is what I was saying like
I'm not just saying it for the hyper
like oh yeah whatever like I think cutie
and Felix are two of the best players in
the field and also because they're
experienced they're not going to get I
think as nervous as a guy like virtual
might I know virtual is a strong player
but I think I think cutie and uh and
Felix are are gonna bring it that's my
prediction I'd like to see a nice E4
move here by cutie just opening up that
file nice yes let's go
dude this is this is a I'm looking at
the real-time accuracy of this game this
is one of those games where all those
self-proclaimed cheat detectives would
email support and be like my opponent
cheated because they played it 96
accuracy like she is playing a 96
accurate game right now and no she's not
cheating uh I Gotta Give it to I did a
thing he doesn't have that many pieces
to his to play with but
move active hitting the knights bringing
it into the game to put pressure on the
pawn and the bishop a good move a good
move
agreed oh I like to open their mics I
haven't seen this look yet
Judy knows what's up she's doing the
gallon jug see only real girls drink out
of gallon water bottles like me too
maybe I just move this out gotta stay
hydrated
walkabouts
Australia I think your accent broke the
stream Danny they don't like it when you
do that don't make fun of Australians
I love I I do not make fun of
Australians that's one thing I don't do
good moves here what are my good moves
I was gonna say we should do a dual open
mic
chest wrap off
freestyle chess off
um I don't know if
did we lose chat or did we lose cutie
something has happened we've lost oh I
think this did this stream just am I
going crazy just like died wait am I
seeing things Danny stop pushing I have
no idea I think we're live somehow
we're always yeah
I think your accent was so unbelievably
bad
it could be I'll keep the Australian
accent away then for now
and be careful with that we don't want
to unleash that Lethal Weapon already
hey chat we're back we're back we're
back don't panic chat don't worry
cootie's Got The Jug everything we're
safe guys we're safe
where is my job
and then she can't push
then does she have a
she have a
foreign
I think I find the zoom commentary when
they're not even streaming to be even
more entertaining in some ways because
they're just kind of talking to
themselves right just the crazy person
playing chess in your basement exactly
it makes me feel more like connected to
them because they're just a crazy person
they'll talk to ourselves once in a
while and that's okay
yeah
maybe I'm thinking about this too much
it's tight there Judy's not even giving
him a pawn or a guy won't even give him
a Crump
she's
ruthlessly well she can't take it the
king is so close to checkmate Rook C7
and then he has no squares to go
and bring in the other rook and it's
it's game but you know what black has it
passed on now you can't just take it yet
but if she wanted to she could drive
something like G4 attacking the defender
even this even this is fantastic right
bringing the Rook end
the King has to go back to either E7 or
F7 and
okay there's a lot of moves why I could
play here objectively black should
actually lose in just a few moves if the
best moves yeah but I think she just
doubles the Rooks and then just brings
them in and roll her lower mates
rollermate rollerblade whatever happened
to roller rinks you know like a
Skateland kind of thing right yeah you
know some things are better just falling
out of dress is that is that a thing is
like the most like unexciting it's
almost worse than bowling I know like
how how shocked are you when you see
someone roller skating in like a public
area like it's like it's like
legitimately shocking these days
suspended all the first League of
Legends players now the roller skaters
I'm sorry chat you gotta know when
you're commentating with Denny No One Is
Safe he will come forever if anyone is
out there roller skating like talk about
the lack of self-awareness you might as
well be naked running down the street if
you're if you're roller skating like
well you clearly haven't ever been to
Venice Beach in California because we
got best of both there all right well
let's look at the cutie and see if she
finds Ricky oh my God she's 100
yeah let's tune in yeah
I think I come over here
so then his only office and then I take
very nice
option board that's ahead of whatever I
want to go here
and she took such seven no way great who
would have thought okay
I'm sorry I'll minimize the other board
that was an accident that's okay it's
okay I would have liked if she kept the
Rooks on the board a roller mate would
have been night too nice to make Justice
skaters we offended today but that's not
happening
all of those roller skaters out there
all seven of you left on the planet
um
jokes all day that's like such a random
thing to be making jokes about but I'm
glad that you have yeah I should pull
this over here so then I can actually
attack because they see QT
yeah I freaking love roller skating Don
you would never do us like that
first of all I love rollerblading but
roller skating like evolve you get what
I'm saying beat
okay I'm closing all right rookie one
super smart by cutie
yeah he's got that passer he's trying
he's using everything he has
now we see why it has prefers Beauty
Cinderella hey you watched it okay yes
you shush your you shush your mouth when
you're chatting with me
uni has been playing chess for a much
longer time than I did you guys
crabs
traps he's up against us intimidating
opponent okay I swear to God
it's true I watch it he's intimidating
he's scary like honestly I think I'm
actually legitimately scared of cutie
Cinderella they're not that good yeah I
mean for many reasons not not our chess
but I agree with that yeah wait it's my
turn to get out of Judy's bad side yeah
agreed
is cracked
I mean she has been here since day one
chat when back in the old days three
years
in three years we all make mistakes
everybody has those days everybody knows
what what I'm talking about everybody
2023.
Judy didn't even play in podcasts
whatever ah yes but she started playing
chess because I remember we did a hand
and brain match with her yeah during
that time so she started playing chess
just other stuff word when I couldn't
drink alcohol true
you still can't drink alcohol
yeah
I'm 21 but I just don't really enjoy
alcohol okay there you go good choice
all right night night FH check next is
going to be nitrog6 check if the king
takes the pawn Little Fork town
um
look at this like she's just I just
wanna I wanna start I know she hasn't
won yet but I just want to be like cutie
I know we're rooting also for I did a
thing I'm not I'm not trying to be I
know clearly you're clearly rooting for
both hey I already said I love it I
already said I love his accent okay so
would I be upset if an incredibly
awesome accent one never all right but
cutie is a fan favorite I I you know no
shame in that
well you know what if if cutie is a big
favorite I shall root
Australian
side so that
yeah
um
people who who
um naturally speak with an accent really
love when you try to fake their accent
like they love it like they don't get
offended at all and it doesn't bother
them yeah Danny unbiased friendship it
is middle name chat
all right you did many things
yeah that's right B5 is played Bishop B6
no Cutie's cleaning up here I mean we
gotta we gotta applaud the fact that uh
regardless of I did a thing being new
that she's playing well that's all she's
she's uh bringing it now I'm as I'm
saying all that
the advantage has dwindled a little bit
and I did a thing is holding on so we
have a stalemate potential
yep I think I think this will drink some
water to that opening was this game was
very difficult for I did a thing because
she played kind of a crazy line I have a
feeling that he stumbled into that E5
thing he didn't mean it and she just
kind of got a huge advantage in the
opening she was also in a territory she
knew very well so the next game could be
very different
agreed to him
population US
um Danny loves to Gaslight chat it's one
of my favorite things in the world
actually thank you for saying that how's
that for being gaslighting I'm
acknowledging you're right well I do
love it I love gaslighting chat it's one
of my favorite things
all right
the um the move H4 is played maybe that
was Cutie 700 she has been playing with
she's absolutely not 700. yeah she's
sandbagging she's sandbagging for sure
I guess she hasn't been playing that
many online rated games but I'm confused
he's played 1500 games I think she
started playing a lot of Blitz though so
rapid and Blitz
I wonder what her rapid rating is chat
does anyone know no this is her rapid
that's what I'm saying I mean sorry her
Blitz oh yeah yeah we'd have to look I
feel like she could literally be 1500
Blitz
maybe not quite that high but yeah yeah
oh you're right I'm not good with
numbers look at a fact check on that
stat guide
we have confidence we know we we know
you know how to win this
and it's also sorry I overestimated yes
it's fortunate for her that
well I think it would be hard
to not win or not Queen the H bomb
because the bishop is the same color as
as the court and so she I was wondering
if she would do this because she's gonna
be in a position where she can advance
the pawn and then protect it and I and I
think she'll she'll see all this
plan Danny she knows how to win this end
game but um to bring her King to the
sixth rank she's got a bishop like
there's she's got enough ammo to make
this
I think we should tune into Cutie's
stream because yeah I don't think she
did to do what she's doing she don't
know oh my God
games right right I'll say that
she doesn't even know
she's literally just threw so mindlessly
oh my God no I don't bro wait is it a
draw
there's so many ways embarrassing no one
tell my dad
oh my God never mind
oh that's a creative idea
I don't think he's gonna fall for it oh
man well I did a thing I hate you as a
human and every I just hate him I hate
him damn I actually don't like him as a
person
did nothing but try to survive I guess
that's literally what he does for a
living He just tries to survive in very
dangerous situations and and it paid off
I'm not gonna lie like I I I'm afraid of
cutie so I'm afraid to say this but that
was one of the most that was one of the
biggest throws we've seen like this year
you joined late today okay you have not
witnessed I have watched three boats has
gamuts in a row no Ford on both sides
half the protest gambits aren't even
taken this is a position where it's like
she gave back one piece after the other
she gave back the rook and gave back the
pawn and gave back and I well anyway
is
this is what happens when you're biased
we were all rooting for Cutie too much
we blew up our ego and we got a drop but
this is good I like this comeback era
for I did a thing felt like we were all
like really hard rooting for Cutie
Cinderella and honestly impressive this
is why you never resign we witnessed
earlier today where daily dose resigned
literally a pretty drawn end game never
resigned in pogchamps that's the most
important lesson of today
let's see what I did a thing had to say
yeah he was excited
there he was
can't even see him but I but I bet it's
adorable I bet everything he's saying is
adorable with an accent that is just
golden oh my gosh wow that that was why
another game but yeah just for anyone
wondering how you were supposed to win
that end game the secret is to bring
your king to the sixth rank you can't
see anything but see that board right
behind me six drink is like that one
kind of okay yeah that one towards the
end all right we're almost there [__]
right there I'm here there's this oh my
god there it is so you bring your King
right there and then the other kings
right there
um and then you push your pawn and then
you kick the king out in front of the
Pod but you don't push the pawn you
gotta bring in the king and um you know
what in most scenarios the king is
pretty useless but in this one it was
not it was very important
we've ever had of all time thank you for
that yeah thank you for that real you
should be like a weather a weather woman
for chess you know like I can describe
how to do this bring it closer there you
go
um any Hooters what we've got here is a
bad game from cutie and now she needs to
rebound so Danny just went from I love
cutie Cutie's the strongest POG chamber
out there yeah cutie cutie Cutie cutie
Cutie played a game and she sucks no
because my prede I want my prediction to
work out I think she's one of the best
players in the event but that didn't go
as to plan if you are thinking cutie is
going to win those games that's all so
anyway let's go I am rooting for Cutie
now I'm not even gonna pretend I'm not
even being biased or unbiased about it
um but uh it's not working out well
we're getting a lot of question marks on
the board so this is
like a London just without the bishop
there but white does the right thing
trying to open up this Pawn open the
file for the Rooks you can develop the
Bishops and now the pawn is also hanging
almost not yet not quite not yet sorry
anyhow let's see what cutie has to say
yeah Bishop Bishop G5
next
okay
[Music]
gotta see the bish
and rookie rookie one is nice too she
has [__] she wants another story oh no
actually I forget Alex is playing the
white pieces Alex has a beautiful
position
agreed and but cutie wants the Stonewall
structure so at least she got that going
forward
okay he should have used the Rook it
would have been a lot more threatening
because then you couldn't really block
with
[Music]
very night but will she see the
discovery if he takes the D5 plus
they're eating me up I I don't know
that's a bit of a a bit of a five head
play
oh yeah that's a big tactic
that's a big one
big I'm just gonna start
okay well he's reading words for free
make things seem more dramatic
I think
I think that is coming
I think I'm already screwed what
happened
I have an idea okay so she's doing it
she did it right the problem is she sees
the D5 Pawn is hanging
wait but she didn't see she had a tactic
we'll have to show it on the board when
we're back but there was a yeah
yeah he blundered it
all right so oh my God
no no no she missed it never mind
all right it's even harder than it
looked though because it's even harder
than to look because you you would like
to play the discovered check and win the
queen but it doesn't work because the
Knight is for not like that the Knight
is protecting the queen so you have to
take on C3 first
yes
and if you're familiar this is one of
those puzzles where it's like you do
puzzle Rush once or twice and then
hopefully remember it forever because
it's a very common
um chest puzzle and a very common
pattern in the board but if you're not
familiar with it it's not that easy to
spot but once you fall for this once and
you lose your queen once you'll never
forget it and I speak from experience
agreed Tim
but oh by the way look at that I did a
thing played G3 after that almost like
he saw it coming he played G3 to close
down the diagonal so that's uh that's a
pretty nice move I am glad that he
didn't lose this queen that would have
felt after the last game just really
unsatisfying if you would have just lost
again
well now he's not only now losing his
Queen he's he's totally in control this
is completely turned around from a a
match that Judy had and my my bold
prediction that she was one of the
favorites in the event good job on that
one Dan yeah there's a lot of holes in
the position those dark squared
weaknesses there's a lot of potential
trades his Knights are active you could
trade the night he could bring his
Knight to G5 he has a rook on this file
like I'm really loving White's position
we should turn on his mic in here but
what he's doing
let's do it if he's doing his thing or
not I think he's talking he's probably
there just you know talking about
walkabouts
I need my Pawn to move
and I think I think when you give him
the pro tip on the mic moving closer
I don't think he's streaming chat we
planted a secret camera in his house and
we're actually recording him without his
permission yeah he doesn't even know
that he's Mike he doesn't know he's
getting watched by 1000 people right now
well I just ate
I think I gotta eat that horse I gotta
eat that horse with my horse
that's yeah let's do that it's true
the way he sits he says it the horse
beat her horse with the horse
now that's good chess commentary
I love it the uh I don't understand why
we always say it's like eat the horse in
front of the Rook cause you don't feed
chest pain do I still have more people
no for starving all the chess players
that's not bad I mean I can't eat it
[__]
that's
just it was funny though and then trade
there
I think I know what you're going to
you're going to see Knight takes
the queen but then
it actually could accidentally work out
I
if he takes and cutie wins the queen it
actually blunders into a discovered
Checkmate on EA so there's we could have
POG Champs magic here everyone buckle up
there could be something magic I was
looking at the queen Fork I didn't even
notice the the mate on the back rank
wait okay Knight takes E4 is genius
right now come on
but the other thing that's funny is even
though that's true
and and this wasn't a good move yeah
like I actually think it was the best
move given their level because she
scared him by pitting the night
all right you guys didn't spam Australia
and look what happened you weren't fast
enough get on top of your game chat
I guess it's a big word it's hard to
spell we need something a little bit
more
spammable
what do Australians spam yeah
well they're doing it they're doing it
so Aussie this is getting tricky while
we're spamming Aussie it's very
important that the Aussies sees the
queen hanging which means white needs to
take on D7 and then take back the bishop
if he takes back right now we have that
botes Gambit that should have happened
actually moves the ghost so maybe it's
just eight doing its part
nice good stuff
yeah but again even though Bishop before
was a move that blundered into this
brilliant 94 it was actually maybe the
best move she could play because they
were both kind of thinking the same
thing about how to stop Knight takes E4
so Vegemite now it's not Australia now
it's back to equal have you ever had
Vegemite
um that is a negatory
very unappealing it sounds sounds like
something my mom would cook with in our
Romanian soups I'm not a fan no maybe
maybe not I think they're like they're
like dried veggies I think they're like
chips you know like I think
uh that's what I think
I don't quote me on that we'll get a
fact check on that but I think veggie
mites are actually maybe delicious
so we'll find out
um but it's good to know you donate your
vegetables or like your mom's soup will
someone clip that I do both
um but yeah my
my mom would eat soup for three meals a
day all the time so I'm a little bit
jaded I've had a lot of soup in my life
I love soup by the way putting water on
your food brings out more flavor fact
soup is delicious okay now you're making
me hungry you know you just hopped in 10
minutes ago I've been here since 10 45
a.m
I'm well fed I I had a I had an RX bar
and a banana I'm feeling ready
this is great that's all I got great all
right C4 guess what that is
hold on
it's explosive it's dynamites explosive
I did it that one that was a good one
Danny you're so cool well but seriously
he played the pawn forward which was
nice oop I gotta I gotta get rid of the
vomiting I gotta get rid of the bomb
played the pawn forward and he took it
full for it and uh
um cutie did and now she's in control
it's been a really a really beautiful
game for I did a thing
um but it wasn't an easy move to find
but now we're in
our middle game territory not as
exciting stuff everything's looking kind
of even white just needs to defend and
play Slowly
but the knights are coming in cutie is
threatening Knight G4 we should um tune
in cutie see if she's planning this or
if this was a coincidence because also
it was just a good Square for the night
although
I think the knights are are not nasty
here nights are nasty nasty nights
astinaz and nasty nights no nastyness
if I say if I say that's a knife do you
even know what movie I'm talking about
but you don't know nasty nuts so I got
you there sucker I know who Nasty Nas is
okay no I don't know nasty knife but no
that's a knife that's from Crocodile
Dundee the most famous Australian ever
and he's the one who died the crocodile
I think I I do no that's Steve Irwin
um
Crocodile Dundee is one of the greatest
movies of all time have you not seen
Crocodile Dundee no it's over here
die in the end or he lives because then
I can at least Fork that it's a romantic
comedy it's a great movie it's not
fighting crocodiles in a while no no
Knight G4 is played cutie is on a roll
with the Knights by the way I think she
sees that F2 to stay off purple squares
when they have one of these guys
oh she likes to sing on purple squares
Pawn with the other
products
this is also what my brain is thinking
when I play chess
the trumpet Mundo
nothing else
this gives me a fork
I'm gonna be good cutie don't touch that
one
maybe you know what you're right stay
off the purples
she doesn't see the pin on the road
oh my god um
this could be the match
you ate this bull
do that
do not move that night
checks captures attacks is what they say
Robert is always watching don't do it
don't do it
right questions but she doesn't have the
answers yeah
don't do it
something I think you're missing
something out of pure anxiety I don't
like him no no he did it no this is
literally losing I don't know he might
not he might
back then
no way dude no way
it's good sometimes it happens we forget
things
it happens to the best of us the worst
thing is she pointed out the attack and
then forgot and then fell for the same
blender
well hold on wait what is he doing why
didn't he just what wait oh she could
have taken it wait she didn't
take the night there's
neither of them see it oh man that was
so rough
I can push the pawn
this is like the greatest subset of POG
Champs if Alex wins this because hoodie
was a huge favorite not to like rub in
the middle or anything but it's true
yeah seriously keep rubbing it in sorry
all of us cuties she might come back she
might come back I'm gonna tell her you
weren't rooting for her and they used to
deal with her I I was and then we were
all rooting for her and I felt bad for
like four neglected student over in
Australia
two Rooks
the only thing I feel bad for about is
that I think it's like 2 A.M the next
day for Australia like the following day
a.m
he's like he's living a day and a half
in the future right he already knows
what happened
on August 3rd
okay so he plays a three she's gotta
move her knight uh elbishi that is
incorrect I'd prefer to go buy my USPS
not my CD rating and it is 19. maybe 98.
I don't have a check it was a good year
that was a good year you weren't even
born yet
I mean I
bringing in the pressure
he could have at least taken the night
back
once maybe just start taking points oh
no I could like walk into
no I think we're gonna get a big trade I
think he's gonna take and she's gonna
take and the question is whether whether
they know how to convert extra Rook
advantages
what's what's weird is if you think
about the fact that he's a day ahead
Andrea that means he already knows how
this match ends
he's already playing from the future how
trippy is that that's why not first then
I started eating porns it's like
Inception except it doesn't make any
sense
him living in Australia is very
fascinating
it's very fast crazy never heard of it
before
uh all right let's go cutie attack the
pawns attack the pawns let's go don't
give up if I push this Pawn here
I have if I can get the Rooks on the
back I gotta checkmate
maybe I'll push that pawn that is
probably true if he's thinking that's a
five-head
the answer is
the answer is four too many that's how
many kids I can push this yeah there you
go the answer is enough that's how many
kids I have
um I guess and I I I have to say we were
hyping up cutie cat said why is she a
huge favorite she is 800 that's true the
strongest players in this tournament are
about 1200 but I I've seen cutie play
chess and she was very strong like
earlier but yeah you know one blender
that's better than her rating we have
had the strongest strongest players in
this opponent like virtual literally
lose so many games just because of just
one-off blender while they're playing
like 90 accuracy the rest of their game
so yep at the end of the day this is
what POG Champs is one blender and you
throw it all away that's life but let's
Andrea we have to take a second to
appreciate idea of things planning can
we bring up the analysis board real
quick yes because
I I thought this is what he was talking
about but of course he's not streaming
so he couldn't see but all the way back
here he already he already was talking
about if he could he said we heard him
say we couldn't see a board if I get the
pawn up and I get my Rooks to the back
rank it would be Checkmate and look at
what he did
he played G4 and then brought the pawn
to G5 and now he's going for this okay
thank God QD player six but we just have
to applaud that like this guy was
launching a multi-move mating net and
the pressure it's still the mating that
is still there yeah no this is a very
very nice one super impressive from uh I
did a thing even as the bias commentator
openly rooting for Cutie this is really
great chess by him amazing we'll see if
cutie finds oh she found it yes
oh yes
nice find now don't trade Rooks cutie
even if he blocks like just check check
around but if this is your chance if you
win G5 it's not over it's not a tuba
Welcome to California
Sports [__] oh you knew that one
I like him I resonate with him because I
too can see myself
in my life I just really resonate
for that one why is everyone hoeing me
what what
[__] was I wrong what Schwartz I can't
believe you're doing great
but also Cutie's doing great she won the
pawn now she's coming over
and look at this I did a thing is still
he's on a one-tracked mind he thinks
it's still Checkmate that pawn is gone
Arnold
um
oh okay all right anyways we're just
gonna move on ignorance
don't be cringed don't do that Arnold
Bach I hate you guys yeah you have to
get the pawn you have to get the pawn
talking about Arnold so good now what
does that look like for me
cutie is playing phenomenal defense here
despite making the blunders from earlier
so I just want to say that no matter
what happens I'm personally now rooting
for a draw because then it just gets us
more chests between these two you know
um no plus three
he's not letting me check
that's my angry face okay moving on and
move on
um you know cutie is offending very well
he's got these two Rooks just a little
bit hopeless
I mean I think hopeless is a strong word
you know
yeah true like the Nick the Knicks are
hopeless okay the Knicks are hopeless or
you know if we want to talk about the
Marlins or however if we're gonna keep
going around hopeless like there are
there are people that you know can feel
hopeless but this position is not
hopeless
yep so he still wants this mating net
he's
nice and she's keeping the pressure on
the C2 Pawn which if Alex forgets that
he moves his Rook she could you know
start trying to eat
I mean if she just sits tight I don't
think Alex has proven that he knows how
to win anymore he had a great player
okay the what's funny about one of these
games Andreas Judy is gonna play herself
into maybe losing because the more open
lines she creates the better the Rooks
are gonna be even with the past Pawn so
if she had just sat there I don't think
that I don't think that Alex knew how to
use the extra Rook but now she's now
she's gonna get her own look at that he
played it settings wow
but I have to say View intuitively
executed by I did a thing now you can
just bring his Rook wow that works too
there's a lot of spots yep
very nice
very nice chess
[Laughter]
little kids at chess club when they
really gotta pee and they kept going oh
look at that left but she takes the poem
with check
nice
Kitty got a pawn chat cutie got a pawn
um and this is really depressing because
she only has one move to defend the mate
Rook H2 and then you skewer them
and then you eat the Rook
what's funny is he sees it he saw the
multi-move mating that idea oh can't do
that to me that's that lets her out if
she sees that she can trade Rooks
uh check there
now you can't check me
is this checkmate I don't want to look
why is it over it's it's almost there
Danny she's got one move one move just
one rook and then it's over oh yeah yeah
her Rook her Rook can come across
stuff that's mate hello
[__] yeah
oh
so he has a very suspicious
um screen that he has like I don't know
a can of something back there and then
like it's good drill good this man's
yeah
[Music]
Well Chad that was the game man we came
in here Almighty hate hate praising
cutie and she did play some good games
but there was one decisive blunder and
you know I think cutie is just kicking
off the rust but credit where it's due I
did a thing you know what he represented
the 800s well today he played some
amazing chess and he cleaned up those
last two games
I'm not gonna lie as much as it pains me
I agree he definitely he definitely
played better than better than cutie I
was rooting for her openly that first
game felt like everything was rolling
for her and when it when the wheels came
off Chad asked who coached I did a thing
um you know crazy coincidence no one
even wants to know
he gave him you gave him one lesson
and I told him to do puzzle Rush every
day and the one thing about I did a
thing why he's different from all my
students is he actually did his homework
every day and he showed me how his
puzzle Rush rating progressed over the
weeks so he actually did his writing so
yeah credits were due but he only had
one lesson it was with me all right
whatever let's move on look at the group
standings Andrea botez student strikes
again in fact he clinches the fact that
he will be winning the D group with that
cutie still has a lot of games left it's
not clear yet whether she'll have a
chance to challenge Papa plot for second
place is it pop a plot pop a plate papa
plotty papa put paper and we're gonna
try about that later but QD still has
matches against fusely and papa plot
left even though I did a thing is your
group D Champion with that Victory so
yeah
um I did a thing is gonna be a tough
matchup we saw both played today I did a
thing's kind of a force not to be messed
with
yeah I agree playing well Alex is doing
great Judy definitely needs to recover I
think she'll have a chance we still have
a lot of POG Champs ahead everybody you
see Alex celebrating don't go anywhere
we'll be back after this break
three two one here we go
[Music]
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow tennis
sisters come on
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
what is the banished Gambit game one or
game two game one game one no please
don't it's too soon Hikaru we didn't
even reach a climax
yes you
this is the best player in his group so
I thought I thought he played um
don't go king of five stalemate
oh
there it is big win big points
oh my God Checkmate checkmate
oh
yes
are you yelling it's like
good move by him so you need to keep the
Rook on the a file to so you don't drop
your passport
oh god there goes the other Rook yeah I
I think he didn't see that but the king
is close enough to the pawn we're gonna
be able to capture it and this will be a
four straw
and now no mouse slip by Ruby it's just
Queen V8 instead of Queen B7 and um and
that's game over oh my gosh he might
have this is crazy he stopped at me oh
he's going the other way oh no he missed
it very nice wow
so
clean wow
amazing let's do this let's do the
respectful thing
he has resigned I don't even know well
it doesn't matter because the Grandeur
resigned and yes
thank you
[Music]
check this out
foreign
[Music]
we are back there is I did a thing
celebrating his victory in style
speaking adorable Australian accented
things drinking water I think that's
what they drink down there they drink
they drink water not fosters anyway
we're now joined like you both
competitors cutie Cinderella and I did a
thing cutie I I said it when we were
waiting to come back I was openly
rooting for you Andrea was also openly
rooting against you do you want to say
anything about that
explain well I did give I did a thing
one lesson but I actually started very
single lesson yes and I coached a
prodigy and you won and played perfect
chess and I take all credit for that but
I started neutral and then everyone was
like hard rooting for Cutie I was like
No And you know that first game you
really like wiping the floor with him
and then we got that stalemate which I
was saying Robert has clearly never
teach un games maybe if you were my
student things would have been
differently
um
gosh that was so embarrassing
all I needed to do was count and I just
I hate you Alex as a person
that's fine that's fine
he's six foot tall he's got a six pack
he gets to play with crash I'm six foot
four
is is playing an adjustment the most
nerve-wracking thing you've ever done
I think it is yeah I I was talking to
someone else about this that compare
I've done a boxing match but I think
this is worse
I think that the fact that you have to
constantly like think and not just react
like at least with boxing you get hit
you're hyped and it's just a reaction
like having an accelerated heart helps
you with chess when you start to kind of
get nervous and be sweating I'm like now
I can't think clearly there's nothing in
my head so yeah I think I think this is
worse than boxing I hate this
I love it but I hate it
that is a very interesting comparison I
don't know man I think boxing's like
that person I would much rather play a
game of chess but it's good to know that
what's on the line here for you today
because you're sure showed up when you
needed to
thank you well you you you've basically
clinched your bracket right I think so
my math isn't too good I'm not gonna lie
um but I think no one has the answer
yeah you were at the top yeah you did
seven wins which is actually insane
because when did you start learning
chess
uh
probably wow I I start I started
training chess like
three four weeks ago
um but I had I I have played before
um I played with Alexa my mate who was
meant to be in Ludwig's chess boxing
event
um and it's good playing with him
because he's he's much better than me
he's like 1300 so
I do I was playing with him quite a few
times before that so I don't think I was
a complete beginner like everyone
thought I was so you're giving me too
much credit
Beauty
we we know okay he started playing you
you know you're a Pog Champs OG and I'm
not just saying this because Alex was
saying it I do consider you one of the
favorites in your group I I honestly
thought you were gonna beat Alex and I
was like he's gonna she's gonna beat him
now she's the favorite and she's gonna
be the the best player in her bracket
and I still believe you can beat Papa
plot and all do respect and love to
Leslie I think you're gonna beat
foosleep pretty badly I'm just gonna say
it so I think you have a chance here I
just wanted you to know that
Denny what do you think I do not think
so
okay I can't seem to get better I don't
I think you understand how hard I try I
I simply cannot get better
maybe it's because I won't change my
opening maybe it's not because of that
you go you ghosted me when I offered you
chess lessons like two years ago
all the wrong coaches that's why
don't you say that about Levy that's
still my coach and I do plan on letting
him down every time I play
uh so Gotham chess coached you for today
um yeah two years ago
no but what I wanted to sorry Daddy I'm
sorry go ahead go ahead no I was gonna I
was gonna go back to Alex and just say
that even though you were accidentally
invited to this because Ludwig gave me
the wrong name and we said your name
live on a show because it was supposed
to be daily dose I'm still happy you're
here I'm a huge fan of the accent and go
Alex into the next round what are your
thoughts on being accidentally invited
into a tournament you might win
I thought it was amazing that's the best
way I've ever been invited to anything
especially because I first heard about
it from Andrea who was like oh I've
heard you're in POG Champs and I was
like yeah and then she's like yeah yeah
I think I think you're in POG Champs and
then that night Ludwig sent me a message
being like sorry dude I accidentally
invited you to pog Champs and I was like
great this is sick I didn't think I
wanted to play chess but yeah
you saw the tweet I had to find the DM
to show him I'm like dude you show you
said I did a thing was in I showed him
on Discord so anyway I was like podcast
I don't know how we got us confused
like we're not the permission but
you guys did great
you guys both have very recognizable
voices and you do big things on YouTube
so I can see how the mistake happened
but let's just say that accidental
invite could turn into a pogchem
champion so it's a good thing it
happened but that's what I'm hoping
Alex great to meet you man good luck in
the next round cutie I I'm Gonna Keep
biasedly rooting for you and trying to
prove you wrong that you can win You
Wrong by you winning this if anyone
wants to biasly unplug all my
competitors internet I would appreciate
that
cutie
thank you I'd appreciate that
bye both all right we're looking ahead
we got we got xuc and Jenny see you
later and then we've got you actually
cootie's gonna be back that's right dude
you'll be back later on against fusley
so that's gonna be fun yay cutie you're
gonna make us proud I'm rooting for
fusely too but they can't hear us
anymore cool all right guys well now you
know the man the myth the legend people
have been coming into chat asking all
day long is xqc gonna show up today and
we're about to find out but my money is
that he's gonna show up yeah well he
just changed his category on Twitch from
just chatting drama click here juice
Lord to now chess and he doesn't stream
chess in the desk
yeah here he goes so xqc is here Felix
is back he played and played fantastic
yes yesterday now he's going to take on
Jenny and uh and dog Champs continues
who who picked Jenny's pairings I have
to say this I love Janina to death but
she has been getting paired against all
the Giga Chads of Chess right now well
for Pogba I would in the past I would I
would have to pretend it wasn't me in
this world and I was doing everything
and I have to say it wasn't me but now
it really isn't me because the company's
gotten so big I can actually name the
person it was Nintendo dude Michael
brancato that's okay you don't even know
it's okay he's not to blame everyone go
after Nintendo on Twitter we love you
Michael all right but let's talk about
Ginny even though I would argue this I
actually think Michael did a great job
but if you look at Jenny's profile the
bottom line is we don't know how good
people are and sometimes you pick
someone like sardosh and the dude grinds
and becomes you know 1800 by the end of
the month so the point is there is a lot
more of an art to picking these groups
in a science and I'm defending Michael
by saying that and Ginny is awesome even
if even if she's one of the newer
players in her group so
yep I mean ladies and gentlemen she is
trilingual which means she can play
chess and not one not two but three
languages pretty crazy guys
when she's thinking about Chess in her
head do you think she bounces back and
forth between languages well we've seen
her curse in Korean so she definitely is
yeah assaulty Ice Climbers bracket
bracket setup sorry that's a Nintendo to
reference the uh the Ice Climbers King
uh but yeah so Jenny um she just started
playing chess and she's she's doing
great and we know that xqc is a uh
he's an OG he's the only person to play
in every POG Champs I think did he play
in every single one it's actually very
impressive you guys have gotten him
every single month
that's right he didn't play POG two I
think
um maybe this is the POG Champs he
finally wins
oh no he didn't play POG four Ah that's
what it was okay sorry I'm getting old
you know um you know the memory is is
but anyway he's uh he's uh the guy that
rolls out of bed to a lot of people
watching him I feel like he's the
closest thing to The Truman Show on the
internet where he just gets online and
just talks about his life and just [__]
and it's it's honestly it just sucks you
in because you're like whatever he's
talking about I just want to hear about
it and now he's gonna play chess yes 3.5
K games I think that's the most out of
everyone today and you know I have to
say xqc did one day beat me in chess it
may have been with 15 second time odds
and I'd blundered a queen and a mate but
he is not to be messed with and not to
be underestimated and his chest has been
drastically improving
agreed no I I I watched yesterday and
every time every time I try to adjust my
fan they put me in fact yes I was gonna
say this is great I love it let's do it
let's just do the show with Hikaru and
not and not Andrea Andrea how about you
hide it's not impressed and Hikaru will
take over
um all right we've got the games that
are about to begin it's xqc versus Ginny
and uh and Andrea is back apparently I
am back unfortunately even though chat
would have must preferred he carted my
chair but he doesn't like to talk to you
guys because he hates you if you want if
you go I can try to do uh a three-way
commentary where I can say the thing
that you and Hikaru would say
I'll spare the chat from that one okay
yeah they already think we're crazy
enough
all right well here we go we've got xqc
we've got another POG Champs and I think
that um
okay I'm gonna say what I said before
about cutie although now my cred is just
going down as if I had any I think Felix
is someone who can win the whole thing
and I know you've got Alex you've got
virtual you've got some some players
there but but uh yeah actually she's
good he's standing at a strong
927 rating he's almost hit big one
thousand
yeah he's got it he's strong
Knight of three he knows his openings
[Music]
yeah I don't think xqc has ever really
taken chess lessons actually speaking of
Hikaru he did once take some lessons for
making cardio and he stopped but the
fact that he's grinded and improved this
on his own also is impressive yep
let's take a look at what he's talking
about he's here and he's right I
probably won't understand a lot of it
but
no
oh he's already taking it wait can we
just why do we go I wanted to watch
xuc is definitely the uh first thing you
can just tune into all day unfortunately
Jenny didn't see the queen is hanging
and we already know that he took it
she's in big trouble
and we already knew that xqc was a big
favorite in this one well guys Anything
Could Happen nobody knows nobody knows
I love how you're just like trying to do
the thing they blame me for I actually
do it when it matters in like you know
high stakes Nakamura versus Carlson this
end game could go either way we're
talking about a fraction of a of a
centipun you're trying to sell people
the next you see isn't just crushing
this game and that it isn't already over
and I love that you're doing great I
don't know what you're talking about if
anything we've learned today that
Queen's gambits don't decide the game
that is true pogchamps is the event that
casual on the edge of the Z because
you're right you're right I guess I
should just embrace it but I do think uh
Felix is he's playing phenomenal chess I
think he came to pog Champs to win can
we just watch Felix guys this is a 800
game with no Queens on the board I don't
think we gotta analyze the chest let's
just can we listen to the man talk
yeah I'm good to listen to him play the
game let's do it
come on
this leads me up to Opportunities like
this like a um check Discovery threat
which is bad for me but I can just go
live I lied and then double twin uh
sideways right so anyway just give it
right back here is it bad for her never
mind
yeah take check
okay yeah he saw that never mind
[Music]
you just move downwards a little bit
after that but I get my again so I I get
I get a chat which is free but it's not
really free but sometimes I get to make
a move afterwards which is um hide right
behind it right here so if it was a lot
on Pace yeah
attack the pawns Tempo maneuver nice I
gained Tempo by doing this look at the
accuracy he's playing a
minus one look at that is that a hamster
twerking that is the best thing I've
ever seen of all time
leaned in to look at the hamster chat um
I I I had to I've got a monitor in front
I just want to make sure before I want
to smoke
it doesn't exist and I would give my
queen for free but then Ali bring the
rules of integrity
and I've never done that ever in my life
in a tournament of Rivals
in his life that would be breaking the
rules
the rules you don't there it is
in the hamster
that's great
it's I like that
who's poro
who's gonna attack this one Granite
check this is good he's bringing the
Bishops it's beautiful no I don't see it
this is sad very smart
which would make sense as to why I don't
know it because league is the easiest
it's not a cat scary not the Tyler
wonder man
I'm not going on time again I like Tyler
like if you actually play back the thing
I was I was I know yeah she really
invited his brother because he wanted
Tyler
bump
he didn't see that coming it didn't do
anything but at least it stopped him for
a second he was like so confident about
it like but I didn't do anything though
it just shut him up for a second like I
said I'm going bang bang
and I'm sure I'm not trying to be rude
okay but what I'm saying on the board
right now on the opposite side
let's start a day get freedom for all
the Rooks
I don't understand
I'm gonna push pot and then guys I'm
just gonna push pot and then
he's not even gonna bring out
the liberated Rooks you're just gonna
make another queen he doesn't even care
he's not even using any of his pieces
he's playing Queen and Palms versus the
rest of her Army but he's got a house
for his Queen
when I look at how the other pieces are
they're all stuck in between right
there's like a check at the Top This is
a classic
a rookie mistake it's all stuck
this is a good observation
she has this we'll just Pawn up taking
to take but still minus two it needs to
move the wish
ES
I agree with everything you said I got
nothing time sticking gotta be thinking
does not activate the Bish let's go game
on
game mode
game but by moving the the C Pawn but
you take the Roku to check so it doesn't
matter oh yeah you at least know Wayne's
World as a movie right wait that was
actually kind of a genius movie no it
wasn't
watch party
through look we know how twitch Works
buddy you see the numbers growing yeah
that's how you do it content you just
sit back
it becomes there hasn't been any
controversy over reacting overreacting
to other people's content reasons better
like you don't even know what you're
watching but you can't turn away that's
what it is
should I move back okay
into check
move back into take check wait is he
arrowing a botez yeah no sorry he's
gonna take no no taking one check yes
I zoned out for a second take checking
wow take it into check
could actually be a good thing
I've seen some I think a disastrous
stalemate in Rapid chess Magnus saw
what's that or who did
um who's the person that Fabiano beat at
the Champions chess tour I was in Oslo I
should remember yeah you're on the wrong
guy
that religiously follows chess
I'm not one who understands the uh the
chess tour
um
I went to the uh the school for kids who
don't chest good that that's where I
went yeah we're very good your chest
very good you had I am okay you got a
chest pretty hard to get there
yeah you gotta you gotta chess you gotta
chess a lot
um anyway but yeah the uh the auto Queen
thing is oh it was against
um it was against uh Eduardo Saga who
was one of the one of the stars of the
show it was amazing her options but he
didn't have he didn't want Auto Queen on
and he lost the game on time because he
couldn't auto check we see the rookie
he's in
he's in Chipotle's gamut no you're in
check there you go he's in check he
highlights the queen why not do I have
Checkmate here check yeah
he doesn't see The Rook is hanging check
he's focused on checks look when you see
a free rook look for better
I don't know what's better here Chad
it's a good tip oh no check oh now he
sees it
Bing okay that's that's even I mean I
don't I don't think it's the best movie
but it was a better move there but I
could just do um check it would have
been stalemate if not for the pawns but
he knows that check into move into check
into move or move I I can't I don't know
what I'm thinking about I'm just acting
like a crew but I'm not miss Maiden too
don't get W like you know it was obvious
I didn't even see the maiden too I'm not
gonna lie
check
he's all right we're getting there he's
all over it yeah I got it this is a slow
run um
right now
he's about to do the Rook roll as long
as he doesn't pre-move it to stalemate
the Mogul the Mogul move stalemate he'll
be fine
interesting
that's a good little pattern I'll take
it actually
it takes pogchamps to show you a new
Queen and Rook roll and he does the job
there you go like roll them all around
the board
well that was anticlimactic
and now he's doing the stare of death
he's game reviewing
let's see what he learns
he's gonna fall over in his chair his
accuracy was incredible the Jokes Aside
he really is he's playing great chess
he's won every game in pogchamps five so
far Andrea
yeah that was insane oh he's been
playing really well I yeah you gotta
give him credit where it's too
um that was there's not much to be said
about that game like I'm not gonna keep
talking like there is that was a clean
sweep
um but yeah more games with xqc coming
they're probably my most entertaining
type of Chess to watch because I also
have to talk to Lee so I'm living life
I'm on videos honestly we all appreciate
that we get a little bit of a break from
you yelling in my ear can I just say it
don't worry I'm sitting back and I
distance myself from the mic Denny so
actually the more relaxed I get the
safer your ears are
I'm kidding no we love you and the hype
is real but also it is nice when he's
talking because we got nothing to do but
listen and right now I can't I can't
wait to see how he fares against some of
the stronger players in the field Andrea
because
because uh I think he's gotten a lot
better and I want to see how he does
against your worshipers and others his
rating is underrated right now yeah and
yep I have to say like even though he is
so strong as we're seeing today let's
not forget the the players at the top of
the group have been playing like 1200
1300 level maybe not 1300 but there's
still some very very intense competition
but SCC has been playing jazz for a long
time it would be cool to see him take
the crown
yeah I mean who wouldn't want to have
him at the uh the first ever live Final
in La it's going to be I wonder if he'll
actually show
it we'll see
honestly now that you say that I just
got a little bit of a hit of anxiety
honestly I almost don't want him to win
like imagine how hard it was to get him
on this call Imagine now flying him to
L.A Danny no I think he's already heavy
I don't know Chad says he's moving I
don't know I have no idea he's always
moving to L.A
yeah he moves to La moves back to Texas
he's homeless half the time you've never
seen a millionaire so homeless as you've
seen next you see yeah you have to say
chat yes like he's really not doing this
for the money he just loves chess so we
are honored to have him be a part of the
tournament he's in Texas it is true and
that is that is one of the other good
parts about pogchamps too is like it's
not like you have a bunch of creators
here nothing taking away from chess
players who are playing professional
tournaments and winning money and that's
their livelihood but it is fun when you
have people playing they're purely here
for the joy of it and to get better even
if they're not as good as Grand Masters
right they're they're here just to play
and have fun by the way both players
Andrea yes what are you gonna say I have
played 100 have played 100 accurate move
so far
well that is amazing and Chad is saying
sad Jenny she's not streaming right now
chat and I think you don't realize that
when us streamers are being normal
people and we're not talking all the
time this is just what we look like of
course you know maybe she's not pleased
to have lost xqc but you know she's
still part of the tournament she's still
here let's all still support Ginny it is
just a really tough match she's very new
to the game she's going up against XTC
um she's also traveling the world but
she's learning we are also offering
coaching so maybe we'll do some training
lessons with Jenny as well
humor is our normal people question mark
you're right streamers are normal people
you did stream nine hours today
hot take she streamed nine hours today
that's insane God how does she do it
seriously it's exhausting I'm exhausted
yeah guys this can't be the worst thing
she's done but I don't know maybe it is
Maybe I'm Wrong
all right she's thinking about it she's
thinking about it she's got both her
nights in the game
this is great openings
we should probably take a listen into
into Felix and see what you know what to
do production just take it away guys
take it away
we'll let we'll let Felix take over the
show here oh my God my mom says I don't
work hard enough
play
yup accurate and true okay maybe I made
a mistake here but he also plays faster
than he used to
he's just that's good Italian
confidence classic no a lot of
commentary in previous podcasts
watching it you see have the right idea
I have no confidence that he had the
right idea like he had like zero
confidence in himself or that he was
seeing it and so you're actually gonna
burn it is also a big part of the
progress
yeah I know we saw that earlier daily
dose resigned literally drawing
definition confidence is very important
in chess sometimes it could be your own
downfall as well though
I can take pause yeah well do you play
better when you think you're winning or
when you think you're losing
I actually crumble under pressure
tonight whenever I get overconfident I
just lose everything
really I'm feeling cool today that's a
cool moment that's kind of why is that
let's talk about that let's unpack the
psychology of that that's okay you know
sit on the couch here you know what's
what's going on with that and I'm
kidding but you really lose more games
when you're winning yeah I just knowing
that I'm winning this year
like I always do it's like he's not
doing that today
is their stats arrows raise your mental
stats any GM player will agree look at
Hikaru he's Jim right what's the common
denominator putting him in being jammed
he does this
and it he does that
that is
in the broadcast that is why Hikaru is a
super GM is because he highlights Heroes
it says take six
I agree we all would then you kind of
knock down Tuesday then you can play oh
everything would be
these days winning title Tuesday is
maybe one of the hardest events to win
in the world you know just go for it
true
all right safe
so this is possibly one of the worst
moves that could have been done at that
point because
if you want to clean up the middle part
for there it happens that I think Queen
upper or Rook sideways is good because
it threatens both pieces which are gonna
be hard to defend if when you start
compounding all the pieces
um for that pawn that is currently
unprotected so I'll always be one move
behind until she runs out and moves that
are aggressive and then I lose but she
didn't go for any of that so my number
he's literally teaching his channel like
I think we need to appreciate what's
going on here like that was phenomenal
advice he was 100 correct on everything
he said like the unit like Armageddon is
coming like what is happening here this
is wild
so I'm gonna do I hate to be all aboard
the phrase this season check my train
but not only is he crushing this game
but he's also at the same time saying
how his opponent could play better
I didn't listen or you know maybe none
of you or even heard what he said so
anything
or I could just go down
I'm not
do I play by weakness would I play for
content
fun see how good he really is
push if he does it
finally took the Adderall
why is uh why is xuc playing before
Lionel Messi's game is surprised I don't
get it
like that's a joke that went over my
head
it's inner Miami playing tonight oh my
God anyway sorry if he plays D5 though
it just shows the progress you know this
is
I feel like Danny would
have I did see it
okay sorry sorry we'll move on sorry as
long as you're thinking all right he did
the pawn push
the over thing is that if you're
wondering on time if you think too much
this is a great move it not only defends
the night but it also attacks the bishop
and gains space
over things certain moves it's crazy
with six moves by moist critical
everybody this is not one you're not a
meme Lord of podcasts this is this is
baby this is one of the best players in
the event Andrea I'm not kidding I know
you think I'm just typing I can see you
over there judging and you would hit
hardwood in the background are skeptical
of what I'm saying I'm not kidding me
right now moves early I just like to sit
inside
well I have to say between my two
Prodigy students
I think my student may take down your
juicer well we're gonna see fine from
now on xqc
I just adopted him I just adopted HTC is
my students even though he doesn't know
it and I got him against gasoline I'll
take it I'll take the odds whatever bet
you want I already owe you a cat made
stream damn it I keep forgetting about
the damn cat made
you keep forgetting yeah I'm not gonna
lie he did beat me in the game of chess
but chat there were some very specific
circumstances you don't need to continue
bringing it up
he takes the bishop he's attacking her
Knight she can take the Knight on e4
though Jenny is also playing well I know
we're on the the Xbox
and that is why I retired coaching
students so that I don't have to beat
him myself but my students can take him
down for me okay
that's great
yeah now we can see that uh
black is totally winning because he gets
the extra Feast right it was simply a a
trade of two for one as they say xqc got
two Miners and she only got one piece
but I want to go back to applauding
Ginny Andrea like this is not this is
much better than the first game she's
mostly developed
um xqc is clearly a much better player
but she's doing good
so
yep it's been it's been a tough match
she's down she's down a night here but
when you say miners chat you're not
talking about minors as an underaged
humans you're talking about Minor P wow
this shows you the level of Chess we
have in chat people think I'm I'm
talking about inappropriate stuff here A
minor piece for the record
a night or Bishop in in chess so
this position
Knight D3 was played Black gets two
miners takes and takes for one minor the
major pieces are the queens and the
Rooks so if you lose a minor piece
you've lost a knight or Bishop if you
lose a major piece you've lost a Rooker
or or queen that is not I didn't say
anything inappropriate
[Laughter]
it's okay by the way we should point out
the match they have on screen right now
Andrea is xqc tyler1 they're reminding
everybody if you didn't know what you
were doing at 5 PM Eastern tomorrow you
do now xqc versus tyler1 it's gonna be
it's gonna be lit I expect xuc to win
2-0 I expect Tyler to freak out and do
some crazy stuff that's gonna hit the
top of livestream fail I expect a lot of
League of Legends fans to pretend like
that game is any more than a bunch of
random potions and witches and wizards
and dragons on a map that is basically a
ripoff of the original World of
warcrafts and starcrafts with some
complex potions thrown in who cares it's
not that hard of a game that's that's
what I'm that's what I'm expecting to
see go down tomorrow all of that you
know Danny I think xqc Sunday saying
something really crazy right now
earlier
let's do it let's do it
it's a block I don't want I don't want
League fans to Riot okay yeah
and then she can move down for a take
take
but I'll call so much damage out middle
it won't matter
that one genuinely made me laugh like I
whenever you add something in finger
quotes it just makes it 20 times funnier
the second mistake no no more
overthinking about the mistake thank you
I'm changing lessons another one minutes
15 years younger Co commentator
something like that you know so I
thought your kids would teach you all of
this stuff but they haven't been doing a
good job yeah they try to but most of
the time they just roll your eyes at you
when you say stuff and that's teenagers
teenagers it's complicated you know but
they do love the boat as uh gear that I
gave them both my boys wear the bojas
hoodies white and black like so proudly
like seriously
um I don't think there's anything she
can do here yeah I think it's kind of
gone um anyways
she's doing good spawned in the game and
he's been directing the wrong ways and
he's gonna die
look at him look at him
I were just going against this is Robert
get stronger than dude look at him by
the way he's still playing phenomenal
chess like yes she's doing good
developing her pieces we have to give
her credit
but xqc already highlighted that if the
queen moves he wins the D3 Pawn now he's
Gonna Take It
it's just ridiculous like
this is crazy
I hope that Tyler is watching that's
something roberting
[Music]
every I feel I'm turning into Danny
getting baited
man that is welcome to the club I'm
covered let me tell you what this is
Robert but sometimes
um
related so I I I still I don't think I'm
losing on Pace or anything
against a better player
um this will end up biting me um in um
the rear later on down the line but
we're not here right now
the man who's careful with his language
too I'm really alarmed I he almost said
that very scary word I don't want to
know what would have happened if you
would have said it yep
agreed but uh he's focused you've
watched this channel Danny you know
there are a lot of kids there are
probably a lot of people not cooperating
with which terms of service watching xqc
that's just the truth they're probably
younger than they should be watching
that
and she has really matured
yeah
the pawn
let's take
Stakes
that's good by the way I get it
move anyways it depends scared I'm
scared
yeah he's phenomenal at chess all of a
sudden like all of a sudden as you see
give him the GM title
in fact I don't want to piss I don't
want to piss off Andrea but we might
have to invite xuc to title Tuesday I
mean that's what I'm saying right I mean
xqc is like title Tuesday before me I
will literally quit chest streaming and
just become a full-time oh oh wait look
she took the rook and she was super
excited because she had a plan which was
good but she forgot the rookie
seven seconds
but did you see the celebration
she had I didn't because I got
distracted by chat check and we have
flagged
damn the song bro you know she was super
excited because she got to check him she
got to attack him
and um
[Laughter]
and he shows why he's the favorite why
he's the favorite in group C I hope
Tyler's watching or at least yeah
better watch out like I was pretty into
I don't know I'm scared more like
talking on the mic when Tyler is in the
zoom call or xqc's chest they're both
very good competitors I thought Tyler
was great to interview everyone was
expecting some like crazy beef and I was
just honest with him told him straight
up to his face league is much easier
than chess he didn't even disagree can
someone roll the tape and back up he
actually changed the subject when I said
it and I'm just telling you that like
Tyler's actually super Pleasant don't
get fooled by the muscle shirts he's
just he's a cute guy just just like
really simple adorable like cuddly kind
of guy
yep it's in uh speaking of changing this
since I have just one point above tyler1
he just needs a little Tyler too and
he'll be there but we're going to get
the most awaited match of hog Champs
coming to you guys soon where xqc and
Tyler are actually gonna step into the
ring and Gladiator battle to death and
loser dies tomorrow it's xqc versus
tyler1
um will win and Reign Victorious we
already know that those two are both
moving on Tyler
the same as with cutie where I'm openly
rooting for her
Victoria I'm rooting for chess rooting
for chess tomorrow is it said rain if I
air quote you you said where tyler1 will
reign Victorious you always could get a
little side bet going on too I think X
UC beats either if you want a side bet
all right well I have
I have quarter then
we're going to a break don't go anywhere
when we come back more matches ahead
it's POG change and we get to hear Jenny
talk yay
[Music]
so for uh for for 10 seconds yeah yes
yes
why to play and draw
oh but this this I'm pretty sure I've
seen
this looks so familiar
so he has to go to either h2h3
I haven't been able to decide to fly but
my 10 seconds pass fast yes yes yes my
feeling would be
definitely not H2 because H2 then maybe
e one night that's really a problem yes
so I have to go to H3 H3 Knight F4 Edge
about PH2 my G4 Chuck
then kh1 Knight F2 check
very good
I know this one I'm just trying to
remember
so it's when the three nine sketches of
King H3 Knight F4 Knight or uh
King H2 my G4 Chuck Knight G4 King H1
1939 freaking G3 right guys now King E3
yeah very good
foreign
okay let's
start with King H2
kind of have to like this
um H2O would probably go E1 I
oh is this kh3 enough E1 light then
Knight F3
well yes but King history I will go
Knight F4
okay now I have to go to H2 Knight G4
okay now I have to go to H1 Knight F2
okay King H2 E1 light
and uh
latitude
oh Knight of three notifications yeah
yeah Knight F3 Knight takes up three
King G3 very nice
any of this one I was just trying to
remember the whole detail look you're
the only one that's uh remaining perfect
after
five studies last one why to move
yeah I've seen this one okay this one I
think I've seen before Queen G7 number
seven Knight six easy yes yes
but what's the uh what's the puzzle wait
to move
because you you saved the simplest one
for the last one this this is
yes yes
wow
how did you get me here
so Queen G7 okay seven Knight P6 made
yeah yes that's it we saved the easiest
for Less
come on
[Music]
let's go
we're going back and we are back with
pogchamps five the Felix xqc gets the
job done he has not lost a single game
in pog's Champs 5 so far which uh given
that he's an OG of the event we'll see
how he feels about that we're now with
him and he's uh he's put on a suit Felix
you've already clinched the championship
bracket bro how's it feel
um feels where I should be at to be
honest
um with the amount of time I've been
I've been putting down practicing and
learning the world of Chess
um I've improved in Shadows and I'm
ready to take on the whole thing and um
you said today
um that was undefeated right
and yeah I I don't mean anyone to
self-glaze too much about this one but I
gotta say
um I'm not only undefeated I haven't
made a single mistake yet
in the whole tournament
not only is that true Felix but I said
yesterday I was watching like and I
don't know if it's the highlighting
arrows to be like a car or whatever it
is but you are playing a next level for
chess and you really are man and I don't
wanna I don't want to get you too hyped
for tomorrow because by the way I'm
betting on you to beat Tyler so I need
you to deliver tomorrow uh but dude
you're playing great and how does it
feel you've really have put in the time
um it feels honestly um
I um no this is like a Jenny
um I just I I haven't had moves that I
was uncomfortable being in yet maybe
because of a how maybe most the openings
are whatever I haven't found spaces
where um I have to make a decision that
is difficult right so yeah I I'm
thinking in strides right I think my
when I can get them
right but um I don't wanna I don't want
to get your head too ahead of myself I
will I'll keep practicing until the the
next match in the next match until um
until when the whole thing
and speaking of the next match how about
you Jenny you've been playing against
some stacked opponents but you're about
to go into the consolation bracket what
is your head at going on games anything
you want to want to do differently maybe
like you know the goal here is to at
least one time during POG champ at least
one time
hey you know you're not the only
competitor with that goal so it's okay I
believe I believe I also think it'll be
a much more enjoyable experience you're
very new to the game and so will be the
consolation bracket
um but yeah you know if you ever you
want some lessons Danny's more than
happy
yeah so I thought I would be like
finished within like six moves or
something I think I lasted long enough
which I'm happy with
yeah that's a good take that's a good
take
good one that is that is and my what a
good one
um I've been gotten by that joke
um
no problem
listen I've made mistakes in the past
okay and it haunted me and like I told
you guys yesterday but I I have my
bladders on I'm looking towards the
future the past is the past and I am
moving on okay and I'm ready
to not losing six moves not only that
but win the whole thing also I don't
think uh just a question the player in
detention right now
um
or maybe virtual right no I was gonna
ask you what competition are you most
scared of or I don't know if you've been
following the other competitors
my cell phone
does anybody playing against stuff
if I don't play properly I have lost
myself in my own decisions so that's who
I'm scared of I know
honestly Felix I don't mean to like keep
this interview super professional but
you did put on a suit and and I want to
go back to that I think it is the right
mindset you're you're forgetting about
the past you've played 2500 plus games
on chess.com like legit bro like how bad
do you want to win POG Champs
I really want to win it um I didn't
really look at the whole rosters when I
came into the tournament
um I only saw my bracket was uh really
pretty pretty decently easy but as I
ease into the next matches I'll probably
put on a lot of time off stream uh and
I'm on my own to really a crafting
whatever I'm missing it for the next
matches and instead of doing a lot of
puzzles puzzles help out a lot puzzles
are massive and once I get into that I
can emulate puzzles before I see them so
they happen in the game
every game
I love it speaking of getting to the
finals you know that if you do and you
have to fly to LA to play chess
what's the likelihood that you're gonna
show up for that one
100 I have a uh I have a track record
um lately to show up to events that I uh
you're not alive no no that's not
sarcasm I know I'm not
I said I wasn't
anyway uh it takes an invite uh remember
how the night ended for you so I'm gonna
keep my mouth shut
up man
it is a professional interview I'm not
Andrea you know on Jimmy I do want to
say you aren't going to win a game in
POG Champs like I'm gonna go on the
record like it's gonna happen just so
you know there are other competitors
that are new to chess please don't get
discouraged I hope I hope you're having
a good time chess lessons are there if
you want it but I think what x said is
actually true I think puzzles I think
puzzles help and you know the next the
next round is gonna it reformats for
people to play against those who are a
little more close to their where they're
at and and I just want you to know that
I think you're gonna get a dub in the
next round
okay yeah me too so I'll practice with
some puzzles and everything I'm so
confident I would even bet a thousand
dollars that you will game win a game in
POG Champs I believe in you I will put
money on the line I need someone to bet
against but let's go okay I'm not
bending against you
well Felix um I'm gonna be tuning in as
a fan tomorrow when you play Tyler
remind him for me after you beat him the
chess is much harder than League that
would be super appreciated and by the
way do you agree with that chess is
harder than league right
um yes league is a game for children I
just played it mostly by children and it
fell off but he could probably out bench
you which was he's gonna he's you will
say and unless you've been Pumping Iron
you might lose that category so
they meet IRL for the match Danny that's
a lot on the line there like he can talk
a lot of [__] behind the camera but it's
not fun and games if he's in life he's
live in L.A if he's live in L.A and I'm
there I mean like it's obviously I'm not
look I love Tyler's go great I'm just
trying to prove a point with League
that's all there's nothing to do with
Tyler yeah um anyway yeah
no I got nothing else
that's the thing that that's globally
agreed on
um he's a lead player and and league is
a child's game it's not it's not very
difficult at all
um it's one of the easiest games out
there if if Tyler had one ounce of
self-respect left he would be playing
DOTA but he isn't that's why he's gonna
lose when I meet him
you heard the man he might as well drop
a mic as he leaves that's xqc he's
moving on to the championship bracket
playing Tyler tomorrow Jenny thank you
also so much for being with us good luck
in in the consolation and we'll catch up
with both of you later for you Jenny
thanks guys thanks guys have a good one
guys bye
that was awesome that was awesome and
this next match is going to be awesome
too we've got Kitty versus foosley I'm
I'm not gonna lie that was the greatest
that was the greatest interview of all
time and not just because he proved me
right about League I think I think Felix
I don't have to say I don't have to say
anything else for the rest of the show
about League yeah I know xqc in a suit
is a very much special occasion but we
have even more exciting stuff coming up
we have the return of the queen of
twitch cutie Cinderella coming to redeem
herself after dying hard in battle
versus strong Australian man she's gonna
be taking on foosly
um you know a very unpredictable player
Anything could happen but this is gonna
be a good matchup today's a special day
we got five matches
that was awesome you said the Cutie goes
down against strong Australian man
that was like local that was like local
local Florida man oh yeah I could be a
news woman so I try only local Florida
man if local Florida man play chess
maybe it would have been him instead of
uh Australian man but there's goosely
foreign
making her return after uh pod Champs
won it's been a minute but she's awesome
and um
well there you go that's all you need to
know more than 10 million uh she's a
musician she's got 10 million followers
she's um she's awesome and I think this
is going to be a good match with Judy I
do think Cutie's the favorite but I'm
gonna try not to jinx her and I'm not
rooting for anyone here fusely and cutie
here we go whoever wins
Lee was very interesting to watch it was
like really a whole roller coaster her
thought process is great to watch and
she was doing amazing and then at some
point in the game she just decided to
start giving away all her pieces and
yoloing everything so I hope she doesn't
do the YOLO shot again otherwise than
that a lot of potential
agreed agreed unfortunately it looks
like she hasn't shaken off the loss
though she kept this it's never good
mojo to leave a position where you got
checkmated against strong Australian man
on the board Oregon's local Florida man
you should get rid of positions where
you get checkmated by strong Australian
men that is approaching and I know
I did want to give
her that I didn't get
and I know she was being really tough on
herself but the truth is she had such a
solid opening and just the one thing she
needs needed to do was slow herself down
and take her time especially when she's
winning and like like that one tactic
just getting the habit of checking her
moves and I think Judy could be like
really take down the competition
could not agree more she was winning
against against a strong Australian man
um in the first game he will be forever
referred to as that by me and and you're
right man I
um just looked at Katie's dream and she
is not listening in fact she's hanging
on to her jug talking about dirty water
so she didn't hear my advice but that's
okay chat you did
well tell her to slow down yeah because
she was winning there's fusely give
foosli some encouragement too she's on
YouTube go check out over there uh
wherever you are you might be watching
us on YouTube already so foosleep
streaming to YouTube cutie streaming to
Twitch xuc is still in a suit on his
stream
I don't think our Zoom call is being
leaked anymore so that's nice
and Andrea just took a sip of water
hydration cutie Cutie inspired me
all right the matches coming anytime
soon I'm excited for this mashup I don't
think we've ever seen Facebook like
cutie
I agree this is going to be honestly has
like kind of a shrink that cutie doesn't
um she checks over every single move but
then sometimes she leads astray but I
really like that habit in beginners
because she's constantly reminding her
of what threats and attacks are there I
agree again the only problem is when it
becomes too much of a lack of confidence
then you can struggle but all right
totally she's sitting up she's ready to
rock
um I'm gonna shout out that foosli
consistently delivers with like a great
background she really does say that she
really does I thought the same thing her
and papa plate have had the best dream
background out of everyone
colors are so cool I'm taking notes
unfortunately she gave up um gave up a
pawn in the center similar to strong
Australian man which is I did a thing
for those who don't know mostly Gambit
it's not no cutie would have found C3 we
would have had a fork
a double attack on the Knight and Bishop
which are minor pieces for the record
they are minor pieces
I just had to make it clear by the way
oh wow neither side one to two tonight
this is this is the other advice we have
to give cutie she's so
stuck in completing the stone wall that
she's missing the opportunities in front
of her she did the same thing against I
did a thing in the last round where she
played F4 sort of yeah she's tunneling
exactly she played a four instead of
seeing her opportunity which right now
is is again still there oh my God this
eval bar just
just moving all over the place the
Knight is still hanging this is honestly
I understand what Cutie's doing I do the
same with my London some point you just
become a bot and you're so used to
playing the same chess moves all the
time that you just stop thinking when
things are going out of the ordinary But
Here We Go Again Come on cutie
can we listen to cutie and see if yes
see if she yeah we're gonna we're gonna
listen to cutie and see if she sees that
the Knight is hanging
everybody use the emo of the person
you've been subscribed to the longest
but look she's an Entertainer she's not
focused on the chest but she's focused
on something
[Music]
wow lots of Hoss frogs Hoss frogs let me
convert you you're wasting your just
kidding
joking joking Hassan I like it this is
content I can get behind
what am I doing come on cutie oh yes yes
has that been there the whole time yes
yes it has oh
what am I doing yes thank you
that's so funny
she got it now now she sees no she's now
she's back in television she doesn't see
the bishop is hanging on F5 she could
have taken that's been there for so long
[Music]
by the way the Vibes are great music is
great thank you these dreams are always
alive it doesn't matter what she's doing
okay
just happy to be here
they take I don't have a way to take it
back so we don't do that although we
should talk about your Vibes a little
bit I think you guys could do a better
job of music selection you and Alexander
are open to feedback
excuse me you know I'm not just talking
I'm not just talking about this this
this new obsession with DJing you've
taken up I'm saying you guys could
choose more vibey music that's what I'm
saying well you have a different
definition of vibing my definition of
vibey is hard techno they go and that's
what I like
okay but you know it's okay my parents
also complain about my music taste so
you guys would get along on that one I
guess we would we get along a couple of
pages on a DJ set that's disco house
hits so you know you can
out of all
of almost any wrench this is that one
hit home oh man okay well I am I am
sorry I was just being honest again I
know the music is not my music and I
know it's similar honesty Danny the EDM
kind of house Vibe I get it sometimes it
works but sometimes it's just like like
make it a little more chill like cuties
right now can we go back to cutie stream
and do a music breakdown for Andrea here
you've been complimenting all over the
same time when we get a second we can
we're gonna we're gonna do it we're
gonna we're gonna talk about the music
here
[Laughter]
um
this is what I'm saying Andre let's
listen
[Music]
listen to me for five seconds Listen
Hold On
like when you're stuck on the elevator
the hell yeah exactly or having a nice
visit to the dentist's office I hate the
dentist office my terrible memories I
had six cavities in a root canal
I'm kidding um anyway it's different
Vibes for different flavors different
shoes you're buying I don't know
smooth jazz 95.5 Kyo so this is like on
the phone waiting music like this music
just reminds me of everything that I
hate in life then just waiting for
things elevators the more I listen the
more I agree with you let's think um
this is
yeah it's getting it's getting a little
too a little too far sleepy
um
test position does not falling sleepy
she is looking for the mates
she's doing good looking at Knight G5
and queen H5 trying to threaten on H7
and the only way black can defend is
Queen G7 and if she activates that dark
squared Bishop some some stuff could be
happening
she highlighted it last move now she's
going to the queen let's see if she goes
for Knight G5 oh she's back at it then
she goes for it
she's on it yes
nice Cutie's on it I was gonna say we
should unmute fusely so we can hear the
Best of Both Worlds here yeah let's
let's get a little let's get a little
mixtape a little foosly mixtape
but Houston's plan may work typically I
say don't go for these type of threats
but at a 600 level there's a chance
fusely doesn't see it
I just realized if we bring up the
fusely stream she's got a Vibe going on
in the other background I was only
looking at the lighting and the plants
now she's got something going on there
it's like some sort of before
oh it's a catcher okay I don't have cats
in fact I don't believe in cats much
more of a wrong person he hates music
hates okay well I don't know I can't
choose
I don't like animals that are smarter
than me and that's what cats are
because let me think it's that simple
by the way look at cutie look at cutie
she's all over it
oh no don't no don't do that there we go
yeah yeah okay that works that works
that works that works oh God okay Bingo
H6
don't don't play Rook FH and offend the
F1 I'm worried she's oh my God I'm
getting scared she's so worried about
the F1 if she plays Rook f8 to defend
the pawn she checkmates herself on H7
you never know what you might get very
honest
um okay that's a good move nope no
what if I go here I'm fascinated in the
way her brain works I have to say and
there's Knight takes H7 winning the
queen
and there we go
Judy is Judy's playing great chess here
she's more confident
unfortunately for Leslie it's it's
coming um
yeah
a good observation
oh Lord
Lucy is so great I think fusely is just
too much of a Pro Gamer
click and everything and touching
everything but you don't want to do that
in chess it's over yeah it's true
shall I do
I offer
oh no it's doomed
oh no
it went
if I feel like this reminds me so much
of pogchamps won the first podcast makes
me happy because she was fousey is just
like the best like always happy no
matter what was happening like just
never got frustrated or down and we got
the same Vibes here like I have to say
fusely saikuno you know their games have
been kind of one-sided but what I did
really notice and appreciate about them
is they always have a good attitude and
they're always Pleasant to watch but I
start losing a game I just start hating
and cursing out the world so Props to
them yeah
and legit Jess is hard I know sometimes
people are like they misinterpret think
we're making fun we're not we're having
fun with them everyone knows this is
tough like playing in a chess tournament
when you're not a professional chess
player is hard and a lot of them are
here alone you look at someone like xuc
you saw how how dedicated he's been
Andrea he was literally the joke of
pogchamps he's literally the video that
has been seen millions of times by
people for getting checkmated in six
moves and now look at him right that is
I'm just saying king of backhanded
compliments that I love it
you did well no no I just the joke of
Chess is very funny but I I totally
agree with you Danny his Improvement has
been amazing going forward how is that a
backhanded compliment I guess that the
joke of Chess just was funny maybe maybe
no no I mean no but
I didn't mean it like that I was calling
out what he said he's like look like I
understand how everyone inserts a six
move joke forevermore but I'm focused on
the future and he's gotten better no I
think you see I didn't understand what
he was saying half then interview so you
were just getting things that I wasn't
okay by the way we by the way we have to
bring up an analysis board real quick
while Andrea and I were talking about
backhanded compliments I think we might
have almost just had a win on the board
for foosli in this position
maybe it wasn't I thought I thought
there was I thought there was D3 check
almost and and I and I was like
hallucinating that there was that there
was Checkmate here okay but um but it
has happened physically has gotten like
many winning positions somehow when
she's completely lost like against Papa
plate gave his Queen not once but twice
she didn't take it and by the way the
fact that
just just because she didn't see D3
check doesn't mean the Cutie wouldn't
have played King H1 so there was almost
a chance there now Cutie's back on it
she takes the poem with check she's all
over it yeah it would be nice to see
the ceasing moves from fusely
but
yeah
let's let's go let's go see how cute
he's doing and see if she takes us home
I was not backhanded complimenting I was
not I was like the pop Champs no he well
he was writer think of the two how many
times did you see the video it's too
soon like
but look at him now
people might accuse me of playing with
my food but it's genuinely because I
don't know how to get a Checkmate faster
besides just cleaning up
true valid and fair
pancakes
[Music]
I'm simply not good enough to not it
looks like BM right now but I swear it's
not
let's see
it's like uh I don't know that's
probably some phrase that we don't
understand oh that was nice no we're not
Gamers you and I Andrea that's why
that's why the one thing I've learned
today
Bad Manners Bad Manners is what it is
Bad Manners I was gonna say bad news
badmins
I thought it was bowel movement so I'm
glad I didn't say that's probably
happening I'll try to get it I was like
damn I hate when my bowel movement hits
me mid chess game
this happens sometimes
uh yeah anyway so BM means Bad Manners
in gamer speak apparently I learned so
much there was another thing I learned
today
virtual it's a very interesting term but
you know it's completely escaped my head
like most things I learned I understand
and then they just whoop
s
even Animal Crossing why does it sound
like baby making music for representing
the IBS community
yep IBS you know what lactose is is
makes a lot of people have IBS you know
oh or the lactose came from
[Music]
lactose intolerant a lot of people are
you lashes I'm not I'm trying to be kind
to groups instead of judging them
because you can tell me I'm judging
everybody ah no I'm really glad you're
defending the lactose
they've been really under attack lately
and they need someone to vent for them
it's been really hard with almond milk
and soy milk yeah it's not an easy life
okay cutie gave it check she's doing
good she's doing good
take the Rook yeah
you should okay okay she wanted to give
a check that works
okay it's going good but again fousey's
gonna be in good spirits we'll see what
she can do when she has the white pieces
I'm speaking too soon because cutie is
not out of the realm if she moves her no
don't exactly okay there we go
I feel like that's the mistake she made
last name she just started sacking
thinking it was over like don't do that
coordinating make it done quicker
foreign
like there's a cat looking into a mug I
don't know I this feels like BM I swear
to you I really don't know how to make
it done quicker
you know if she really wanted to yeah
I'm in Flex on how she should remove the
pawn all the way till the end and then
remember G7 and then pre-move actually
that could pull a Ludwig and move to
stalemate yeah oh no now she should take
the performance check oh
she's going to wrist stalemating the
more pieces she adds to the board
luckily the light squares B5 and B7 are
still
undefended so yeah but now if she takes
if she takes that pawn and it's not
checked oh wait I didn't want a queen
I usually change those into wires
go to YouTube to watch Omegle oh my God
if she
if she plays
oh my God it's stalemate if she's moved
to another piece
no
that is I feel like she's throwing I
feel like she's throwing yeah I feel
like she's purposely throwing like this
I'm gonna confront her about this like I
legit I think she's throwing I'm not
getting out of hand but you know what
promise to foosli for scoring a draw my
girl fusley she's been kind of having a
rough day so you know what let's go
foosli play till the end I agree with
chat like what in the actual just was
Bishop C1 yeah someone needs to teach
her how to checkmate
she's throwing for Content uh yeah
you're she should feel I feel like she
is I'm Legit wondering every Chatters
points right now because everyone went
so heavy voting on cutie which yeah it
was pretty easy mode but um wow yeah now
they're changing they're like 10K
Channel points fusely comes back and
wins it at this point I would bet on
fusely too all right that was that was
absolutely wild that was wild I I don't
like Andre I called it I saw C6 I was
like uh oh if she takes C6 and it's not
check it's gonna be stalemate I could I
could see it coming
and it makes me wonder if she's throwing
where was she going with the bishop like
why touch the bishop when you've got who
Queen
Queen cutie has a thing that a lot a lot
of players who struggle with confidence
this is a real thing instead of like
getting through their confidence block
by like all right let me solve this they
try to just avoid ways to go wrong and
so her mindset was literally let me get
the bishop out of the way because that
makes it easier to think you get what
I'm saying instead of solving for the
problem she's trying to avoid ways to
make mistakes which is a way to get
stalemate it actually is a thing people
do
and I'm not trying to play therapist but
it is a very common thing you see that's
right
you were clearly a therapist in another
life I think that that analysis is
honestly spot on and she also just had a
lot of time she just just needed to take
her time and when you have so many
pieces on the board and the King has
nowhere to go you stop and think and you
look for checks you need to get like uh
you know there's like a levy Gotham bot
that talks in your voice when you're
getting along time we need one for Cutie
whenever she's winning just say stop and
think and just look for checks yeah like
you solve for the problem by trying to
think through it not by avoiding ways
because you don't trust yourself and you
think you're gonna go wrong and again I
get it the insecurity but like you can't
solve it that way and like I think you
just gave a really good piece of advice
Andrea you should at least keep checking
keep checking because if you check
there's likely less chance of a
stalemate yeah and I just want to say
Danny you were right Chad is saying she
actually said her thought process and
that it was and that was it so I stopped
Danny the psychologist
can you diagnose all my issues I have a
lot of a money I mean honestly I can't
you know we had a great chocolate at
dinner that night whatever you know we
can talk about I don't even remember
when we died the streamers Bowl we were
talking about uh with you and Alex we
were talking about something with some
deep life talks actually I don't
remember any of them but I remember it
was everything
super deep yeah that was a good dinner
all right well good talk and all right
London typical
happy to see a London in POG jams
um but kind of when fusely plays it it
almost offends me because everything
goes so well and she gets an amazing
position but then she doesn't take the
winning move so I hope this game and
what's so funny this identical thing
happened last time they do the copycat
Strat and it went pretty well for
foosleep against Papa plate but it looks
like we have another copycat game
agreed especially if Knight F6 is played
we're in almost full copycam mode but
it's because cutie was taught the
Stonewall so she's trying to do it at
both both white and black fusely was
taught to London so she's going to do it
no matter what her opponent does and you
kind of called yourself out so I'm gonna
double down on it and say one of the one
of the problems with London players is
they tend to be very like you know horse
with blinders on system oriented right
and it's the same mistake we saw cutie
make with the Stonewall like the problem
I have with coaches who teach people
systems is you're literally killing
their critical thinking skills because
instead of telling them to solve for the
opening and actually look they're like
no no you can play this against no
matter what they play that's literally a
selling point is you can play this
against no matter what they play and it
makes them feel all warm and cozy and
then it kills their ability to solve the
critical position I'm calling out Gotham
I'm calling out Andrea stop teaching
people the London so first I didn't
teach London but second I have to say
all right Daniel to my music and I was
like but the truth is what Danny said is
so accurate and one of the reasons that
I had been like hard stuck at 2000 is
because I didn't learn any other
openings because of London still haven't
learned any other openings
um but because of that I kind of only
learned one type of chest position and I
couldn't think in different type of
positions and then I started doing
lessons with Dina and she started giving
me other positions and it felt like I
discovered A Whole New World
um so honestly I think I have to agree
with that and I'm really roasting myself
on that I do agree
this is this has gotten deep we've
gotten deep that I wasn't expecting to
go so deep
all right
open because I'm a master profile
Progresso it's okay but ultimately no
I'll be real to stay on the coaching
ultimately you can solve this without
fixing the London the point is Andrea
you can improve the parts of the system
player that build weaknesses in their
muscles you can improve them with things
like you're doing with Dina like looking
at positions re retraining your brain
but the problem is that that type of
approach to the opening kills a muscle
you really want players developing at an
early stage so you can fix it without
changing the London that's why the
London gets a bad rap but that's my
problem with it is is what it does there
so there you go
anyway we're back to the chest this is
great and it's also like the only
opening in fog chips where people just
do the copycat system
um but we have gotten a little bit of
astray let's see who
he is with the black pieces right yes
cuties with black pieces yeah night on
the rim we've had this this rhyme come
up a few times today and at that point I
don't know why people don't remember it
they're clearly not watching this
commentary right on the rim is them I
don't know why we keep doing it there's
I guess technically never mind actually
she's kind of Genius I take everything
back she would have went 97 we would
have fallen for Knight takes F7 beauty
is actually a genius I'm sorry night on
the rim is them was not bad
yep well we
let's see like the whole world pool I
don't know he took us on a ride yeah I I
I caught myself mid thought let's let's
go look at firstly stream
all right
this is getting dangerous
yeah but she oh look at how she stopped
the threat right away Queen H4 was
played and she stopped it that's good
I'm out of water
something has to be done it's a little
bit spicy that's true I need to learn
from you
I swear it's gonna happen
yep she might
Queen H3 and then maybe bringing in that
light squared Bishop but fusely could
play Bishop F1
yeah and that Queen could actually get
in trouble if you do that oh my God
relax why is it so scary why is she
freaking
awesome Bishop F1 would trap the queen
for the record okay Andrea was right you
spotted it first Bishop F1 traps the
queen okay so what
dude Bruce Lee is the queen of having
free Queens on the board
no shit's given
she's The anti-botesquez Gambler what I
was gonna say yeah because the solution
to all of my problems she's the editor
oh man
well she is attacking the knights you
got to give her that okay
well and technically that move still
works
but I don't think she's gonna be looking
for it because now the queen can only go
to H4 H5 then you would push G forward
and then the queen goes he's six and
then you're in oh no I really want to
date that piece
what's funny is there's so many things
that could go wrong with this position
but I'm trying to anticipate like the
POG Champs move and
anything open I should do that more
often anticipate the podcast move she's
gonna just blunder her knife
I was gonna say I don't know that she
sees the bishop trade I don't think she
does into the center I called it I'm
moment
well it is a fork yeah that's true that
was a good move Fork
true foreign
true Fork that's a show coming to HBO
like True Blood true Fork it's like a
chess show where like bad things happen
uh wait no don't do that you're gonna
Checkmate yourself on G2 it happen and
um
yeah it would have been nice if we saw
Bishop F1 wow wait how is this 36 going
to defend this spot how did this win
this is so I see
it's still Bishop Bishop one still traps
the queen maybe she'll see it because
she has to now the bishop is being
attacked so she has to go bowties dude
right she's the anti-votech but now she
has pizza she has to see it now I don't
think she will Danny I don't think she
will
feel like she's just gonna go like
Bishop E2
come on fusely this is the moment we
have all been waiting for
just we've all been waiting for I was
rooting for cutie but I think even if he
was waiting she's gonna throw for
Content anyway so now I'm rooting for
food
right
you were right you were right you called
it I wish I wasn't
I wish I wasn't
I wish I was wrong they
I know
there though like I
either
and but I don't think she's gonna think
about it like it's still there we should
nope we should go back to the main board
just so we can appreciate that the eval
bar is literally having a heart attack
every single move is a complete
evaluation change of the position
watch this ready
every single move
the evil bar can't even keep up because
it's trying to analyze the live position
back then it was here
then it was here then it was here
then it was this
it was that
and then it was there oh he's still up
there right now
and then
just having fun yep
you
chest has been really dry these days so
we've just invented our own game chat
we'll keep asking for the next match but
we just made this instead
oh wait hold on we've got liftoff
firstly keeps the email for two moves in
a row
who still has Bishop F1 I know she
doesn't I lied it's gone never mind
Queen goes stage five
but the eval bar stayed in this position
for two moves in a row I think that was
a record for the game chat that was it
so Bruce Lee keeps the advantage
she's keeping the pressure
bad we
tipping our feet
and not backwards so
I'll take this from loosely
cutie now might get baited into taking
the pawn um but I guess the knight's not
really trapped 93 is just gonna give a
pawn
Lucy's got a good position like she
might accidentally win this game without
like realizing if she walks into
something that's true I think it's going
to take an accidental Win For Cutie to
win too like I think like
the it's gonna be accidental for either
side true
cutie still has a nice threat on G2 at
night is they're defending but if she
could just get her Bishop in or
something to attack the G2 Square be a
nice mate
agree town
you guys want to hear what's fusely
saying sure
bring her on yeah let's do it
I was trying to add Andrea's face to G2
before we went away there you go number
one
it's sending us a message
um but I want to make sure that's not a
big blunder because
um am I gonna lose a piece anywhere like
uh can her Bishop do something can her
Queen do something I feel like that's
kind of the big the big brain play here
it's just kind of like hey
you know what I mean
there's no way that's a mistake I think
there's just no way
all right she did it
I don't think cutie sees this whole idea
of the light squares anymore so I think
she's struggling to find a plan
yep I mean I'm also you said she did it
which I don't know what Loosely is doing
with this move but
ah
is okay now you know maybe even white
might get an axle made on G7 her Knight
is under attack
could go attack The Rook
um it's kind of
well actually
let's go see what cutie thinks about
this she's down a piece she's getting
attacked yeah no fusely made a good
night move there
we get too drunk
there's The Vibes I hear The Vibes of
the music I kind of want to just go like
this
it's a good move the Knight takes oh duh
the Queen's hanging right right you're
right I mean it's actually not a good
move but for POG Champs I think it is a
taxi Lucy would have to bring the queen
all the way back to attack the Knight
like on A3 I think or something and then
it's why did I say tours
he's on F6 oh
there you go
I think it's on F6 check open
she might accidentally wait I don't know
what yours what is this content people
do they've got
oh my God the Subway Surfer me oh oh it
was a Dono it is um the content of Our
Generation we've all become so ADHD that
all of our expenses need to be
stimulated at once so people need like
five things going on and I very much is
going to cater to this trend God
it's it's really I mean
all right I'm not gonna go full Boomer
on this it's just no I agree with you
it's not healthy I I
I'm gonna say it it reminds me of my
childhood and it brings back trauma
hahaha
kind of watching Subway Surfers I know
like I can't look away I don't watch the
Jazz anymore I've never been one to fall
for the bait but I think I've just
fallen for the bait and she's eating all
these coins and she's going so fast and
she's so good if she hasn't lost yet
she's still going
what if she's actually playing
there's no way this does not hurt right
no there's no way she's actually her
friends aren't even touching the board
there's no way okay
it's so good
by the way Judy did find a fork on D3
and the reason this is actually super
powerful
is because fusely would have to see a
retreating move which is Bishop takes D3
and retreating moves are super hard for
players of this level right the bishop
on B5 has to go I'm see I didn't mean
that as like another backhanded
compliment I was laughing at chat going
you can literally see the YouTube video
in fact we can see on the board it
happened
we came back to the live board and
that's exactly what happened foosli took
on f8 and lost her Queen and cutie is in
control
Kitty's driving the bus
well
yeah I know Lucy had a very cool tactic
Knight takes F6 earlier in that position
um but now the Queens are off the board
so see if cutie finds that mating
pattern on G2
yeah accidental mating pattern
let's do it Beauty in the front
Bishop into the light squares come on
let's do it let's hear what foosli's
saying
yeah I don't think fousey's too thrilled
that she lost her Queen and let's go
let's go
let's check in on her
let's see maybe uh
oh man it's she's in another Fork she's
got all kinds of fork problems
I can threaten her Knights oh
Andrea I don't know why but somehow I
blame you for this game I don't even
know why it doesn't make any sense
it's the subconscious in me about the
London talk we had I think it's just me
needing to get out my feelings that
she's gonna take it you know I'm still
so frustrated with the London
has got there the execution was not and
you would have learned the money from
the right coach maybe it would have been
a different story
yeah well all right okay uh now we've
got Rook D7 on the board and we go but
don't forget
she still made it last game guys
but this is the working fusely Strat
yeah still make time chats all over
you're right
this is going to be a match Andre that's
going to go to tie breaks because of
another stalemate and it's going to
become down to life actually somebody's
accidentally gonna win
figures tell me I just want you guys to
know I haven't eaten since 10 30 a.m I
get very hangry and you don't want to
yeah but you're drinking enough water
down so I better see your Checkmate I
will not be here any of course it's
gonna take over a commentary okay look
she sees this idea okay good she didn't
see what the question
okay good she's replaced the pieces with
the bishop this is actually really
really nice by cutie look at that yeah
she's literally walking her into it or
right there right there ladies and
gentlemen
it's all over it come on just don't stop
checking don't stop checking make sure
we get well the thing about beauty is
she doesn't know how to
know how to finish the game
I don't know I don't know what's gonna
happen and I'm getting very nervous and
I might have to pull in Hikaru and I'm
worried you're getting hungry you know
how much I mean you've drink enough
water to fill a lake
um I mean this is
okay
this is now in this is now an oblique
territory here now she's taken she's
literally created the stalemate you
I actually think that someone is paying
her and there's no no if she does this
again I'm gonna I'm gonna lose it like I
will not be
striking and protesting and I am living
and you don't want to see this happen
watching
come on cutie come on cutie just no
don't do it again just check her she
knows how to check me she just doesn't
watching settings she's literally doing
this on purpose
it to turn into a queen okay she's going
to change your settings how much time
does she have okay it's a check box
she knows what she's doing chat
[Music]
but if you don't want a queen then why
are you doing this you're just gonna get
more chances
I just feel like at this point this is
some cruel plan by chess.com just to
keep me here just the auto turned into a
queen one last time I would be so into
that I would be so into that but that's
not what we're doing it seems like some
sort of cruel prank oh first you guys
to come in and out and then Danny gets
stopping but no you must sit through and
watch all of this ah all she has to do
is get a queen with check if she gets a
queen with check she found it we need
okay she gets agree with check this is
gonna be it good she's gonna do it any
check is mate
[Applause]
I don't get it I don't get it I don't
get it I don't get it
right I don't get it I
good
I don't understand
I sat here and I changed it why why it's
not the auto Queen you still made it why
I pushed save it's not on what I'm going
to get some water and a snack
I'm not coming back
[Music]
I feel I don't know it's a draw because
I have no legal moves either that's all
I know because I literally couldn't do
anything but like it's I don't know you
just have to
I mean I I'll take it I'll take it
commentators are involting
from all of the test Community you guys
have ruined hashtag Grove the game and I
shall never return to a podcast and I
you call him
foreign
good news Chad I got some applesauce
everyone's gonna be okay
where are we at what are we doing
this is unbelievable
you guys have ruined the game
all right everybody we're going to a tie
break cutie is white and I'm gonna
explain the rules to you the person who
had the more accurate chest which is
going to be mind-blowing to find out by
the way I can't wait to see it we'll get
white so we're gonna find out who played
the more accurate brand of chest between
Judy and fusely the time control is
three minutes plus five seconds per move
so three minutes base time and five
seconds added back for every move if
we're still tied which unfortunately
given the stalemate Trend that we're on
is a very real possibility we hope Andre
is going to be okay uh we will swap
colors and do it again and uh yeah we
just rinse and repeat this until it's
over
um I've actually stopped using shampoo
that fights dandruff because it has a
lot of chemicals and it's not good for
your scalp so I'm not gonna I'm actually
not gonna suggest that you rinse and
repeat anymore ever again in my life
um I'm joined by my co-host nicara
Nakamura who uh
honestly I I hope Andre is okay hope
she's getting a snack Hikaru welcome
here buddy this is uh you're back at it
man you're back out I literally don't
care
you don't care and I get it well you're
you're joining us in between games from
Baku we do wish you the best of luck
um at the World Cup but what is the
world is happening here we have we have
cutie Cinderella purposely throwing for
Content or so it seems yeah
[Laughter]
I broke the camera
I've broken it I've broken it
this is the second
I don't know how to fix it just hold it
up in my house it's really hot Andre
[Laughter]
you know
everything's crumbling I can't take me
off I can't do this anymore
I can't do it I lost my mind where is
your big sister where where is your big
sister to help you guys I broke the gate
I broke
no I don't think I need a second give me
a moment take me off the screen okay
okay I need to go okay I need to stop
yelling at everybody go get your big
sister she'll help you she'll help you
it won't go back
yeah I don't know how to fix the zoom
I'm
I think Andrea's coming back here any
moment
um
Judy is getting ready for her game
is she from oh she's not frozen cutie
just nodded her head I literally thought
she was frozen for a second because she
was so shocked
is somebody
is somebody paying cutie
there's some somebody paying cutie to uh
to throw games that's the question
because we've never seen anything like
him
we're back on the air
[Music]
nice
thing
let me chess
I'm ready to guess
let me check and you're back Andrea is
back [__] hang on no you're back we're
good no I know it's just my zoom that's
okay
the one thing I didn't do in that whole
Fiasco was I didn't use the bathroom so
now I just wait
oh wow well that that seems like right
what's going on
what I miss um
um everything nothing's going on we just
started the game
um we had the greatest moments of
pogchamps history and now we are uh
there's a fly on my head please bring me
on camera so that we can prove it
big forehead and I saw it straight in
the middle and you know every time he's
complaining about fruit flies we don't
believe him I saw that thing it was real
and then by the time production got to
it flew away it's here it's here it's
just torturing me it's torturing me it's
actually crazy that was the coolest
thing I've ever seen there's a giant fly
I'm like thanks for calling my forehead
giant not that I didn't hear that you
know me too we're big forehead gang why
do you think we're so smart that's why
we're friends
cutie has got white Andrea we have
liftoff we have Blitz I think somebody's
gonna accidentally win this match I
think it's gonna happen
yeah I hope someone figures out how to
Checkmate how many POG Champs game does
for us to learn the Checkmate because
like typically stalemates the harder
mate to learn but it feels like our
students are just ahead of the Curve
yeah
I'm uh
I'm hoping I'm hoping that cutie isn't
throwing and there isn't some side bet
between her and someone about it because
you didn't give any explanation or what
she did we're gonna talk to her no she
didn't she didn't give anything we
didn't we didn't zoom into her audio but
we will we will be zooming in and
getting getting some some clarification
on her behavior and what she's doing
here
um all right let's see what is
wait a second who Okay cuties wait
cuties playing the white pieces dude if
fusely ends up winning this match first
cutie this
[Laughter]
and I accidentally happened
no honestly no okay she didn't she
didn't play it but rookie three was it
was really good that was that was the
best fake call for checkmate what you
just did was the equivalent of someone
yelling like gold when it's not a goal
which is amazing
um I've never I you know I always see
videos of Gotham chess commenting like
that's all a bunch of [__] and no
one gets that excited about Chess but
that was my soul coming out of my body
like that was not fake that so I I
understand now maybe it isn't enough
yeah it people get that excited about
Chess I mean I've been suffering from
PTSD with chess moves my whole life I
mean I freak out I can't hold it back
all right here we go Queen D6
okay now that I look at the eval bar
white is winning I didn't count that
we're up not one not two but three minor
pieces don't cancel us minor pieces
three miners I don't know man I feel
like fusely is gonna like make three
three my three miners three miners on a
chessboard Andrea there we go three
months I mean I I'm trying to think of a
joke for people who don't know what
minor pieces are three miners okay King
G3
changes
[__] [__]
Judy is walking herself in wait wait
okay no it's a freak I keep seeing
things but there's a queen I thought
quenchy
no cutie is walking herself into
Checkmate basically she's
take the queen no again don't try again
oh my God now she has done it now she
has done it she's walked in to mate if
Queen takes G2 and we take on H1 black
is winning but I don't think she's gonna
see Queen takes Sichuan I think she's
gonna see the pawn we got she did it
she's like we think she too oh my God
cutie it's funny I don't know where to
lose this there's no there's no [__]
way
there's no forking way
let's go to fousey's game I don't think
she's gonna see it she's
let's go see if Lucy can find it come on
come on [__] someone's gotta win it's
Gotta Be You Cutie's not gonna do it
and then say I check again
that's also not the worst but it's not
good but it does the job here
don't go there
oh that doesn't do it you can do here I
feel like uh there's gotta be something
yeah there is there's a rook that was
not it that just was not it
but I'm freaking out about the time
yeah it's just freaking out about the
time
just take the night cutie I don't even
think fusely sees that she can take your
queen something here
here I gotta be able to move my Rook I
Something's Gonna
by the way
by the way we do all hope hikara was
okay
um well he's not he's bent over and he's
all broken inside inside and outside
okay she sees it she sees it she sees
the queen yeah but I don't know if this
is enough Danny I don't think this is
good enough no no that's too much
you can't trust anyone these days
play with your feelings
I don't either God it's all gone wrong
this is the worst because now we're back
in there
yeah
exactly that's the problem is now we're
back
this is a never-ending game
if Judy stalemates again like can we get
a vote can we get a chat poll will Judy
Cinderella stalemate for a third time in
a row breaking POG Champs hit records in
history in the process let's get him
let's get her pull
having all the pieces on the board when
she doesn't know how to use them she
just gives them away or cutie who is
very capable of winning this and will
get in a winning position but then
doesn't know how to check me
maybe this is just like the internal
Eternal torture
yeah maybe that's where we are maybe
we're in purgatory maybe maybe this
maybe that's what happened yeah that
could be it that could be it could be
the end
everything about it you haven't been
able to go to the bathroom for hours
right we haven't let you eat it's like
all your fears realize I've been
criticizing the London right we've been
this is my worst nightmare this is just
a giant fever dream okay
uh okay okay
we're officially back
now we're back
to me for Cutie come on these things
don't happen wait [__] Cutie's playing
the white pieces [__] yeah yeah we're
right to Rooney for Cutie that's what
I'm saying cutie takes the Run
we need to get on dress food everybody
can we get Andrea some food seeing
things Daddy it's been a long day
um Alex hasn't been in town and
we are we're in the Cutie Paradox this
is oh my God we're stuck third tries to
charm chat third tries to charge don't
take all the pieces cutie just check
check and see what the spawns there
they're not doing anything to you
there's no need to go attack them
they're harmless they're Pawns they're
barely worth anything
Andre I think she's got it I think she's
gonna figure it out
I think I think she knows the Rook
roller mate no he knows he's defending
her Rooks no matter where they go so ah
yes she's got it come on come on
we're gonna be free Dobby is a free elf
okay oh no all right one more move she's
gonna go to eat and it's gonna prevent
rookie okay we're almost there yes yes
there you wait oh God The Bishop's
taking away another king this is getting
dangerous okay we're okay no she's got
it yeah she is free yay I'm in Rio
yay oh thank God
oh my God that was the cuties looking to
the side she knows
Kitty you committed a monstrous crime
today and I hope you know what you put
us through today I'm [__]
she's 400 rated
don't slander the 400s like that they
worked hard to get there Tyler one's
still 200 you know
cutie Cinderella takes the match by
final score of two to one everybody
Welcome to pog Champs if you uh didn't
know what it was about I think you
learned today and Andrea we just saw the
most
POG champsiest match in the history of
POG Champs
you wake me up and
Irving it kind of
kind of like hey Carter however he's
gone he's not coming back to life I I
lost my cardboard cutout for that match
so I hope it was worth it I hope this is
what cutie wanted what she put me
through but is that what you want cutie
she just wanted to are you happy now
that you wanted I'm so glad she finally
found a Checkmate somewhere Robert has
this peacefully probably has no idea
what the hell is going on but he would
finally be proud
let's see where we're at the standings
um we may or may not have interviews
coming up with these players everybody
so don't go anywhere but here we go
cutie Cinderella gets it done she gets
two points fusi gets one remember
because it was a tie-break victory
fusely also gets a point so as as
awkward as that all feels right it was
as awkward for us as it was for you it
was a Victoria State because I have a
lot of streamer friends sakuno and Ginny
who keep telling I keep checking in on
them after seeing them I'm like hey guys
you okay you hate chess like let me help
you and they're like no I just want to
win one game so now fusely is out of the
loser kids club she's gotta win that
just leaves you saikuno and Ginny to
take home the dubs and then we could
call it a successful POG champ well
firstly firstly one of the first POG
Champs too so foosa's been there she's
taking the dubs and even though she
didn't actually win here she got two
draws but all right we are headed toward
a break everybody there is cutie
Cinderella freaking out with her big jug
and uh we're gonna be back with some
interviews in just a moment don't go
anywhere
[Music]
oh
the the check king of the king and the
queen of six right
Daddy it's not me I said don't play
Queen F6
oh my gosh oh my God
oh my God
yes come on your subscription makes
shows like this possible which is why
our twitch subscribers will never see
ads on chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Masters can then lose 10 pounds and burn
6 000 calories just by sitting yeah so
I've actually been spending a lot of
time getting in shape wow that's great
what are you doing mostly like Rook
lifts oh I've never heard of that it's a
thing don't look it up
[Music]
thank you
two one here we go
[Music]
three two one here we go
POG Champs five if that wasn't the most
POG champiest of Champs days POG day I
don't even know what to say then I don't
know what was we just saw Judy
Cinderella beat foosli in a 2-1
tiebreaker where
um I'm not gonna lie ladies it didn't
feel like either one of you wanted to
win cutie are you throwing for content
to be honest
dude why does it auto turn into a queen
I don't want a queen
yeah neither did fusely based on those
gameplay
I went back on the review after I saw
there was a couple opportunities
Bruce Lee not one not two every game
listen ladies I'm here to help obviously
I know I sent you a text I said hey
fousey what a chess lesson no answer no
I didn't see it I didn't see it yeah no
yeah I'm sure I did it cutie I would I
would gladly teach you how to Checkmate
but it seems like Gotham got that
territory covered
we're getting scolded listen Leslie and
I have been at a camp we've been camping
yeah
I'm sure I've practiced every single
night I have an ALT account that I
practice on I do 100 puzzles a day it
doesn't
there's no point there's just no point
so but I do have a point you're not as
confident as you should be go ahead go
ahead you go no I'm just happy to be on
the board that's it that's all I want I
just have there's a blaring zero next to
my name every time I looked at the
standings and I just no one needs to
know how I got that point no one needs
to know how it happened cutie just it's
there and I'll take it honestly you've
got to experience I just wanted to give
foosli that point thank you so much
you're so generous
no I'm happy for you guys you must be
really in love because no one wanted to
beat the other one
but it was it was awesome
yeah you guys made pogchamps history so
we'll call it a historic day
you did thank you cutie you were you
were trying you were trying to avoid
stalemate and that's what made Stillman
I'm not trying to go coach mode but you
were like you were trying to solve the
problem by avoiding ways to go wrong
instead of like taking your time to just
solve for checkmate because you were
very close and I think I think if you
get more confidence you you would you
would just Checkmate instead of trying
to avoid going wrong like with the queen
that would be my advice who gives a
flying bleep what I have to say I'm just
saying it that's all
I am excited to okay good night yeah
play again
someday all right tomorrow tomorrow
firstly welcome back it's it's been a
minute from POG Champs one so what got
you back in POG Champs and please tell
me it wasn't just Ludwig
Ludwig asks multiple times and I said no
no chess is stressful and he said no no
wrong answer
and then I said okay fine so uh yeah I'm
happy to be back this was very
reminiscent of my math first Nate Hill
uh where it was just like a blunderfest
like we just like kept missing each
other's queens and whatnot it was a
disaster I think that also ended in
stalemate or something like that a draw
for sure
on H7
yes I did get some a win somewhere in
there but this was reminiscent Good
Times Obviously is there anyone you're
looking forward to playing in the
consolation bracket I think one of your
roomies you will be going face to face I
think you guys wait actually
yeah
yes yes well I'm facing him well you
will soon because you guys have a very
close score so what do you think between
the two of you
um yesterday we all we played and we
save it with stalemate as well he had
three queens and couldn't finish the
game so maybe something like we will be
looking forward I will make sure we hire
Hikaru for that commentary I think we
need to get a GM to cover that game
all right cutie you gotta beat Papa plot
and regulation to move on to the
championship bracket this is it I know
it I know you're gonna do it you can't
even check me I don't know what's going
on
embarrassed
honestly
the other way to look at it is that you
played fantastic chess and you just
struggled to put it away you were
winning right so you're gonna get a good
game against Papa plot and you're gonna
win actually yeah speaking of like
actual tips cutie when you have all
these good positions all you need to do
well first if they have pawns just leave
the pawns don't touch them they're
harmless they're not working worth
anything but just look for forcing moves
we're just checks just try to constantly
look for checks
foreign
have you had any tips for me as well to
improve oh yeah yeah no you you also had
a lot of good tactics in front of you
but you're
you had a lot of chances to take free
pieces free queens and I think if we
were to go through the big three every
move which is what are the checks what
are the captures and what are the queen
attacks you would find better so like
every move is like what are my checks
what are my captures and can I attack
their Queen same thing if you go through
that list
if you go through that list you would
have won like 20 Queens just force
yourself to look for attacks and
captures those are what we call forcing
moves and honestly for both of you
ladies that would help the game so much
because you you guys somehow walk into
these genius positions where like you're
setting something up you gotta make
coming you got a tactic you have to
force yourself to look for the attacks
and sometimes they're counter-intuitive
it's like you're bringing a piece back
that's why you really have to try to
consider every move and also it's okay
to take your time and play a little bit
slower because you can decide the game
much earlier on
okay noted all right checks maybe
checks and captures just go through that
list there you go and a couple puzzle
rush just to warm up those are always
good all the rushes are good that helps
the pattern recognition and they make
them and they're actually fun they're
only five minutes try to do like two or
three those are good that's your
homework for the day
every day sounds good thank you all
right okay cutie we'll we'll we'll see
you tomorrow with Papa plot foosli
you're uh you're on track I think I've
got you against kaikuno don't tell him I
said that but I think I think you're the
favorite there so thank you so I'm the
favorite I'll take it thank you yep I
won't let you down for sure all right
all right if you want to learn how to
Checkmate you have my number
thank you you know what's crazy for that
one I'm I'm a thousand rated on my alt
account and I can't even beat Leslie
it's crazy
yeah you're there I quit I'm good no
you're not no you're gonna win tomorrow
you're gonna get it okay all right
bye everybody all right bye guys bye
everyone see you soon goodbye
all right
here's our group standings this this was
a day quite a day quite the day quite
the day quite the day
recapping the day speaking of quite the
day we uh well at the beginning we had
Judy Cinderella and I did a thing or at
least the beginning of when I joined I'm
sorry
um and then of course it was all a blur
and I don't remember anything Danny you
have to okay yes
and it was hot we broke daily dose you
resigned when he was really doing
totally fine
I believe in Judy but I will also say
I've been impressed with Papa plot
there's Alex I did a thing freaking out
again with his Australian accent
um straight up
get a little bit of water
and then next you see we did put on a
suit he washed his hair today I didn't
get to ask him about the giraffe which
was unfortunate that was on my to-do
list but then he came back in a suit and
I forgot I was gonna learn how to make
how to make
those were our four winners
um those were our those were our winners
that we saw there everybody in Reverse
chronological order Andrea I think the
real winner today was everybody who
learned
um
about the London that's that that was
what this show was about let's not talk
about no no one needs to know about the
London honestly who cares about the
London like
another
race let's take a look at tomorrow's
matches you're gonna be here Andrea
oh who's joining me yeah I don't even
know I know I'm taking a break
um
oh this is we're gonna be a disaster
because no one's gonna hold down the
fort between me and Anna
and then xqc versus Tyler if you had
other planes like I am literally I will
be reorganizing my schedule to watch
that match despite the fact that Felix
is going to take it in a 2-0 2-0
domination it's still going to be fun to
watch like I've seen what Tyler does
when he wins I don't want to know what
he'll do when he loses and xqc is
looking really sharp I hate to say it
but I think xcc is going to destroy
Tyler one and I'm I'm a little bit
scared for that game I agree I agree all
right well you don't want to miss the
match tomorrow between xqc and Tyler one
and you also don't want to miss your
chance to use the command drops and get
yourself a diamond membership it's super
easy through August 11th it's the summer
of Chess thanks for twitch for just
promoting chess we didn't know why they
did it I mean I don't even know what's
going on here but here's the deal all
you have to do is use the command drops
you can connect your account at
chess.com you can link up your Twitch
and chess.com accounts and you can get
yourself two free weeks of Premium
actually a whole month of Premium I
think if if you've watched two hours of
Chess no it's two weeks it's two weeks
of Premium if you watch two hours of
Chess in the entire category that's a
pretty sweet deal Andrea no more free
premium memberships for you
yeah I totally zoned out but yeah
command drops in the chat which comes
through August 11th do something to
claim I literally just blanked out you
literally didn't even hear that I I
insulted you at the end of that I
insulted you didn't even notice I'm so
sorry
but okay let's Andrea let's get some
food I want you to get some food once
you take a break get outside that's what
you're gonna do that's your homework
okay you're gonna get outside get some
food fix it fix it broken and then
you're gonna have a great time with POG
Champs tomorrow and I will be watching
from home good night everybody you guys
tomorrow if I make it
embarrassing
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
all the way
foreign
[Music]
thank you
one
here we go
thank you
foreign